foreign
welcome to this video tutorial on
machine learning projects by simply
learn
in this video we'll cover some of the
crucial topics related to machine
learning and explore the different
algorithms that are widely used to solve
machine learning tasks and then we look
at several machine learning projects
which are very interesting so here is
the agenda for today's session
we will Begin by learning the basics of
machine learning and then we will
explore about linear regression analysis
followed by logistic regression with
Hands-On demo sessions in Python next
we'll understand about decision tree and
random Forest after that we are going to
learn about support Vector machines K
nearest neighbors and k-means clustering
with Hands-On demo and Python
programming moving ahead we'll learn how
to predict coronavirus cases using
several algorithms in machine learning
next we'll explore about the stock
market analysis and then we'll look at
an exploratory data analysis about the
world happiness report followed by
understanding how you can use election
data to make United States election
prediction we will wind up this session
by learning about time series in R and
then we look at German credit and
College admission project what
get ahead today we're covering what is
machine learning what's in it for you
we're going to cover the basics of
machine learning what is machine
learning artificial intelligence versus
machine learning versus deep learning
how does machine learning work types of
machine learning machine learning
prerequisites applications of machine
learning here we have our um it looks a
little bit like Frankenstein our
Frankenstein looking robot today let me
tell you what is machine learning
machine learning works on the
development of computer programs that
can access data and use it to
automatically learn and improve from
experience watch a robot builder
construct a house in two days this was
back in July 29th
2016. so that's pretty impressive this
amount of time to continue to grow in
its development and it's smart enough to
leave spaces in the brickwork for wiring
and plumbing and can even cut and shape
bricks to size
Amazon Echo relies on machine learning
and with more data it becomes more
accurate play your favorite music order
pizza from Domino's voice control your
home request rides from Uber have you
ever wondered the difference between AI
machine learning and deep learning
artificial intelligence a technique
which enables machines to mimic human
behavior this is really important
because this is how we are able to gauge
how well our computations or what we're
working on works is the fact that we're
mimicking human behavior we're using
this to replace human work and make it
more efficient and make it more
streamlined and more accurate and so the
center of artificial intelligence is the
big picture of all this put together IBM
deep blue chess electronic game
characters those are just a couple
examples of artificial intelligence
machine learning a technique which uses
statistical methods enabling machines to
learn from their past data so this means
if you have your input from last time
and you have your answer you use that to
help prove the next guess it makes for
the correct answer IBM Watson Google
search algorithm email spam filters
these are all part of machine learning
and then deep learning which is a subset
of machine learning composing algorithms
that allow a model to trade itself and
perform tasks alphago natural speech
recognition these are a couple examples
deep learning is associated with tools
like neural networks where it's kind of
a black box as it learns it changes all
these things that are as a human we
would have a very hard time tracking and
it's able to come up with an answer from
that now let's see how machine learning
works first we start with training the
data once we've trained the data the
train we go into the machine learning
algorithm which then puts the data into
a processing which then goes down to
machine another machine learning
algorithm and then we take new data
because you have to test whatever you
did to make sure it works correctly and
we put that into the same algorithm once
we do that we check our prediction we
check our results and from the
prediction if we've set aside some
training date and we find that it didn't
do a good job predicting it and it gets
a thumbs down as you see then we go back
to the beginning and we retrain the
algorithm and a lot of times it's not
just about getting the wrong answer it's
about continually trying to get a better
answer so you'll see the first time you
might be like oh this is not the answer
I want depending on what domain you're
working in whether it's medical
economical business stocks whatever you
try out your model and if it's not
giving you a good answer you retrain it
if you think you can get a better answer
you retrain it and you keep doing that
until you get the best answer you can
let's see the types of machine learning
supervised learning unsupervised
learning there's a number of ways to
divide up machine learning and how it
works these are two main categories you
can divide it into supervised learning
we have a known amount of data so in
this case we have a bunch of apples we
have machine learning algorithm it goes
through the process it goes through and
trains a model based on that known data
and then once you've trained your model
on the known stuff you can then put an
unknown data in there and you get a new
response and of course in this
particular one it's an Apple so it's
trying to figure out whether it's an
apple or another fruit there are many
different algorithms you can use for
computing this information for doing
this supervised training just to list
the some of the top ones that are
currently being used and by no means not
there's more than just this so by no
means this isn't the complete list
there's polynomial regression there's a
random Forest there's linear regression
there's logistic regression there's
decision trees there's K nearest
neighbors and there's naive Bays like I
said this is just a short list of some
of the many tools that are out there
nowadays and if you have supervised
learning then we should also look at
unsupervised learning unsupervised
learning so we have unknown data in this
case you can see we have a bunch of
fruit and we might not have have labeled
it we don't know we've never had anybody
look at it and say this is what this is
and we take that data and we put it
through the machine learning algorithm
and then that goes through the
processing and then the trained model
and with the trained model says hey can
I see a pattern here and from that
pattern it divides it up into a response
in this case apples and pairs you can
see some of these things look just like
the other and it tries to put them all
together so that you get similar things
in similar groups and again we have a
nice list of algorithms here and this is
not the only algorithms used for this so
don't limit yourself to this just these
these are just some of the primary ones
used today and of course we have the K
means clustering singular value
decomposition fuzzy means partial least
squares apriori hierarchial clustering
principle component analysis machine
learning prerequisites computer science
fundamentals and programming so any of
the machine learning out today you have
to know some basic scripting or
programming intermediate statistical
knowledge you have to understand a
little bit about probabilities if a is
current How likely is B going to happen
if there's clouds overhead How likely is
it going to rain linear algebra and
intermediate calculus the linear algebra
is very important because you have to
understand basically drawing a line
through the data points and what that
means that's the most fundamental linear
regression models you draw a line
through all your data and you use that
line to compute new values intermediate
calculus means you need to have a little
bit of understanding of what a
differential equation is you really
don't need to be an expert because the
computer does all the heavy lifting for
you but it's important to know the terms
when they come up unless you're doing
some Advanced programming on the actual
models themselves and data wrangling and
cleaning I would say this might be the
biggest one in here is you have to start
getting a grip on how to clean up your
data there's a saying is bad data in bad
data out good data in you're more likely
to have good data out some applications
of machine learning instant segmentation
object detection instant segmentation
you can see here where they use machine
learning to go in there and find where
the different cats are and the different
objects are in the picture and then in
segmentation it actually Cuts them out
kind of a fun one especially if you have
a Google pixel phone and you can do
little animation objects on top of your
ongoing pictures you're taking or movies
number plate detection you can see here
where we have a card it comes in there
and it finds a number plate on the car
once it's done that it can then do
automatic translation automatic
translation is we pick up some symbols
in this case on a machine and it does
machine translation so that you can know
what it's saying even if you don't speak
that language let's look at another
example of machine learning based on the
amount of rainfall how much would be the
crop yield so here we have our crops we
have our rainfall and we want to know
how much we're going to get from our
crops this year so we're going to
introduce two variables independent and
dependent the independent variable is a
variable whose value does not change by
the effect of other variables and is
used to many manipulate the dependent
variable it is often denoted as X in our
example rainfall is the independent
variable this is a wonderful example
because you can easily see that we can't
control the rain but the rain does
control the crop so we talk about the
independent variable controlling the
dependent variable let's Define
dependent variable as a variable whose
value change when there is any
manipulation the values of the
independent variables it is often
denoted as Y and you can see here our
crop yield is dependent variable and it
is dependent on the amount of rainfall
received now that we've taken a look at
a real life example let's go a little
bit into the theory and some definitions
on machine learning and see how that
fits together with linear regression
numerical and categorical values let's
take our data coming in and this is kind
of random data from any kind of project
we want to divide it up into numerical
and categorical so numerical is numbers
age salary height where categorical
would be a description the color a dog's
breed gender categoricals limited to
very specific items where numerical is a
range of information now that you've
seen the difference between numerical
and categorical data let's take a look
at some different machine learning
definitions when we look at a different
machine learning algorithms we can
divide them into three areas supervised
unsupervised reinforcement we're only
going to look at supervise today
unsupervised means we don't have the
answers we're just grouping things
reinforcement is where we give positive
and negative feedback to our algorithm
to program it and it doesn't have the
information until after the fact but
today we're just looking at supervised
because that's where linear regression
fits in in supervised data we have our
data already there and our answers for a
group and then we use that to program
our model and come up with an answer the
two most common uses for that is through
the regression and classification now
we're doing linear regression so we're
just going going to focus on the
regression side and in the regression we
have SIMPLE linear regression we have
multiple linear regression and we have
polynomial linear regression now on
these three simple linear regression is
the examples we've looked at so far
where we have a lot of data and we draw
a straight line through it multiple
linear regression means we have multiple
variables remember where we had the
rainfall and the crops we might add
additional variables in there like how
much food do we give our crops when do
we Harvest them those would be
additional information add into our
model and that's why it'd be multiple
linear regression and finally we have
polynomial linear regression that is
instead of drawing a line we can draw a
curved line through it now that you see
where regression model fits into the
machine learning algorithms and we're
specifically looking at linear
regression let's go ahead and take a
look at applications for linear
regression let's look at a few
applications of linear regression
economic growth used to determine the
economy economic growth of a country or
a state in the coming quarter can also
be used to predict the GDP of a country
product price can be used to predict
what would be the price of a product in
the future we can guess whether it's
going to go up or down or should I buy
today housing sales to estimate the
number of houses a builder would sell
and what price in the coming months
score predictions Cricket fever to
predict the number of runs a player
would score in the coming matches based
on the previous performance I'm sure you
can figure out other applications you
could use linear regression for so let's
jump in and let's understand linear
regression and dig into the theory
understanding linear regression linear
regression is the statistical model used
to predict the relationship between
independent and dependent variables by
examining two factors the first
important one is which variables in
particular are significant predictors of
the outcome variable and the second one
that we need to look at closely is how
significant is the regression line to to
make predictions with the highest
possible accuracy if it's inaccurate we
can't use it so it's very important we
find out the most accurate line we can
get since linear regression is based on
drawing a line through data we're going
to jump back and take a look at some
euclidean geometry the simplest form of
a simple linear regression equation with
one dependent and one independent
variable is represented by y equals m
times X plus C and if you look at our
model here we plotted two points on here
X1 and y1 X2 and Y2 y being the
dependent variable remember that from
before and X being the independent
variable so y depends on whatever X is m
in this case is the slope of the line
where m equals the difference in the Y2
minus y1 and X2 minus X1 and finally we
have C which is the coefficient of the
line or where it happens to cross the 0
0 axes let's go back and look at an
example we used earlier of linear
regression we're going to go back to
plotting the amount of crop yield based
on the amount of rainfall and here we
have our rainfall remember we cannot
change rainfall and we have our crop
yield which is dependent on the rainfall
so we have our independent and our
dependent variables we're going to take
this and draw a line through it as best
we can through the middle of the data
and then we look at that we put the red
point on the y-axis is the amount of
crop yield you can expect for the amount
of rainfall represented by the Green Dot
so if we have an idea what the rainfall
is for this year and what's going on
then we can guess how good our crops are
going to be and we've created a nice
line right through the middle to give us
a nice mathematical formula let's take a
look and see what the math looks like
behind this let's look at the intuition
behind the regression line now before we
dive into the math and the formulas that
go behind this and what's going on
behind the scenes
I want you to note that when we get into
the case study and we actually apply
some python script that this math you're
going to see here is already done
automatically for you you don't have to
have it memorized it is however good to
have an idea what's going on so if
people reference the different terms
you'll know what they're talking about
let's consider a sample data set with
five rows and find out how to draw the
regression line we're only going to do
five rows because if we did like the
rainfall with hundreds of points of data
that would be very hard to see what's
going on with the mathematics so we'll
go ahead and create our own two sets of
data and we have our independent
variable X and our dependent variable Y
and when X was one we got y equals 2
when X was 2 y was 4 and so on and so on
if we go ahead and plot this data on a
graph we can see how it forms a nice
line through the middle you can see
where it's kind of grouped going upwards
to the right the next thing we want to
know is what what the means is of each
of the data coming in the X and the Y
the means doesn't mean anything other
than the average so we add up all the
numbers and divide by the total so one
plus two plus three plus four plus five
over five equals three and the same for
y we get four if we go ahead and plot
the means on the graph we'll see we get
three comma four which draws a nice line
down the middle a good estimate here
we're going to dig deeper into the math
behind the regression line now remember
before I said you don't have to have all
these formulas memorized or fully
understand them even though we're going
to go into a little more detail of how
it works and if you're not a math whiz
and you don't know if you've never seen
the sigma character before which looks a
little bit like an e that's opened up
that just means summation that's all
that is so when you see the sigma
character it just means we're adding
everything in that row and for computers
this is great because as a programmer
you can easily iterate through each of
the X Y points and create a all the
information you need so in the top half
you can see where we've broken that down
into pieces and as it goes through the
first two points it computes the squared
value of x the squared value of y and x
times Y and then it takes all of X and
adds them up all of Y adds them up all
of x squared adds them up and so on and
so on and you can see we have the sum of
equal to 15 the sum is equal to 20. all
the way up to x times Y where the sum
equals 66. this all comes from our
formula for calculating a straight line
where y equals the slope times X plus
the coefficient C so we go down below
and we're going to compute more like the
averages of these and we'll explain
exactly what that is in just a minute
and where that information comes from is
called the square means error but we'll
go into that in detail in a few minutes
all you need to do is look at the
formula and see how we've gone about
Computing it line by line instead of
trying to you have a huge set of numbers
pushed into it and down here you'll see
where the slope m equals and then the
top part if you read through the
brackets you have the number of data
points times the sum of x times Y which
we computed one line at a time there and
that's just the 66 and take all that and
you subtract it from the sum of x times
the sum of Y and those have both been
computed so you have 15 times 20. and on
the bottom we have the number of lines
times the sum of x squared easily
computed as 86 for the sum minus I'll
take all that and subtract the sum of x
squared and we end up as we come across
with our formula you can plug in all
those numbers which is very easy to do
on the computer you don't have to do the
math on a piece of paper or calculator
and you'll get a slope of 0.6 and you'll
get your C coefficient if you continue
to follow through that formula you'll
see it comes out as equal to 2.2
continuing deeper into what's going
behind the scenes let's find out the
predicted values of Y for corresponding
values of X using the linear equation
where m equals 0.6 and C equals 2.2
we're going to take these values and
we're going to go ahead and plot them
we're going to predict them so y equals
0.6 times where x equals 1 plus 2.2
equals 2.8 and so on and so on and here
the Blue Points represent the actual y
values and the brown points represent
the predicted y values based on the
model we created the distance between
the actual and predicted values is known
as residuals or errors the best fit line
should have the least sum of squares of
these errors also known as e square if
we put these into a nice chart we can
see X and you can see Y what the actual
values were and you can see why it
predicted you can easily see where we
take y minus y predicted and we get an
answer what is the difference between
those two and if we square that y minus
y prediction squared we can then sum
those squared values that's where we get
the 0.64 plus the 0.36 plus 1 all the
way down until we have a summation
equals 2.4 so the sum of squared errors
for this regression line is 2.4 we check
this error for each line and conclude
the best fit line having the least e
Square value in a nice graphical
representation we can see here where we
keep moving this line through the data
points to make sure the best fit line
has a least squared distance between the
data points and the regression line now
we only looked at the most commonly used
formula for minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like sum of squared errors sum of
absolute errors root mean square error
Etc which you want to take away from
this is whatever formula is being used
you can easily using a computer
programming and iterating through the
data calculate the different parts of it
that way these complicated formulas you
see with the different summations and
absolute values are easily computed one
piece at a time up until this point
right we've only been looking at two
values X and Y well in the real world
it's very rare that you only have two
values when you're figuring out a
solution so let's move on to the next
topic multiple linear regression let's
take a brief look at what happens when
you have multiple inputs so in multiple
linear regression we have well we'll
start with the simple linear regression
where we had y equals M plus X plus C
and we're trying to find the value of y
now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in so
instead of having just X we have X1 X2
X3 and instead of having just one slope
each variable has its own slope attached
to it as you can see here we have M1 M2
M3 and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
M1 times X1 plus M2 times X2 so on all
the way to m to the nth x to the nth and
then you add your coefficient on there
implementation of linear regression now
we get into my favorite part let's
understand how multiple linear
regression works by implementing it in
Python if you remember before we were
looking at a company and just based on
its R and D trying to figure out its
profit we're going to start looking at
the expenditure of the company we're
going to go back to that we're going to
predict as profit but instead of
predicting it just on the r d we're
going to look at other factors like
Administration costs marketing costs and
so on and from there we're going to see
if we can figure out what the profit of
that company is going to be to start our
coding we're going to begin by importing
some basic libraries and we're going to
be looking through the data before we do
any kind of linear regression we're
going to take a look at the data to see
what we're playing with then we'll go
ahead and format the data to the format
we need to be able to run it in the
linear regression model and then from
there we'll go ahead and solve it and
just see how valid our solution is so
let's start with importing the basic
live libraries now I'm going to be doing
this in Anaconda Jupiter notebook a very
popular IDE I enjoy it because it's such
a visual to look at it's so easy to use
just any ID for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python IDE so here we are in our Jupiter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries were
importing first we're going to import
numpy as NP and then I want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as PD
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as NP and you have to
almost have that for your SK learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
I'll show you what that looks like the
other three line lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as PLT and then
Seaborn as SNS Seabourn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library then Seaborn sits
on top of it and we'll take a look at
what that looks like you could use any
of your own plotting libraries you want
there's all kinds of ways to look at the
data these are just very common ones and
the Seaborn is so easy to use it just
looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the Amber signed matplot Library
inline that is only because I'm doing an
inline IDE my interface in the Anaconda
Jupiter notebook requires I put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read CSV and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end one thousand companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
Supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that I have companies equals
pd.reader underscore CSV and I've
changed this path to match my computer C
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies.csv and then below
there we're going to set the x equals to
companies under the I location and
because this is companies as a PD data
set I can use this nice notation that
says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the the values set
into there so X is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies.head which
lists the first five rows of data and
I'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the pandas sees it when I
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what pandas one of
the things pandas is really good about
is it looks just like an Excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns R and D
spend Administration marketing spend
State profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a CSV so you can
actually see the raw data so here I've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have r d spend
comma Administration comma marketing
spin comma State comma profit carries
return I don't know about you but I'd go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an Excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where I can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and Investments and you understand what
165
349.20 compared to the administration
cost of 136
897.80 so and so on helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our notebook
and see what we got going and so we have
the visualization and again we're using
SNS which is pandas as you can see we
imported the matplot Library dot Pi plot
is PLT which then the Seaborn uses and
we imported the Seaborn as SNS and then
that final line of code helps us show
this in our inline coding without this
it wouldn't display and you can display
it to a file in other means and that's
the matplot library in line with the
Amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
Seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame so I can
just take the companies dot core for
coordinates and I can put that right
into the Seaborn and when we run this we
get this beautiful plot and let's just
take a look at what this plot means if
you look at this plot on mine the colors
are probably a little bit more purplish
and blue than the original one we have
the columns and the rows we have R and D
spinning we have Administration we have
marketing spending and profit and if you
cross index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with Administration costs so
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark diagonal row that shows that
this is the highest corresponding data
that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupyter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder instead of equal to
capital L label capital E encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before and
see what I'm talking about here if you
remember when we did the companies dot
head and we printed the top five rows of
data we have our columns going across we
have column zero which is R and D
spending column one which is
Administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
State and you'll see under State we have
New York California Florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process New York it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that New York California and
Florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in Brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the X also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a New York it has a zero or a one
or a two and then finally we need to do
a one hot encoder which equals one hot
encode or categorical features equals
three and then we take the X and we go
ahead and do that equal to one hot
encoder fit transform X to array this
final transformation preps our data
Force so it's completely set the way we
need it is just a row of numbers even
though it's not in here let's go ahead
and print X and just take a look what
this data is doing you'll see you have
an array of arrays and then each array
is a row of numbers and if I go ahead
and just do row zero you'll see I have a
nice organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computers
automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transformed all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data now
whenever we create a predictive model of
data we always want to split it up so we
have a training set and we have a
testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and I'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital X test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different models
usually see that a capital x and you see
the train and the test and the lowercase
Y what this is is X is our data going in
that's our RND spin our Administration
our marketing and then Y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this tutorial the
next part train test a split we take X
and we take y we've already created
those X has the columns with the data in
it and Y has a column with profit in it
and then we're going to set the test
size equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent so twenty percent of the rows
are going to be tested we're going to
put them off to the side so since we're
using a thousand lines of data that
means that 200 of those lines we're
going to hold off to the side to test
for later and then the random State
equals zero we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this it's
not overly exciting so setting up our
variables but the next step is the next
step we actually create our linear
regression model now that we got to the
linear regression model we get that next
piece of the puzzle let's go ahead and
put that code in there and walk through
it so here we go we're going to paste it
in there and let's go ahead and since
this is a shorter line of code let's
zoom up there so we can get a good look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now I don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math let's go ahead and
flip back there and take a look at that
do you remember this or we had this long
formula on the bottom and we were doing
all this summarization and then we also
looked at setting it up with the
different lines and then we also looked
all the way down to multiple linear
regression where we're adding all those
formulas together all of that is wrapped
up in this one section so what's going
on here is I'm going to create a
variable called regressor and the
regressor equals the linear regression
that's a linear regression model that
has all that math built in so we don't
have to have it all memorized or have to
compute it individually and then we do
the regressor.fit in this case we do X
train and Y train because we're using
the training data X being the data n and
y being profit what we're looking at and
this does all that math for us so within
one click and one line we've created the
whole linear regression model and we fit
the data to the linear regression model
and you can see that when I run the
regressor it gives an output linear
regression it says copy x equals True
Fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false it's just
giving you some general information on
what's going on with that regressor
model now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it and if you remember we kept a bunch
of data aside so we're going to do a why
predict variable and we're going to put
in the X test and let's see what that
looks like scroll up a little bit paste
that in here predicting the test set
results so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict X test going in
and this gives us y predict now because
I'm in Jupiter in line I can just put
the variable up there and when I hit the
Run button it'll print that array out I
could have just as easily done print y
predict so if you're in a different IDE
that's not an inline setup like the
Jupiter notebook you can do it this way
print y predict and you'll see that for
the 200 different test variables we kept
off to the side is going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when I run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into and where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals M1 times X1 plus M2
times X2 and so on and so on plus C the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the N plus C
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of two etc etc
times the First Column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus one zero three
zero zero nine point boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now I told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning I said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look at what that looks
like in code and so we're going to use
this from
sklearn.metrix we're going to import R2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the R2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us so we know are true the Y predict
of those 200 values is what we think it
was true and when we go ahead and run
this we see we get a
0.9352 that's the R2 score now it's not
exactly a straight percentage so it's
not saying it's 93 percent correct but
you do want that in the upper 90s oh and
higher shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the R2 score and if
r squared value of 0.91 or 92 as we got
on our model could remember it does have
a random generation involved this proves
the model is a good model which means
success yeah a we successfully trained
our model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression all right what
is logistic regression as I mentioned
earlier positive regression is an
algorithm for performing binary
classification so let's take an example
and see how this works let's say your
car has not been serviced for quite a
few years and now you want to find out
if it is going to break down in the near
future so this is like a classification
problem find out whether your car will
break down or not so how are we going to
perform this classification so here's
how it looks if we plot the information
along the X and Y axis X is the number
of years since the last service was
performed and why is the probability of
your car breaking down and let's say
this information was this data rather
was collected from several car users
it's not just your car but several car
users so that is our labeled data so the
data has been collected and for for the
number of years and when the car broke
down and what was the probability and
that has been plotted along x and y axis
so this provides an idea from this graph
we can find out whether your car will
break down or not we'll see how so first
of all the probability can go from zero
to one as you all aware probability can
be between 0 and 1 and as we can imagine
it is intuitive as well as the number of
years are on the Lower Side maybe one
year two years or three years still
after the service the chances of your
car breaking down are very limited right
so for example chances of your car
breaking down on the probability of your
car breaking down within two years of
your last service are 0.1 probability
similarly three years is maybe 0.3 and
so on but as the number of years
increases let's say if it was six or
seven years there is almost a certainty
that your car is going to break down
that is what this graph shows so this is
an example of a application of the
classification algorithm and we will see
in little details how exactly logistic
regression is applied here one more
thing needs to be added here is that the
dependent variables outcome is discrete
so if we are talking about whether the
car is going to break down or not so
that is a discrete value the Y that we
are talking about the dependent variable
that we are talking about what we are
looking at is whether the car is going
to break down or not yes or no that is
what we are talking about so here the
outcome is discrete and not a continuous
way so this is how the logistic
regression curve looks let me explain a
little bit what exactly how exactly we
are going to
recommend the class like the outcome
rather so for a logistic regression
curve a threshold has to be set saying
that because this is a probability
calculation remember this is a
probability calculation and the
probability itself will not be zero or
one but based on the probability we need
to decide what the outcome should be so
there has to be a threshold like for
example 0.5 can be the threshold let's
say in this case so any value of the
probability below 0.5 is considered to
be 0 and any value above 0.5 is
considered to be 1. so an output of
let's say 0.8 will mean that the car
will break down so that is considered as
an output of 1 and let's say an output
of 0.29 is considered as 0 which means
that the car will not break down so
that's the way logistic regression works
now let's do a quick comparison between
logistic regression and linear
regression because they both have the
term regression in them so it can cause
confusion so let's try to remove that
confusion so what is linear regression
linear regression is a process is once
again an algorithm for supervised
learning however here you are going to
find a continuous value you are going to
determine a continuous value it could be
the price of a real estate property it
could be your height how much height
you're going to get or it could be a
stock price these are all continuous
values these are not discrete compared
to a yes or no kind of a response that
we are looking for in logistic
regression so this is one example of a
linear regression let's say at the HR
team of a company tries to find out what
should be the salary hike of an employee
so they collect all the details of their
existing employees their ratings and
their salary hikes what has been given
and that is the labeled information that
is available and the system learns from
us it is and it learns from this labeled
information so that when a new
employee's information is fed based on
the rating it will determine what should
be the high so this is a linear
regression problem and a linear
regression example now salary is a
continuous value you can get five
thousand five thousand five hundred five
thousand six hundred it is not discrete
like a cat or a dog or an apple or a
banana these are discrete or a yes or a
no these are discrete values right so
this way you are trying to find
continuous values is where we use linear
regression so let's say just to extend
on the scenario we now want to find out
whether this employee is going to get a
promotion or not so we want to find out
that is the discrete problem right a yes
or no kind of a problem in this case we
actually cannot use linear regression
even though we may have labeled data so
this is the label date So based on the
employee rating these are the ratings
and then some people got the promotion
and this is the ratings for which people
did not get promotion that is a no and
this is the rating for which people got
promotion we just plotted the data about
whether a person has got an employer's
got promotion or not yes no right so
there is nothing in between and what is
the employee's rating and ratings can be
continuous that is not an issue but the
output is discrete in this case whether
employee got promotion yes no okay so if
we try to plot that and we try to find a
straight line this is how it would look
and as you can see it doesn't look very
right because looks like there will be
lot of errors this root mean square
error if you remember for linear
regression would be very very high and
also the the values cannot go beyond
zero or Beyond one so the graph should
probably look somewhat like this clicked
at 0 and 1. but still this straight line
doesn't look right therefore instead of
using a linear equation we need to come
up with something different and
therefore the logistic regression model
looks somewhat like this so we calculate
the probability and if we plot that
probability not in the form of a
straight line but we need to use some
other equation we will see very soon
what the depression is then it is a
gradual process right so you see here
people with some of these ratings are
not getting any promotions and then
slowly uh at certain rating they get
promotion so that is a gradual process
and this is how the math behind logistic
regression looks so we are trying to
find the odds for a particular event
happening and this is the formula for
finding the odd so the probability of an
event happening divided by the
probability of the event not happening
so P if it is the probability of the
event happening probability of the
person getting a promotion and divided
by the probability of the person not
getting a promotion that is 1 minus p
this is how you measure the odds now the
values of the odds range from 0 to
Infinity so when this probability is 0
then the odds will the value of the odds
is equal to zero and when the
probability becomes 1 then the value of
the odds is 1 by 0 that will be Infinity
but the probability itself remains
between 0 and 1. now this is how an
equation of a straight line love so Y is
equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x where beta0
is the y-intercept and beta 1 is the
slope of the line if we take the odds
equation and take a log of both sides
then this would look somewhat like this
and the term logistic is actually
derived from the fact that we are doing
this we take a log of DX by 1 minus p x
this is an extension of the calculation
of odds that we have seen right and that
is equal to beta0 plus beta 1 x which is
the equation of the straight line and
now from here if you want to find out
the value of PX we will see we can take
the exponential on both sides and then
if we solve that equation we will get
the equation of PX like this p x is
equal to 1 by 1 plus e to the power of
minus beta0 plus beta 1 x and recall
this is nothing but the equation of the
line which is equal to y y is equal to
Beta 0 plus beta 1 X so that this is the
equation also known as the sigmoid
function and this is the equation of the
logistic regression all right and if
this is plotted this is how the sigmoid
curve is obtained so let's compare
linear and logistic regression how they
are different from each other let's go
back so linear regression is solved or
used to solve regression problems and
logistic regression is used to solve
classification problems so both are
called regression but linear regression
is used for solving regression problems
where we predict continuous values
whereas logistic regression is used for
solving classification problems where we
have had to predict discrete values the
response variables in case of linear
regression are continuous in nature
whereas here they are categorical or
discrete in nature and the linear
regression helps to estimate the
dependent variable when there is a
change in the independent variable
whereas here in case of logistic
regression it helps to calculate the
probability or the possibility of a
particular event happening and linear
regression as the name suggests is a
straight line that's why it's called
linear regression whereas logistic
regression is a sigmoid function and
curve is the shape of the curve is s
it's an s shaped curve this is another
example of application of logistic
regression in weather prediction whether
it's going to rain or not rain now keep
in mind both are used in weather
prediction if we want to find the
discrete values like whether it's going
to rain or not rain that is a
classification problem we use logistic
regression but if we want to determine
what is going to be the temperature
tomorrow then we use linear regression
so just keep in mind that in weather
prediction we actually use both but
these are some examples of logistic
regression so we want to find out
whether it's going to be rain or not it
is going to be sunny or not it is going
to snow or not these are all logistic
regression examples a few more examples
classification of objects this is a
again another example of logistic
regression now here of course one
distinction is that these are
multi-class classification so logistic
regression is not used in its original
form but it is used in a slightly
different form so we say whether it is a
dog or not a dog I hope you understand
so instead of saying is it a dog or a
cat or a elephant we convert this into
saying so because we need to keep it to
Binary classification so we say is it a
dog or not a dog is it a cat or not a
cat so that's the way logistic
regression can be used for classifying
objects otherwise there are other
techniques which can be used for
performing multi-class classification
Healthcare plastic regression is used to
find the survival rate of a patient so
they take multiple parameters like drama
score and age and so on and so forth and
they try to predict the rate of survival
all right now finally let's take an
example and see how we can apply
logistic regression to predict the
number that is shown in the image so
this is actually a live demo I will take
you into Jupiter notebook and show the
code but before that let me take you
through a couple of slides to explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an eight by eight image and
there the image has a number one two
three four and you need to train your
model to predict what this number is so
how do we do this so the first thing is
obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model so in this
case we are using logistic regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we test how
accurate our model is with the test data
which means that like any machine
learning process we split our initial
data into two parts training set and
test set with the training set we train
our model and then with the test set we
test the model till we get good accuracy
and then we use it for for inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models so let's take a
look at the code and see what we are
doing so I'll not go line by line but
just take you through some of the blocks
so first thing we do is import all the
libraries and then we basically take a
look at the images and see what is the
total number of images we can display
using matplotlib some of the images or a
sample of these images and then we split
the data into training and test as I
mentioned earlier and we can do some
exploratory analysis and then we build
our model we train our model with the
training set and then we test it with
our test set and find out how accurate
our model is using the confusion Matrix
the heat map and use heat map for
visualizing this and I will show you in
the code what exactly is the confusion
Matrix and how it can be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
get an accuracy of about 0.94 which is
pretty good or 94 percent which is
pretty good all right so what is the
confusion Matrix this is an example of a
confusion Matrix and this is used for
identifying the accuracy of a
classification model or like a logistic
regression model so the most important
part in a confusion Matrix is that first
of all this as you can see this is a
matrix and the size of the Matrix
depends on how many outputs we are
expecting
so to the most important part here is
that the model will be most accurate
when we have the maximum numbers in its
diagram like in this case that's why it
has almost 93 94 percent because the
diagonals should have the maximum
numbers and the others other than
diagnose the cells other than the
diagonal should have very few numbers so
here that's what is happening so there
is a two here there are there's a one
here but most of them are along the
diagonal this what does this mean this
means that the number that has been fed
is zero and the number that has been
detected is also zero so the predicted
value and the actual value are the same
so along the diagonals that is true
which means that let's let's take this
diagonal right if the maximum number is
here that means that like here in this
case it is 34 which means that 34 of the
images that have been fed or rather
actually there are two
misclassifications in there so 36 images
have been fed which have number four and
out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four and one has
been predicted as number eight and
another one has been predicted as number
nine so these are two missed
classifications okay so that is the
meaning of saying that the maximum
number should be in the diagonal so if
you have all of them so for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent accurate model okay so
that's uh just of how to use this Matrix
how to use this confusion Matrix I know
the name uh is a little funny sounding
confusion Matrix but actually it is not
very confusing it's very straightforward
so you are just plotting what has been
predicted and what is the labeled
information on what is the actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all right
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that all
of them have been predicted correctly
there have been 38 zeros and the
predicted value and the actual value is
exactly the same whereas in this case
right it has there are I think 37 plus
five yeah 42 have been fed the images 42
images are of Digit 3 and the accuracy
is only 37 of them have been accurately
predicted three of them have been
predicted as number seven and two of
them have been predicted as number eight
and so on and so forth okay all right so
with that let's go into jupyter notebook
and see how the code looks so this is
the code in in Jupiter notebook for
logistic regression in this particular
demo what we are going to do is train
our model to recognize digits which are
the images which have digits from let's
say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
um and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these numbers correctly or not
so let's get started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then the
last line in this block is to load the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize the
shape of these digits so we can see here
okay if we take a look this is how the
shape is 1797 by 64. these are like
eight by eight images so that's that's
what is reflected in this shape now from
here onwards we are basically once again
importing some of the libraries that are
required like numpy and matplot and we
will take a look at some of the sample
images that we have loaded so this one
for example creates a figure and then we
go ahead and take a few sample images to
see how they look so let me run this
code and so that it becomes easy to
understand so these are about five
images sample images that we are looking
at zero one two three four so this is
how the images this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will actually
train our logistic regression model and
then we will test it and see how well it
is able to recognize so the way it works
is the pixel information so as you can
see here this is an eight by eight pixel
kind of a image and the each pixel
whether it is activated or not activated
that is the information available for
each pixel now based on the pattern of
this activation and non-activation of
the various pixels this will be
identified as a zero for example right
similarly as you can see so overall each
of these numbers actually has a
different pattern of the pixel
activation and that's pretty much that
our model needs to learn for which
number what is the pattern of the
activation of the pixels right so that
is what we are going to train our model
okay so the first thing we need to do is
to split our data into training and test
data set right so whenever we perform
any training we split the data into
training and tests so that the training
data set is used to train the system so
we pass this probably multiple times and
then we test it with the test data set
and the split is usually in the form of
there and there are various ways in
which you can split this data it is up
to the individual preferences in our
case here we are splitting in the form
of 23 and 77 so when we say test size as
20.23 then that means 23 percent of that
entire data is used for testing and the
remaining 77 percent is used for
training so there is a readily available
function which is uh called train test
split so we don't have to write any
special code for the splitting it will
automatically split the data based on
the proportion that we give here which
is test size so we just give the test
size automatically training size will be
determined and we pass the data that we
want to split and the the results will
be stored in X underscore train and Y
underscore train for the training data
set and what is X underscore train these
are these are the features right which
is like the independent variable and why
underscore train is the label right so
in this case what happens is we have the
input value which is or the features
value which is in X underscore train and
since this is the labeled data for each
of the them each of the observations we
already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a zero or a
one or a two so that that's this is what
will be used for comparison to find out
whether the the system is able to
recognize it correctly or there is an
error for each observation it will
compare with this right so this is the
label so the same way X underscore train
y underscore train is for the training
data set X underscore test y underscore
test is for the test data set okay so
let me go ahead and execute this code as
well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the how many entries are
there and in each of this so X
underscore train the shape is 1383 by 64
and Y underscore train has 1383 because
there is uh nothing like the second part
is not required here and then X
underscore test shape we see is 414 so
actually there are 414 observations in
test and 1383 observations in train so
that's basically what these four lines
of code are are saying okay then we
import the logistic regression library
and which is a part of scikit-learn so
we we don't have to implement the
logistic regression process itself we
just call these the function and let me
go ahead and execute that so that we
have the logistic regression Library
imported now we create an instance of
logistic regression right so logistic
regr is a is an instance of logistic
regression and then we use that for
training our model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line basically creates an
instance of logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing our data the training data set
and this is our the predictors and this
is our Target we are passing this data
set to train our model all right so once
we do this in this case the data is not
large but by and large and the training
is what takes usually a lot of time so
we spend in machine learning activities
in machine learning projects we spend a
lot of time for the training part of it
okay so here the data set is relatively
small so it was pretty quick so all
right so now our model has been trained
using the training data set and we want
to see how accurate this is so so what
we'll do is we will test it out in
probably faces so let me first try out
how well this is working for one image
okay I will just try it out with one
image my the first entry in my test data
set and see whether it is uh correctly
predicting or not so and in order to
test it so for training purpose we use
the fit method there is a method called
fit which is for training the model and
once the training is done if you want to
test for a particular value new input
you use the predict method okay so let's
run the predict method and we pass this
particular image and we see that the
shape is or the prediction is four so
let's try a few more let me see for the
next 10 seems to be fine so let me just
go ahead and test the entire data set
okay that's basically what it will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has is performed so we use the
score method to find what is the
percentages of accuracy and we see here
that it has performed up to 94 percent
accurate okay so that's on this part now
what we can also do is we can
um also see this accuracy using what is
known as a confusion Matrix so let us go
ahead and try that as well so that we
can also visualize how well this model
has done so let me execute this piece of
code which will basically import some of
the libraries that are required and
um we we basically create a confusion
Matrix an instance of confusion matrix
by running confusion Matrix and passing
these values so we have so this
confusion underscore Matrix method takes
two parameters one is the Y underscore
test and the other is the prediction so
what is the Y underscore test these are
the labeled values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the test data set okay so this is known
to us and this is what the system has
the model has generated so we kind of
create the confusion Matrix and we will
print it and this is how the confusion
Matrix looks as the name suggests it is
a matrix and the key point out here is
that the accuracy of the model is
determined by how many numbers are there
in the diagonal the more the numbers in
the diagonal the better the accuracy is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole Matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set that is the first
thing right so if you add up all these
numbers that will be equal to the number
of observations in the test data set and
then out of that the maximum number of
of them should be in the diagonal that
means the accuracy is pretty good if the
the numbers in the diagonal are less and
in all other places there are a lot of
numbers which means the accuracy is very
low the diagonal indicates a correct
prediction that so this means that the
actual value is same as the predicted
value here again actual value is same as
the predicted value and so on right so
the moment you see a number here that
means the actual value is something and
the predicted value is something else
right similarly here the actual value is
something and the predicted value is
something else so that is basically how
we read the confusion Matrix now how do
we find the accuracy you can actually
add up the total values in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 Plus 43 and so
on and divide that by the total number
of test observations that will give you
the percentage accuracy using a
confusion Matrix now let us visualize
this confusion Matrix tricks in a
slightly more sophisticated way using a
heat map so we will create a heat map
with some We'll add some colors as well
it's uh it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea so if we let me run this
piece of code and this is how the heat
map looks and as you can see here the
diagonals again are all the values are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate and yeah basically the accuracy
score is 94 percent this is calculated
as I mentioned by adding all these
numbers divided by the total test value
so the total number of observations in
test data set okay so this is the
confusion Matrix for logistic regression
all right so now that we have seen the
confusion Matrix let's take a quick
sample and see how well uh the system
has classified and we will take a few
examples of the data so if we see here
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh number four which is the
actual value and also the predicted
value both are four this is an image of
zero so the predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of nine so this has also
been predicted correctly nine and actual
value is 9 and this is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as like the actual value okay
so this was a quick demo of logistic
regression how to use logistic
regression to identify images what is a
decision tree let's go through a very
simple example before we dig in D
decision tree is a tree shape diagram
used to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision or current or reaction
let's start with a simple question how
to identify a random vegetable from a
shopping bag so we have this group of
vegetables in here and we can start off
by asking a simple question is it red
and if it's not then it's going to be
the purple fruit to the left probably an
eggplant if it's true it's going to be
one of the red fruits is a diameter
greater than two if false is going to be
a what looks to be a red chili and if
it's true it's going to be a bell pepper
from the capsicum family so it's a cap
capsicum
problems that decision tree can solve so
let's look at the two different
categories the decision tree can be used
on it can be used on the classification
the true false yes no and it can be used
on regression where we figure out what
the next value is in a series of numbers
or a group of data in classification the
classification tree will determine a set
of logical if-then conditions to
classify problems for example
discriminating between three types of
flowers based on certain features in
regression a regression tree is used
when the target variable is numerical or
continuous in nature we fit the
regression model to the Target variable
using each of the independent variables
each split is made based on the sum of
squared error
before we dig deeper into the mechanics
of the decision tree let's take a look
at the advantages of using a decision
tree and we'll also take a glimpse at
the disadvantages the first thing you'll
notice is that it's simple to understand
interpret and visualize it really shines
here because you can see exactly what's
going on in a decision tree little
effort is required for data preparation
so you don't have to do special scaling
there's a lot of things you don't have
to worry about when using a decision
tree it can handle both numerical and
categorical data as we discovered
earlier and non-linear parameters don't
affect its performance so even if the
data doesn't fit an easy curved graph
you can still use it to create an
effective decision or prediction
if we're going to look at the advantages
of a decision tree we also need to
understand the disadvantages of a
decision tree the first disadvantage is
overfitting overfitting occurs when the
algorithm captures noise in the data
that means you're solving for one
specific instance instead of a general
solution for all the data High variance
the model can get unstable due to small
variation in data low bias tree a highly
complicated decision tree tends to have
a low bias which makes it difficult for
the model to work with new data
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further we need to look at some
basic terms we need to have some
definitions to go with our decision tree
in the different parts we're going to be
using we'll start with entropy entropy
is a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set for
example we have a group of animals in
this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set is
considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals as a big clump of
entities so as we start splitting it
into subgroups we come up with our
second definition which is Information
Gain Information Gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split so in this case based on the
color yellow we've split one group of
animals on one side as true and those
who aren't yellow as false as we
continue down the yellow side we split
based on the height true or false equals
10 and on the other side height is less
than 10 true or false and as you see as
we split it the entropy continues to be
less and less and less and so our
Information Gain is simply the entropy
E1 from the top and how it's changed to
E2 in the bottom and we'll look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
Python because it'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math and how
they compute entropy finally we went
into the different parts of our tree and
they call the leaf node Leaf node
carries a classification or the decision
so it's a final end at the bottom the
decision node has two or more branches
this is where we're breaking the group
up into different parts and finally you
have the root node the topmost decision
node is known as the root node
how does a decision tree work wonder
what kind of animals I'll get in the
jungle today maybe you're the hunter
with a gun or if you're more into
photography you're a photographer with a
camera so let's look at this group of
animals and let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement is to classify the
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree the
data set is looking quite messy and the
entropy is high in this case so let's
look at a training set or a training
data set and we're looking at color
we're looking at height and then we have
our different animals we have our
elephants our giraffes our monkeys and
our tigers and they're of different
colors and shapes let's see what that
looks like and how do we split the data
we have to frame the conditions that
split the data in such a way that the
Information Gain is the highest note
gain is the measure of decrease in
entropy after splitting so the formula
for entropy is the sum that's what this
symbol looks like that looks like kind
of like a the funky e of K where I
equals 1 to k k would represent the
number of animal the different animals
in there where value or P value of I
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log base 2 of the same the
percentage of that animal let's try to
calculate the entropy for the current
data set and take a look at what that
looks like and don't be afraid of the
math don't really have to memorize this
math just be aware that it's there and
this is what's going on in the
background and so we have three drafts
two tigers one monkey two elephants a
total of eight animals gather and if we
plug that into the formula we get an
entropy that equals three over eight so
we have three drafts a total of eight
times the log usually they use base two
on the log so log base 2 of 3 over 8
plus in this case let's say it's the
elephants two over eight two elephants
over a total of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over a
total of eight log base two one over
eight and plus two 2 over 8 of the
Tigers log base 2 over 8. and if we plug
that into our computer or calculator I
obviously can't do logs in my head we
get an entropy equal to
0.571 the program will actually
calculate the entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain now we're not going to go
through each set one at a time to see
what those numbers are we just want you
to be aware that this is a Formula or
the mathematics behind it gain can be
calculated by finding the difference of
the subsequent entropy values after a
split now we will try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest gain
we will do that by splitting the data
using each condition and checking that
the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split can
you guess what that first split will be
just by looking at this image as a human
is probably pretty easy to split it
let's see if you're right if you guessed
the color yellow you're correct let's
say the condition that gives us the
maximum gain is yellow so we will split
the data based on the color yellow if
it's true that group of animals goes to
the left if it's false it goes to the
right the entropy after the splitting
has to decreased considerably however we
still need some splitting at both the
branches to attain an entropy value
equal to zero so we decide to split both
the nodes using height as the condition
since every Branch now contains single
label type we can say that entropy in
this case has reached the least value
and here you see we have the giraffes of
the Tigers the monkey and the elephants
all separate into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with the
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some Python and see what the programming
code and the scripting looks like in
here we're going to want to do a
prediction and we start with this
individual here who's requesting to find
out how good his customers are going to
be whether they're going to be pay their
loan or not for this bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
Python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
Python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing I need is
I need something to edit my Python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
I'm using the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
now you can use any python IDE you like
to run it in but I find the Jupiter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the Fly and let's go ahead and just
paste that code in the beginning and
before we we start let's talk a little
bit about what we're bringing in and
then we're going to do a couple things
in here we have to make a couple changes
as we go through this first part of the
import the first thing we bring in is
numpy as NP that's very standard when
we're dealing with mathematics
especially with a very complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num your
number it's called number python it has
your mathematics in there in this case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with and
then we're going to use pandas as PD
that's also a standard the pandas is a
data frame setup and you can liken this
to taking your basic data and storing it
in a way that looks like an Excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see NP or PD those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and I'll show you a little
bit more when we explore the data in
just a minute then we're going to need
to split the data so I'm going to bring
in our train test and split and this is
coming from the sklearn package cross
validation and just a minute we're going
to change that and we'll go over that
too and then there's also the SK dot
tree import decision tree classifier
that's the actual tool we're using
remember I told you don't be afraid of
the mathematics it's going to be done
for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrix for accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function that's needed for the
decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and I'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says I need to read a file and when this
was written the person who wrote it this
is their path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and I'm going to put in here my file
path I'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my C drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where I stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer it'll be
different the data.2 CSV file was
generated by simply learn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the YouTube
and then if I'm going to give it a name
full file name
I'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up is probably the
hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here if you
read the warning it says the cross
validation is depreciated so it's a
warning on it's being removed and it's
going to be moved in favor of the model
selection
so if we go up here we have
sklearn.cross validation and if you
research this and go to the sklearn site
you'll find out that you can actually
just swap it right in there with model
selection
and so when I come in here and I run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further I went ahead
and opened up the data from this file
remember the the data file we just
loaded on here the data underscore2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet this
is what it looks like as a basic text
file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here I've
opened it up in the open Office calc
which is pretty much the same as Excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score house
number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1000 lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data I usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so I can see what I'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in Python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple Lin
function from python
and when I run this you'll see that it's
a thousand long and that's what we
expected there's a thousand lines of
data in there if you subtract the column
head this is one of the nice things when
we did the balance data from the panda
read CSV you'll see that the header is
row zero so it automatically removes a
row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that and again
we're going to utilize the tools in
panda
and since the balance underscore data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using Python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data.head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of data set just a
simple print statement
and when we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas does such a wonderful job of
making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head it prints the first five lines of
the data and we always start with zero
so we have five lines we have zero one
two three four instead of one two three
four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you want to start
with the zero position and that is what
the data head does it pulls the first
five rows of data puts in a nice format
that you can look at and view very
powerful tool to view the data so
instead of having to flip and open up an
Excel spreadsheet or open Office Cal or
trying to look at a word doc where it's
all scrunched together and hard to read
you can now get a nice open view of what
you're working with we're working with a
shape of a thousand long five wide so we
have five columns and we do the full
data head you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to First
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
site to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set so to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our X and Y
where did X and Y come from well X is
going to be our data
and Y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at it source and
Target
in this case we're using X and Y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets means that we're going to
select all the lines in the database so
it's all the data and the second one
says we're only going to look at columns
one through five remember always start
with zero zero is a yes or no and that's
whether the loan went default or not so
we want to start with one if we go back
up here that's the initial payment and
it goes all the way through the house
number
well if we want to look at one through
five we can do the same thing for Y
which is the answers and we're going to
set that just equal to the zero row so
it's just the zero row and then it's all
rows going in there so now we've divided
this into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your X training your X
test your y train your y test
simply put we have X going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have X test where we're
going to test that data and we have to
know in the end what the Y was supposed
to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the X train and since we know the
answers for X trade or the Y train we go
and put those in and let's go ahead and
run this and what most of these sklearn
modules do is when you set up the
variable in this case when we set the
clf entropy equal decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play Within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this tutorial able to go through all of
these and how they work but we're
working on entropy that's one of the
options we've added that it's completely
a random state of 100 so 100 percent and
we have a max depth of three now the max
depth if you remember above when we were
doing the different graphs of animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops and then we have
minimal samples of leaves as five so
it's going to have at least five leaves
at the end so I'll have at least three
splits I'll have no more than three
layers and at least five in leaves with
the final result at the bottom now that
we've created our decision tree
classifier not only created it but
trained it let's go ahead and apply it
and see what that looks like so let's go
ahead and make a prediction and see what
that looks like we're going to paste our
predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here we
have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the SK learn modules that
they're different tools have the predict
when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our X
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use an
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be pay
them back or not in this case so we need
to test out the data and just see how
good our sample is how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally since Anaconda Jupiter notebook
is works as a command line for python we
can simply put the why predict en to
print it I could just as easily have put
the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out and we'll go ahead and do
that it doesn't matter which way you do
it
and you'll see right here that it runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
now we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from that's coming from here down
here from
sklearn.metrix import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict en
that's the answers we got and we're just
going to multiply that by a hundred
because this is just going to give us an
answer as a decimal and we want to see
it as a percentage and let's run that
and see what it looks like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profit is going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not so why random Forest It's
always important to understand why we
use this tool over the other ones what
are the benefits here and so with the
random Forest the first one is there's
no overfitting if you use of multiple
trees reduce the risk of overfitting
training time is less overfitting means
that we have fit the data so close to
what we have as our sample that we pick
up on all the weird parts and instead of
predicting the overall data you're
predicting the weird stuff which you
don't want high accuracy runs
efficiently on large database for large
data it produces highly accurate
predictions in today's world of Big Data
this is really important and this is
probably where it really shines this is
where why random Forest really comes in
it estimates missing data data in
today's world is very messy so when you
have a random force it can maintain the
accuracy when a large proportion of the
data is missing what that means is if
you have data that comes in from five or
six different areas and maybe they took
one set of Statistics in one area and
they took a slightly different set of
Statistics in the other so they have
some of the same same shared data but
one is missing like the number of
children in the house if you're doing
something over demographics and the
other one is missing the size of the
house it will look at both of those
separately and build two different trees
and then it can do a very good job of
guessing which one fits better even
though it's missing that data let us dig
deep into the theory of exactly how it
works and let's look at what is random
forests random forests or random
decision Forest is a method that
operates by constructing multiple
decision trees the decision of the
majority of the trees is chosen by the
random Forest as the final decision and
this we have some nice Graphics here we
have a decision tree and they actually
use a real tree to denote the decision
tree which I love and given a random
some kind of picture of a fruit this
decision tree decides that the output is
it's an apple and we have a decision
tree two where we have that picture of
the fruit goes in and this one decides
that it's a limit and the decision three
tree gets another image and it decides
it's an apple and then this all goes
together and what they call the random
forest and this random Forest then looks
at it and says okay I got two votes for
apple one vote for lemon the majority is
Apples so the final decision is apples
to understand how the random Forest
works we first need to dig a little
deeper and take a look at the random
forest and the actual decision tree and
how it builds that decision tree and
looking closer at how the individual
decision trees work we'll go ahead and
continue to use the fruit example since
we're talking about trees and forests a
decision tree is a tree shaped diagram
to use to determine a course of action
each branch of the tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
so in here we have a bowl of fruit and
if you look at that it looks like they
switch from lemons to oranges we have
oranges cherries and apples and the
first decision of the decision tree
might be is a diameter greater than or
equal to three and if it says false it
knows that they're cherries because
everything else is bigger than that so
all the cherries fall into that decision
so we have all that data we're training
we can look at that we know that that's
what's going to come up is the color
orange well goes hmm orange or red well
if it's true then it comes out as the
orange and if it's false that leaves
apples
so in this example it sorts out the
fruit in the bowl or the images of the
fruit a decision tree these are very
important terms to know because these
are very Central to understanding the
decision tree when working with them the
first is entropy everything on the
decision tree and how it makes this
decision is based on entropy entropy is
a measure of Randomness or
unpredictability in the data set then
they also have Information Gain
the leaf node the decision node and the
root node we'll cover these other four
terms as we go down the tree but let's
start with entropy so starting with
entropy we have here a high amount of
Randomness what that means is that
whatever is coming out of this decision
if it was going to guess based on this
data it wouldn't be able to tell you
whether it's a lemon or an apple it
would just say it's a fruit
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to split this apart and we take the
initial data set we're going to create a
data set one and a data set two we just
split it in two and if you look at these
new data sets after splitting them the
entropy of each of those sets is much
less so for the first one whatever comes
in there it's going to sort that data
and it's going to say okay if this data
goes this direction it's probably an
apple and if it goes into the other
direction it's probably a lemon so that
brings us up to Information Gain it is a
measure of decrease in the entropy after
the data set is split what that means in
here is that we've gone from one set
which has a very high entropy to two
lower sets of entropy and we've added in
the values of E1 for the first one and
E2 for the second two which are much
lower and so that information gain is
increased greatly in this example and so
you can find that the information grain
simply equals decision E1 minus E2 and
as we're going down our list of
definitions we'll look at the leaf node
and the leaf node carries the
classification or the decision so we
look down here to the leaf node we
finally get to our set one or our set
two when it comes down there and it says
okay this object's gone into set one if
it's gone into set one it's going to be
split by some means and we'll either end
up with apples on the leaf node or a
lemon on the leaf node and on the right
it'll either be an apple or lemons those
Leaf nodes are those final decisions or
classifications that's the definition of
leaf node in here if we're going to have
a final Leaf where we make the decision
we should have a name for the nodes
above it and they call those decision
nodes a decision node decision node has
two or more branches and you can see
here where we have the five apples and
one lemon and in the other case the five
lemons and one apple they have to make a
choice of which tree it goes down
based on some kind of measurement or
information given to the tree
and that brings us to our last
definition the root node the topmost
decision node is known as the root node
and this is where you have all of your
data and you have your first decision it
has to make or the first split in
information
so far we've looked at a very general
image with the fruit being split let's
look and see exactly what that means to
split the data and how do we make those
decisions on there let's go in there and
find out how does a decision tree work
so let's try to understand this and
let's use a simple example and we'll
stay with the fruit we have a bowl of
fruit and so let's create a problem
statement and the problem is we want to
classify the different types of fruits
in the bowl based on different features
the data set in the bowl is looking
quite messy and the entropy is high in
this case so if this bowl was our
decision maker it wouldn't know what
choice to make it has so many choices
which one do you pick Apple grapes or
lemons and so we look in here we're
going to start with a training set
so this is our data that we're training
our data with and we have a number of
options here we have the color and under
the color we have red yellow purple we
have a diameter three three one three
three one and we have a label Apple
lemon Grapes apple lemon grapes and how
do we split the data we have to frame
the conditions to split the data in such
a way that the Information Gain is the
highest it's very key to note that we're
looking for the best gain we don't want
to just start sorting out the smallest
piece in there we want to split it the
biggest way we can and so we measure
this decrease in entropy that's what
they call it entropy there's our entropy
after splitting and now we'll try to
choose a condition that gives us the
highest gain we will do that by
splitting the data using each condition
and checking the gain that we get out of
them the conditions that give us the
highest gain will be used to make the
first split so let's take a look at
these different conditions we have color
we have diameter and if we look
underneath that we have a couple
different values we have diameter equals
three color equals yellow red diameter
equals one and when we look at that
you'll see over here we have one two
three four threes that's a pretty hearty
selection so let's say the condition
gives us a maximum gain of three so we
have the most pieces fall into that
range so our first split from our
decision node is we split the data based
on the diameter is it greater than or
equal to three if it's not that's false
it goes into the great bolt and if it's
true it goes into a bowl fold of lemon
and apples the entropy after splitting
has decreased considerably so now we can
make two decisions if you look at
they're very much less chaos going on
there this node has already attained an
entropy value of zero as you can see
there's only one kind of label left for
this Branch so no further splitting is
required for this node however this node
on the right is still requires a split
to decrease the entropy further so we
split the right node further are based
on color if you look at this if I split
it on color that pretty much cuts it
right down the middle that's the only
thing we have left in our choices of
color and diameter too and if the color
is yellow it's going to go to the rifle
and if it's false it's going to go to
the left Bowl so the entropy in this
case is now zero so now we have three
moles with zero entropy there's only one
type of data in each one of those bowls
so we can predict a lemon with a hundred
percent accuracy and we can predict the
Apple also with 100 accuracy along with
our grapes up there so we've looked at
kind of a basic tree in our forest but
what we really want to know is how does
a random Forest work as a whole so to
begin our random Forest classifier let's
say we already have built three trees
and we're going to start with the first
tree that looks like this just like we
did in the example this tree looks at
the diameter if it's greater than or
equal to three it's true otherwise it's
false so one side goes to the smaller
diameter one side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange it's
going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of lemons and
if it's red it's going to go to the left
false we build a second tree very
similar but split differently instead of
the first one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first Bowl it has a lot of
red objects so it says is the color red
because that's going to bring our
entropy down the fastest and so of
course if it's true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape false or true
and so on and so on and tree three is
the diameter equal to one and it came up
with this because there's a lot of
cherries in this bowl so that would be
the biggest split on there is is the
diameter equal to one that's going to
drop the entropy the quickest and as you
can see it splits it into true if it
goes false and they've added another
category does it grow in the summer and
if it's false it goes off to the left if
it's true it goes off to the right let's
go ahead and bring these three trees you
can see them all in one image so this
would be three completely different
trees categorizing a fruit and let's
take a fruit now let's try this and this
fruit if you look at it we've blackened
it out you can't see the color on it so
it's missing data remember one of the
things we talked about earlier is that a
random Forest works really good if
you're missing data if you're missing
pieces so this fruit has an image but
maybe as a person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this and
it's going to have they put the color in
there so ignore the color down there but
the diameter equals three we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes and the
shape is a circle and if you go to the
right you can look at what one of the
decision trees did this is the third one
is the diameter greater than equal to
three is a color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but if you look
at the value it say true and you go to
the right tree two classifies it as
cherries is a color equal red is is the
shape a circle true it is a circle so
this would look at it and say oh that's
a cherry and then we go to the other
classifier and it says is the diameter
equal one well that's false does it grow
in the summer true so it goes down and
looks at as oranges so how does this
random Forest work the first one says
it's an orange the second one said it
was a cherry and the third one says it's
an orange
and you can guess that if you have two
oranges and one says it's a cherry when
you add that all together the majority
of the vote says orange so the answer is
it's classified as an orange even though
we didn't know the color and we're
missing data on it I don't know about
you but I'm getting tired of fruit so
let's switch and I did promise you we'd
start looking at a case example and get
into some python coding today we're
going to use the case the iris flower
analysis
oh this is the exciting part as we roll
up our sleeves and actually look at some
python coating before we start the
python coding we need to go ahead and
create a problem statement wonder what
species of Iris do these flowers belong
to let's try to predict the species of
the flowers using machine learning in
Python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and Implement
our python code and you'll find that the
first half of our implementation is all
about organizing and exploring the data
coming in let's go ahead and take this
first step which is loading the
different modules into Python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case I'm going to be using the
Anaconda Jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites certainly there's
notepad plus plus and eclipse and dozens
of others or just even using the python
terminal window any of those will work
just fine to go ahead and explore this
python coding so here we go let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter note
book and I've already opened up a new
page for Python 3 code and I'm just
going to paste this right in there and
let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python the first thing
we're going to do is from the
sklearn.datasets import load Iris now
this isn't the actual data this is just
the module that allows us to bring in
the data the load Iris and the iris is
so popular it's been around since 1936
when Ronald Fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring the different
parts of the flower and based on those
measurements predicting what kind of
flower it is and then if we're going to
do a random Forest classifier we need to
go ahead and import our random forest
classifier from the sklearn module so
sklearn dot Ensemble import random force
classifier and then we want to bring in
two more modules and these are probably
the most commonly used modules in Python
and data science with any of the other
modules that we bring in and one is
going to be pandas we're going to import
pandas as PD p is a common term used for
pandas and pandas is basically creates a
data format for us where when you create
a pandas data frame it looks like an
Excel spreadsheet and you'll see that in
a minute when we start digging deeper
into the code panda is just wonderful
because it plays nice with all the other
modules in there and then we have numpy
which is our numbers Python and the
numbers python allows us to do different
mathematical sets on here we'll see
right off the bat we're going to take
our NP and we're going to go ahead and
Seed the randomness with it with zero so
np.random.seed is seating that as zero
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because I need to make sure I have all
those loaded and then let's take a look
at the next module on here the next six
slides including this one are all about
exploring the data remember I told you
half of this is about looking at the
data and getting it all set so let's go
ahead and take this code right here the
script and let's get that over into our
jupyter notebook and and here we go
we've gone ahead and run the Imports now
I'm going to paste the code down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading the iris data and
if you remember up here we loaded the
module that tells it how to get the iris
data now we're actually assigning that
data to the variable Iris and then we're
going to go ahead and use the DF to
Define data frame
and that's going to equal PD and if you
remember that's pandas as PD so that's
our pandas
and Panda data frame and then we're
looking at Iris data and columns equals
Irish feature names
and we're going to do the DF head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our DF has created what looks like
an Excel spreadsheet and in this Excel
spreadsheet we have set the columns so
up on the top you can see the four
different columns and then we have the
data iris.data down below it's a little
confusing without knowing where this
data is coming from so let's look at the
bigger picture and I'm going to go print
I'm just going to change this for a
moment and we're going to print olivirus
and see what that looks like
so when I print all a virus I get this
long list of information and you can
scroll through here and see all the
different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary
and in a python dictionary you'll have a
key or a label and this label pulls up
whatever information comes after it so
feature names which we actually used
over here under columns is equal to an
array of simple length simple width
petal length petal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns and if you scroll down
far enough you'll also see data down
here oh goodness it came up right
towards the top and data is equal to the
different data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like Target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute and there's
also the names uh the target names which
is further down and we'll show you that
also in a minute let's go ahead and set
that back
to the Head
and this is one of the neat features of
pandas and Panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the panda
dataframe dot head it'll print the first
five lines of the data set in there
along with the headers if you have them
in this case we have the column header
set to Iris features and in here you'll
see that we have 0 1 2 3 4 in Python
most arrays always start at zero so when
you look at the first five it's going to
be zero one two three four not one two
three four five so now we've got our IRS
data imported into a data frame let's
take a look at the next piece of code in
here and so in this section here of the
code we're going to take a look at the
Target and let's go ahead and get this
into our notebook this piece of code so
we can discuss it a little bit more in
detail so here we are in our jupyter
notebook I'm going to put the code in
here and before I run it I want to look
at a couple things going on so we have a
DF species and this is interesting
because right here you'll see where I
have DF species in Brackets which is the
key code for creating another column and
here we have iris.target now these are
both in the pandas setup on here so in
pandas we can do either one I could have
just as easily done Iris and then in
Brackets Target depending on what I'm
working on both are acceptable let's go
ahead and run this code and see how this
changes and what we've done is we've
added the target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict so we have our data
which tells us the answer for all these
different pieces and then we've added a
column with the answer that way when we
do our final setup we'll have the
ability to program our our neural
network to look for these this different
data and know what a setosa is or a Vera
color which we'll see in just a minute
or virginica those are the three that
are in there and now we're going to add
one more column I know we're organizing
all this data over and over again it's
kind of fun there's a lot of ways to
organize it what's nice about putting
everything onto one data frame is I can
then do a printout and it shows me
exactly what I'm looking at and I'll
show you where you where that's
different where you can alter that and
do it slightly differently but let's go
ahead and put this into our script up to
that now and here we go we're going to
put that down here
and we're going to run that
and let's talk a little bit about what
we're doing now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is did your model work
and to do this we need to split the data
and we split it into two different parts
they usually call it the training and
the testing and so in here we're going
to go ahead and put that in our database
so you can see it clearly and we've set
it DF remember you can put brackets this
is creating another column is train so
we're going to use part of it for
training and this equals NP remember
that stands for numpy DOT random.uniform
so we're generating a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each of the rows that's where the
length DF comes from so each row gets a
generated number and if it's less than
0.75 it's true and if it's greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take 75 percent of the data roughly
because there's a Randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25 percent we're
going to hold off to the side and use
that to test it later on on so let's
flip back on over and see what the next
step is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing let's go ahead and sort that
into two different variables train and
test and let's take this code and let's
bring it into our project and here we go
let's paste it on down here and before I
run this let's just take a quick look at
what's going on here is we have up above
we created remember there's our def dot
head which prints the first five rows
and we've added a column is train at the
end and so we're going to take that
we're going to create two variables
we're going to create two new data
frames one's called train one's called
test 75 percent in train 25 in test
and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing DF our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it and if DF is trained equals
true
that's going to go in the train and if
DF is trained equals false it goes in
the test and so when I run this
we're going to print out the number in
each one let's see what that looks like
and you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module and it puts 32 in the
testing module which lets us know that
there was 150 lines of data in here so
if you went and looked at the original
data you could see that there's 150
lines and that's roughly 75 percent in
one and 25 percent for us to test our
model on afterward so let's jump back to
our code and see where this goes in the
next two steps
we want to do one more thing with our
data and let's make it readable to
humans I don't know about you but I hate
looking at zeros and ones so let's start
with the features and let's go ahead and
take those and make those readable to
humans and let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done a couple very
basic things we know that the columns in
our data frame again this is a panda
thing the DF columns
and we know the first four of them zero
one two three that'd be the first four
are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when I
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length sepa width petal
length and petal width and this should
be familiar because if you look up here
here's our column titles going across
and here's the first four
one thing I want you to notice here is
that when you're in a command line
whether it's Jupiter notebook or you're
running command line in the a terminal
window if you just put the name of it
it'll print it out this is the same as
doing print
features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code
and saving the script and running it by
remote you really need to put the print
in there but for this when I run it
you'll see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter and this is one
of the fun thing about Jupiter notebooks
is I'm just building the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that for our
final step in prepping our data before
we actually start running the training
and the testing is we're going to go
ahead and convert the species on here
into something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we've set y equal
to PD dot factorize train species of
zero so let's break this down just a
little bit we have our pandas right here
PD factorize what is factorize doing I'm
going to come back to that in just a
second let's look at what train species
is and why we're looking at the group
zero on there
and let's go up here and here is our
species
remember this on we created this whole
column here for species
and then it has cytosis cytosis cytosis
cytosa and if you scroll down enough
you'd also see virginica and Vera color
we need to convert that into something
the computer understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero because
this is in the format of a of an array
of arrays so you have to have the zero
on the end and then species is just that
column factorize goes in there and looks
at the fact that there's only three of
them so when I run this you'll see that
y generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set and it's
zeros ones and twos representing the
three different kinds of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally we get to actually start doing
the predicting so here we go we have two
lines of code oh my goodness that was a
lot of work to get to two lines of code
but there is a lot in these two lines of
code so let's take a look and see what's
going on here and put this into our full
script that we're running and let's
paste this in here and let's take a look
and see what this is we have we're
creating a variable clf and we're going
to set this equal to the random forest
classifier and we're passing two
variables in here and there's a lot of
variables you can play with as far as
these two are concerned they're very
standard in jobs all that does is to
prioritize it not something to really
worry about usually when you're doing
this on your own computer you do in jobs
equals two if you're working in a larger
or big data and you need to prioritize
it differently this is what that number
does is it changes your priorities and
how it's going to run across the system
and things like that and then the random
state is just how it starts zero is fine
for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma Y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more clf dot fit
so we're fitting we're training it we
are actually creating our random Forest
classifier right here this is a code
that does everything and we're going to
take our training set remember we kept
our test off to the side and we're going
to take our training set with the
features and then we're going to go
ahead and put that in and here's our
Target the Y so the Y is 0 1 and 2 that
we just created and the features is the
actual data going in that we put into
the training set let's go ahead and run
that
and this is kind of an interesting thing
because it printed out the random Force
classifier
and everything around it
and so when you're running this in your
terminal window or in a script like this
this automatically treats this like just
like when we were up here and I typed in
y and it printed out y instead of print
y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out but if
you're actually running your code that
wouldn't be the case and what is printed
out is it shows us all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two you can see the random State
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there you would really have to
dig deep to find out all these the
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like Max
features is auto so all the features
that we're putting in there it's just
gonna automatically take all four of
them whatever we send it it'll take some
of them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there at that point you
probably want to limit the maximum
features that you're going to process in
leaf nodes that's the end notes remember
we had the fruit and we're talking about
the leaf nodes like I said there's a lot
in this we're looking at a lot of stuff
here so you might have in this case
there's probably only think three leaf
nodes maybe four you might have
thousands of leaf nodes at which point
you do need to put a cap on that and say
okay you can only go so far and then
we're going to use all of our resources
on processing this and that really is
what most of these are about is limiting
the process and making sure we don't
overwhelm a system and there's some
other settings in here again we're not
going to go over all of them warm start
equals false forms start as if you're
programming it one piece at a time
externally since we're not we're not
going to have like we're not going to
continually to train this particular
Learning Tree and again like I said
there's a lot of things in here that
you'll want to look up more detail from
the SK learn and if you're digging in
deep and running a major project on here
for today though all we need to do is
fit or train our features and our Target
y so now we have our training model
what's next if we're going to create a
model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside the test feature test group 25 of
the data so let's go ahead and take this
code and let's put it into our script
and see what that looks like okay here
we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos which represents
the three type of flowers the setosa the
virginica and the Versa color and what
we're putting into our predict is the
test features and I always kind of like
to know what it is I am looking at so
real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of simple length sepal width pedal
length pedal width so when we put it in
this way it actually loads all these
different columns that we loaded into
features so if we did just features let
me just do features in here seeing so
what features looks like this is just
playing with the with pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test it then
takes those columns and creates a panda
data frames from those columns and in
this case
we're going to go ahead and put those
into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5.2 and we're going to put
those in and we're going to predict what
our new Forest classifier is going to
come up with and this is what it
predicts it predicts uh zero zero zero
one two one one two two two and and
again this is the flower type satosha
virginica and Versa color so now that
we've taken our test features let's
explore that let's see exactly what that
data means to us so the first thing we
can do with our predicts is we can
actually generate a different prediction
model when I say different we're going
to view it differently it's not that the
data itself is different so let's take
this next piece of code and put it into
our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh predict and
we've added underscore proba for
probability so there's our clf DOT
predict probability so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get
slightly different result and we're only
going to look at the first 10.
so you'll see down here instead of
looking at all of them which was what 27
you'll see right down here that this
generates a much larger field on the
probability and let's take a look and
see what that looks like and what that
means
so when we do the predict underscore
praba for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes at
the end and if you remember from all the
theory we did this is the predictors the
first one is predicting a one for setosa
it predicts a zero for virginica and it
predicts a zero for Versa color and so
on and so on and so on and let's uh you
know what I'm going to change this just
a little bit let's look at 10
to 20 just because we can
and we start to get a little different
of data and you'll see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0 0.5 0.5 and so if
we're going to vote and we have two
equal votes it's going to go with the
first one so it says uh satosha gets
zero votes virginica gets 0.5 votes
Versa color gets 0.5 votes but let's
just go with the virginica since these
two are equal and so on and so on down
the list you can see how they vary on
here so now we've looked at both how to
do a basic predict of the features and
we've looked at the predict probability
let's see what's next on here so now we
want to go ahead and start mapping names
for the plants we want to attach names
so that it makes a little more sense for
us and that's what we're going to do in
these next two steps we're going to
start by setting up our predictions and
mapping them to the name so let's see
what that looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it and this goes along
with the next piece of code so we'll
skip through this quickly and then come
back to it a little bit so here's Iris
dot Target names
and if you remember correctly this was
the the names that we've been talking
about this whole time the setosa
virginica versus color and then we're
going to go ahead and do the prediction
again we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we'll go
ahead and run it again clf dot predict
test features remember that Returns the
zeros of ones in the twos and then we're
going to set that equal to predictions
so this time we're actually putting it
in a variable and when I run this
hit distributes and it comes out as an
array and the array is setosis cytosis
cytosis cytosa we're only looking at the
first five we could actually do let's do
the first 25 just so we can see a little
bit more on there and you'll see that it
starts mapping it to all the different
flower types the Versa color and the
virginica in there and let's see how
this goes with the next one so let's
take a look at the top part of our
species in here and we'll take this code
and put it in our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run it and let's talk about both these
sections of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and I went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosis cytosis cytosis
cytosis that's what we're predicting
from our test model
and then we come down here we look at
test species I remember I could have
just done test dot species dot head and
you'll see it says cytosis cytosis
cytosa and they match so the first one
is what our forest is doing
and the second one is what the actual
data is now is we need to combine these
so that we can understand what that
means we need to know how good our
forest is how good it is at predicting
the features so that's where we come up
to the next step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals so we have a nice chart to look
at and let's go ahead and put that in
our script in our Jupiter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then I'm going to because I'm on
the Jupiter notebook I can do a control
minus you can see the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here we're
going to create in pandas remember PD
stands for pandas and we're doing a
cross tab this function takes two sets
of data and creates a chart out of them
so when I run it you'll get a nice chart
down here and we have the predicted
species
so across the top you'll see the satosha
versus color virginica and the actual
species sistosa versicolor virginica and
so the way to read this chart and let's
go ahead and take a look on how to read
this chart here when you read this chart
you have setosa where they meet you have
versicolor where they meet and you have
virginica where they meet and they're
meeting where the actual and the
predicted agree so this is the number of
accurate predictions so in this case it
equals 30. if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12
you get 30. and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versacolor this is
inaccurate so now we have two two
inaccurate predictions and 30 accurate
predictions so I will say that the model
accuracy is 93 that's just 30 divided by
32 and if we multiply it by a hundred we
can say that it is 93 percent accurate
so we have a 93 accuracy with our model
I did want to add one more quick thing
in here on our scripting before we wrap
it up so let's flip back on over to my
script in here we're going to take this
line of code from up above I don't know
if you remember it but predicts equals
the iris dot Target underscore names so
we're going to map it to the names and
we're going to run the prediction and we
read it on test features but you know
we're not just testing it we want to
actually deploy it so at this point I
would go ahead and change this and this
is an array of arrays this is really
important when you're running these to
know that
so you need the double brackets and I
could actually create data maybe let's
let's just do two flowers so maybe I'm
processing more data coming in and we'll
put two flowers in here
and then I actually want to see what the
answer is so let's go ahead and type in
preds and print that out and when I run
this
you'll see that I've now predicted two
flowers so maybe I measured in my front
yard as versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since I put the same data
in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
last week my son and I visited a fruit
shop dad is that an apple or a
strawberry so the question comes up what
fruit do they just pick up from the
Fruit Stand after a couple of seconds
you could figure out that it was a
strawberry so let's take this model a
step further and let's uh why not build
a model which can predict an unknown
data and in this we're going to be
looking at some sweet strawberries or
crispy apples we want it to be able to
label those two and decide what the
fruit is and we do that by having data
already put in so we already have a
bunch of strawberries we know our
strawberries and they're already labeled
as such we already have a bunch of
apples we know our apples and are
labeled as such then once we train our
model that model then can be given the
new data and the new data is this image
in this case you can see a question mark
on it and it comes through and goes it's
a strawberry in this case we're using
the support Vector Machine model svm is
a supervised learning method that looks
at data and sorts it into one of two
categories and in this case we're
sorting the strawberry into the
strawberry side at this point point you
should be asking the question how does
the prediction work before we dig into
an example with numbers let's apply this
to our fruit scenario we have our
support Vector machine we've taken it
and we've taken labeled sample of data
strawberries and apples and we've drawn
a line down the middle between the two
groups this split now allows us to take
new data in this case an apple and a
strawberry and place them in the
appropriate group based on which side of
the line they fall in and that way we
can predict the unknown as colorful and
tasty as the food example is let's take
a look at another example with some
numbers involved and we can take a
closer look at how the math Works in
this example we're going to be
classifying men and women and we're
going to start with a set of people with
a different height and a different
weight and to make this work we'll have
to have a sample data set a female where
you have their height and weight 174 65
174 88 and so on and we'll need a sample
data set of the male they have a height
179 90 180 to 80 and so on let's go
ahead and put this on a graph so we have
a nice visual so you can see here we
have two groups based on the height
versus the weight and on the left side
we're going to have the women on the
right side we're going to have them in
now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we draw in two lines through the data in
the middle that separates some men from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we we can also say that the
distance between the points and the line
should be as far as possible in
technical terms we can say the distance
between the support vector and the
hyperplane should be as far as possible
and this is where the support vectors
are the extreme points in the data set
and if you look at this data set they
have circled two points which seem to be
right on the outskirts of the women and
one on the outskirts of the men and
hyperplane has a maximum distance to the
support vectors of any class now you'll
see the line down the middle and we call
this the hyperplane because when you're
dealing with multiple Dimensions it's
really not just a line but a plane of
intersections and you can see here where
the support vectors have been drawn in
dashed lines the math behind this is
very simple we take D plus the shortest
distance to the closest positive point
which would be on the Min side and D
minus is the shortest distance to the
closest negative point which is on the
women's side the sum of D plus and D
minus is called the distance margin or
the distance between the two support
vectors that are shown in the dashed
lines and then by finding the largest
distance margin we can get the optimal
hyperplane once we've created an optimal
hyperplane we can easily see which side
the new data fits in and based on the
hyperplane we can say the new data point
belongs to the male gender hopefully
that's clear how that works on a visual
level as a data scientist you should
also be asking what happens if the
hyperplane is not optimal if we select a
hyperplane having low margin then there
is a high chance of misclassification
this particular svm model the one we
discussed so far is also called referred
to as the ls VM so far so clear but a
question should be coming up we have our
sample data set but instead of looking
like this what if it looked like this
where we have two sets of data but one
of them occurs in the middle of another
set you can see here where we have the
blue and the yellow and then blue again
on the other side of our data line in
this data set we can't use a hyperplane
so when you see data like this it's
necessary to move away from a 1D view of
the data to a two-dimensional view of
the data and for the transformation we
use what's called a kernel function the
kernel function will take the 1D input
and transfer it to a two-dimensional
output as you can see in this picture
here the 1D when transferred to a
two-dimensional makes it very easy to
draw a line between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
date on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyperplane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2D to a 3D
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example in and dive
into the script let's look at the
advantage of the support Vector machine
we'll start with high dimensional input
space or sometimes referred to as the
curse of dimensionality we looked at
earlier one dimension two Dimension
three dimension when you get to a
thousand dimensions a lot of problems
start occurring with most algorithms
that have to be adjusted for the svm
automatically does that in high
dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize the
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
I've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the realization
parameter or Lambda is a parameter that
helps figure out whether we're going to
have a bias or overfitting of the data
whether it's going to be overfitted to a
very specific instance or it's going to
be biased to a high or low value with
the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms these three
advantages of the support Vector machine
make it a very powerful tool to add to
your repertoire of machine learning
tools now we did promise you a used case
study we're actually going to dive into
some Python Programming and so we're
going to go into a problem statement and
start off with the zoo so in the zoo
example we have family members going to
the zoo we have the young child going
dad is that a group of crocodiles or
alligators well that's hard to
differentiate and zoos are a great place
to start looking at science and
understanding how things work especially
as a young child and so we can see the
parents sitting here thinking well what
is the difference between a crocodile
and an alligator well one crocodiles are
larger in size alligators are smaller in
size snout width the crocodiles have a
narrow snout and alligators have a wider
snout and of course in the modern day
and age the father sitting there is
thinking how can I turn this into a
lesson for my son and he goes let a
support Vector machine segregate the two
groups I don't know if my dad ever told
me that but that would be funny now in
this example we're not going to use
actual measurements in data we're just
using that for imagery and that's very
common in a lot of machine learning
algorithms and setting them up but let's
roll up our sleeves and we'll talk about
that more in just a moment as we break
into our python script so here we arrive
in our actual coding and I'm going to
move this into a python editor in just a
moment but let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to cover first we're
going to cover in the code the setup how
to actually create our svm and you're
going to find that there's only two
lines of code that actually create it
and the rest of it is done so quick and
fast that it's all here in the first
page and we'll show you what that looks
like as far as our data because we're
going to create some data I talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just a second and then the second
part is we're going to take this and
we're going to bump it up a notch we're
going to show you what it looks like
behind the scenes but let's start with
actually creating our setup I like to
use the Anaconda Jupiter notebook
because it's very easy to use but you
can use any of your favorite python
editors or setups and go in there but
let's go ahead and switch over there and
see what that looks like so here we are
in the Anaconda python notebook or
anaconda jupyter notebook with python
we're using python3 I believe this is
3.5 but it should be work in any of your
3x versions and you'd have to look at
the SK learn and make sure if you're
using a 2X version an earlier version
let's go and put our code in there and
one of the things I like about the
jupyter notebook is I go up to view and
I'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier to talk about and we can even
increase the size because this is edited
in in this case I'm using Google Chrome
Explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor although anyone any like I
said any editor will work now the first
step is going to be our Imports and
we're going to import four different
parts the first two I want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as NP and
matplotlibrary.pi plot as PLT now these
are very standardized Imports when
you're doing work the first one is the
numbers python we need that because part
of the platform we're using uses that
for the numpy array and I'll talk about
that in a minute so you can understand
why we want to use a numpy array versus
the standard python array and normally
it's pretty standard setup to use NP for
numpy the map plot library is how we're
going to view our data so this has you
do need the NP for the SK learn module
but the matplot library is purely for
our use for visualization and so you
really don't need that for the svm but
we're going to put it there so you have
a nice visual aid and we can show you
what it looks like that's really
important at the end when you finish
everything so you have a nice display
for everybody to look at and then
finally we're going to I'm going to jump
one ahead to line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samples generator
import make blobs and I told you that we
were going to make up data and this is a
tool that's in the SK learning makeup
data I personally don't want to go to
the zoo get in trouble for jumping over
the fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as I work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length instead we're just going to make
up some data and that's what that make
blobs is It's a Wonderful tool if you're
ready to test your your setup and you're
not sure about what data you're going to
put in there you can create this blob
and it makes it real easy to use and
finally we have our actual svm the
sklearn import svm on line three so that
covers all our Imports we're going to
create remember I used the make blobs to
create data and we're going to create a
capital x and a lowercase y equals make
blobs in samples equals 40. so we're
going to make 40 lines of data it's
going to have two centers with a random
State equals 20s which each each group
is going to have 20 different pieces of
data in it and the way that lux is it
will have under X an X Y plane so I have
two numbers under X and Y will be 0 1.
that's the two different centers so we
have yes or no in this case alligator or
crocodile that's what that represents
and then I told you that the the actual
SK learner the svm is in two lines of
code and we see it right here with clf
equals
svm.svc kernel equals linear and I set
SQL to 1 although in this example since
we are not regularizing the data because
we want to be very clear and easy to see
I went ahead you can set it to a
thousand a lot of times when you're not
doing that but for this thing linear
because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyper plane
it'll be a nice linear line instead of a
full plane so we're not dealing with a
huge amount of data and then all we have
to do is do clf dot fit X comma Y and
that's it clf has been created and then
we're going to go ahead and display it
and I'm going to talk about this display
here in just a second but let me go
ahead and run this code and this is what
we've done is we've created two blobs
you'll see the blue on the side and then
kind of an orangish on the other side
that's our two sets of data they
represent one represents crocodiles and
one represents alligators and then we
have our measurements and in this case
we have like the width and length of the
snout and I did say I was going to come
up here and talk just a little bit about
our plot and you'll see PLT that's what
we imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
I have the capital x and then in
brackets I have a colon comma zero
that's from numpy if you did that in a
regular array you'll get an error in a
python array you have to have that in a
numpy array it turns out that our make
blobs returns a numpy array and this
notation is great because what it means
is the first part is the colon means
we're going to do all the rows that's
all the data in our blob we created
under capital x and then the second part
has a comma zero we're only going to
take the first value and then if you
notice we do the same thing but we're
going to take the second value remember
we always start with zero and then one
so we have column 0 and column one and
you can look at this as our X Y plots
the first one is the X plot and the
second one is the Y plot so the first
one is on the bottom zero two four six
eight and ten and then the second one X
of the one is the four five six seven
eight nine ten going up the left hand
side s equals Thirty is just the size of
the dot so we can see them instead of
real tiny dots and then the C map equals
plt.cm dot paired and you'll also see
the C equals y That's the color we're
using two colors zero one and that's why
we get the nice blue and the two
different colors for the alligator and
the crocodile now you can see here that
we did this the actual fit was done in
two lines of code a lot of times
there'll be a third line where we
regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice because you can
actually see what's going on and then if
we wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case I am giving it a width and
length 3 4 and a width and length five
six and note that I put the data as a
set of brackets and then I have the
brackets inside and the reason I do that
is because when we're looking at data
it's designed to process a large amount
of data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case I'm processing two lines and
then I'm just going to print and you'll
see clf.predict new data so the clf and
the dot predict part is going to give us
an answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 0 1 so predicted the
first one the three four is going to be
on the one side and the 5 6 is going to
be on the other side so one came out as
an alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for this setup but really we
want to dug in and see what's going on
behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like so the next step is to
dig in deep and find out what's going on
behind the scenes and also put that in a
nice pretty graph we're going to spend
more work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and I'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and I'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up and finally we're going
to plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyper plane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our Jupiter notebook
before I scroll down to a new line I
want you to notice line 13 it has Plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and I'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the the top here of our
new section one two three and four is
the same code we had before and let's go
back up here and take a look at that
we're going to fit the values on our svm
and then we're going to plot scatter it
and then we're going to do a plot show
so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code well when you do
the plot show that blanks out what's in
the plot so once I've done this Plot
show I have to reload that data now we
could do this simply by removing it up
here re-running it and then coming down
here and then we wouldn't have to rerun
these first four lines of code now in
this it doesn't matter too much and
you'll see the plot show is down here
and then removed right there on line
five I'll go ahead and just delete that
out of there because we don't want to
blank out our screen we want to move on
to the next setup so we can go ahead and
just skip the first four lines because
we did that before and let's take a look
at the ax equals
plt.gca now right now we're actually
spending a lot of time just graphing
that's all all we're doing here okay so
this is how we display a nice graph with
our results and our data ax is very
standard used variable when you're
talking about PLT and it's just setting
it to that axis the last axes in the PLT
it can get very confusing if you're
working with many different layers of
data on the same graph and this makes a
very easy to reference the ax so this
reference is looking at the PLT that we
created and we already mapped out our
two blobs on and then we want to know
the limits so we want to know how big
the graph is we can find out the X limit
and the Y limit simply with the get X
limit and get y limit commands which is
part of our matplot library and then
we're going to create a grid and you'll
see down here we have we've set the
variable XX equal to NP dot line Space X
limit zero X limit 1 comma 30 and we've
done the same thing for the y space and
then we're going to go in here and we
create a mesh grid and this is a numpy
command so we're back to our numbers
python let's go through what these numpy
commands mean with the line space and
the mesh grid we've taken XX small x x
equals MP line space and we have our X
limit 0 and our X limit 1 and we're
going to create 30 points on it and
we're going to do the same thing for the
y-axis now this has nothing to do with
our evaluation it's all we're doing is
we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between 0
and the X limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the Y and then
the mesh grid Loops those all together
so it forms a nice grid so if we were
going to do this say between the limit 0
and 10 and do 10 points we would have a
0 0 1 1 0 1 0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on
you can just imagine a point at Each
corner of one of those boxes and the
mesh grid combines them all so we take
the YY and the XX we created and creates
the full grid and we've set that grid
into the YY coordinates and the XX
coordinates now remember we're working
with number in Python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being X comma 1 you know X comma Y
and then X2 comma Y2 and this in the
next set of data it would be a column of
x's and a column of y's and that's what
we have here is we have a column of y's
and we put it as a capital y y and a
column of x's capital x x with all those
different points being listed and
finally we get down to the numpy v stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into one array X Y array now that we've
created the stack of data points we're
going to do something interesting here
we're going to create a value Z and the
Z equals the clf that's our that's our
support Vector machine we created and
we've already trained and we have a DOT
decision function and we're going to put
the X Y in there so here we have all
this data we're going to put that X Y in
there that data we're going to reshape
it and you'll see that we have the XX
dot shape in here this this literally
takes the XX resets it up connected to
the Y and the Z value lets us know
whether it is the left hand side it's
going to generate three different values
the Z value does and it'll tell us
whether that data is a support Vector to
the left the hyperplane in the middle or
the support Vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so if they're right
on a line on those three different lines
so we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so that's
900 points of data and we separate it
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our matplot library where we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
Contour Capital XX capital y y these
have been reshaped to fit those lines Z
is the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we we can set the colors
equals K and I told you we had three
different labels but we have three
levels of data the alpha is just makes
it kind of see-through so it's only 0.5
of the value in there so when we graph
it the data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line Styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be Dash dashed lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax dot scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dashed line and the dashed line on
that grid and you can see here when we
do the clf Dot support vectors we are
looking at column 0 and column one and
then again we have the S equals 100 so
we're going to make them larger and the
line width equals one face colors equals
none let's take a look and see what that
looks like when we show it and you can
see we get down to our end result it
creates a really nice graph we we have
our two support vectors and dashed lines
and they have the near data so you can
see those two points or in this case the
Four Points where those lines nicely
cleave the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator congratulations you've
done it we've made it of course these
are pretend data for our crocodiles and
alligators but this Hands-On example
will help you to encounter any support
Vector machine projects in the future
and you can see how easy they are to set
up and look at in depth today we're
going to cover the K nearest neighbors
that refer to as k n n and KNN is really
a fundamental place to start in the
machine learning it's the basis of a lot
of other things and just the logic
behind it is easy to understand and
Incorporated in other forms of machine
learning so today what's in it for you
why why do we need k n n what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does KNN algorithm work and then
we'll dive in to my favorite part the
use case predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model Builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog a little kid looking over
there and watching the black cat cross
their path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats cats have sharp
claws uses to climb smaller length of
ears meows and purrs doesn't love to
play around dogs they have dull claws
bigger length of ears barks loves to run
around you usually don't see a cat
running around people otherwise do have
a cat that does that we're dogs do and
we can look at these we can say we can
evaluate the sharpness of the claws how
sharp are their claws and we can
evaluate the length of the ears and we
can usually sort out cats from dogs
based on even those two characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog an
odd question usually little kids no cats
and dogs by now unless you live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has a smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because KNN is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using KNN classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is KNN what is the k
n algorithm K nearest neighbors is what
that stands for it's one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification so we
want to know is this a dog or is not a
dog is it a cat or not a cat it
classifies a data point based on how his
neighbors are classified KNN stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we've gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine k n stores
all available cases and classifies new
cases based on a similarity measure and
here you see we have a measurement of
sulfur dioxide versus a chloride level
and then the different wines they've
tested and where they fall on that graph
based on how much sulfur dioxide and how
much chloride K and K N is a perimeter
that refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals
five we'll talk about K in just a minute
a data point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five nearest
neighbors here the unknown point would
be classified as red since four out of
five neighbors are red so how do we
choose K how do we know k equals five I
mean that's was the value we put in
there so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose the factor K and N
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of K is a
process called parameter tuning and is
important for better accuracy so at k
equals three we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this as a square and if we put k
equals to 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around it you can see as the K changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of K you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these facts
factors that's the face you get he's
like oh my gosh you say choose the right
K did I set it right my values in
whatever machine learning tool you're
looking at so that you don't have a huge
bias in One Direction or the other and
in terms of knnn the number of K if you
choose it too low the bias is based on
it's just too noisy it's it's right next
to a couple things and it's going to
pick those things and you might get a
skewed answer and if your K is too big
then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
also if it's an even number so if you're
using uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of n and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use knnn we can use K N when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where you might
get into a gig of data if it's really
clean it doesn't have a lot of noise
because K N is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knnn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does the K N algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we can see right here we have two
variables you know true false are either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using k n n so
if we have new data coming in this says
57 kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance D equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus B squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're Computing the third Edge
since we know the X side and the Y side
let's calculate it to understand clearly
so we have our unknown point and we
placed it there in red and we have our
other points where the data is scattered
around the distance D1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13 and distance 3 is
about 13.4 similarly we will calculate
the euclidean distance of unknown data
point from all the points in the data
set and because we're dealing with small
amount of data that's not that hard to
do and it's actually pretty quick for a
computer and it's not a really
complicated Mass you can just see how
close is the data based on the euclidean
distance hence we have calculated the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from all the points as shown where X1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the
euclidean distance who's going to be
their closest neighbors now let's
calculate the nearest neighbor at k
equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors put some at normal and
that's pretty self-evident when you look
at this graph it's pretty easy to say
okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal three votes for normal
this is going to be a normal weight so
majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of k n n positive
integer K is specified along with a new
sample we select the K entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in Python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through I
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight eight columns with a
particular attribute and then the ninth
column which is the outcome is whether
they have diabetes as a data scientist
the first thing you should be looking at
is insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes that's why
they're taking it well that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages but for a very basic setup this
works fine for doing the KNN and the
next thing you notice is it didn't take
very much to open it up I can scroll
down to the bottom of the data there's
768. it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer computer I
can look at it I can manipulate it and
it's not going to really tax just a
regular desktop computer you don't even
need an Enterprise version to run a lot
of this so let's start with importing
all the tools we need and before that of
course we need to discuss what IDE I'm
using certainly can use any particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the jupyter notebook and just a
quick view of the Anaconda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python36 I have a couple
different versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where you can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm going
it's going to open up Chrome because
that's my default that I use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see I have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and since we're
working on the KNN predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and I'm
also going to go up here and click on
Cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then I'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
I'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run this python it's a markdown language
so if I run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our Imports we're going to import
the pandas as PD import numpy is NP
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here so we have our
Imports so even brought in our pandas
are numpy our two general python tools
and then you can see over here we have
our train test split by now you should
be familiar with splitting the data we
want to split part of it for training
our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between
-1 and 1. and then the actual tool this
is the K neighbors classifier we're
going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
Matrix our F1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the SK learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
PD and we'll take a look at the data in
Python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually I like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read CSV that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder I just put in the
same folder where my IPython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick Links of the data set
that is a simple python on command Len
for length we might even let's go ahead
and print that we'll go print and if you
do it on its own line links that data
set in the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there if you put a bunch of
these in a row you know the data set one
head data set two head it only prints
out the last one so I usually always
like to keep the print statement in
there but because most projects only use
one data frame pandas data frame doing
it this way it doesn't really matter the
other way works just fine and you can
see when we hit the Run button we have
the 768 lines which we knew and we have
our pregnancies it's automatically given
a label on the left remember the head
only shows the first five lines so we
have zero through four and just a quick
look at the data you can see it matches
what we looked at before we have
pregnancy glucose blood pressure sure
all the way to H and then the outcome on
the end and we're going to do a couple
things in this next step we're going to
create a list of columns where we can't
have zero there's no such thing as zero
skin thickness or zero blood pressure
zero glucose any of those you'd be dead
so not a really good Factor if they
don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data and
we'll take a look at that because we're
going to start replacing that
information with a couple of different
things and let's see what that looks
like so first we create a nice list as
you can see we have the values talked
about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
Panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the N A but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column dot
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the Nan num pnan is
what that stands for is none it doesn't
exist so the first thing we're doing
here is we're replacing the zero with a
numpy none there's no data there that's
what that says that's what this is
saying right here so put the 0 in and
we're going to play zeros with no data
so if it's a zero that means a person's
well hopefully not dead hope they just
didn't get the data the next thing we
want to do is we're going to create the
mean which is the integer from the data
set from the column dot mean where we
skip in A's we can do that and that is a
pandas command there the skip n a so
we're going to figure out the mean of
that data set and then we're going to
take that data set column and we're
going to replace all the npnan with the
means why did we do that and we could
have actually just taken this step and
gone right down here and just replace 0
and Skip anything where except you can
actually there's a way to skip zeros and
then just replace all the zeros but in
this case we want to go ahead and do it
this way so you can see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average person so if we
don't know what it is if they did not
get the data and the data is missing one
of the tricks is you replace it with the
average what is the most common data for
that this way you can still use the rest
of those values to do your computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data if you want to
see what that looks like we don't have
anything the first few lines just not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with the printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones that shows you can see I
skipped a bunch in the middle because
that's what it does we have too many
lines in Jupiter notebook he'll skip a
few and and go on to the next in a data
set let me go and remove this and we'll
just zero out that and of course before
we do any processing before proceeding
any further we need to split the data
set into our train and testing data that
way we have something to train it with
and something to test it on and you're
going to notice we did a little
something here with the pandas database
code there we go my drawing tool we've
added in this right here off the data
set and what this says is that the first
one in pandas this is from the PD pandas
it's going to say within the data set we
want to look at the eye location and it
is all rows that's what that says so
we're going to keep all the rows but
we're only looking at zero columns 0 To
8. Remember column nine here it is right
up here we printed it in here as outcome
well that's not part of the training
data that's part of the answer yes
column nine but it's listed as eight
number eight so zero to eight is nine
columns so 8 is the value and when you
see it in here zero this is actually
zero to seven it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to Y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column eight and you can
do it this way with this particular
notation and then if you remember we
imported the train test split that's
part of the SK learn right there and we
simply put in our X and our y we're
going to do random State equals zero you
don't have to necessarily seed it that's
a seed number I think the default is one
when you seed it I'd have to look that
up and then the test size test size is
0.2 that simply means we're going to
take 20 percent of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual running of our k n n we need to
go ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard Taylor which means
instead of the data being from you know
five to three hundred and three in one
column and the next column is one to six
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between minus one and one
that's what that standard scalar does
keeps it standardized and we only want
to fit the scalar with the training set
but we want to make sure the testing set
is the X test going in is also
transformed so it's processing it the
same so here we go with our standard
scalar we're going to call it SC
underscore X for the scalar and we're
going to import the standard scalar into
this variable and then our X train
equals SC underscore x dot fit transform
so we're creating the scalar on the X
train variable and then our X test we're
also going to transform it so we've
trained and transformed the X train and
then the X test isn't part of that
training it isn't part of the of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to run this and if you look
at this we've now now gone through these
steps all three of them we've taken care
of replacing our zeros for key columns
it shouldn't be zero and we replace that
with the means of those columns that way
that they fit right in with our data
models we've come down here we split the
data so now we have our test data and
our training data and then we've taken
and we've scaled the data so all of our
data going in now no we don't TR we
don't train the Y part the Y train and Y
test that never has to be trained it's
only the data going in that's what we
want to train in there then Define the
model using K neighbors classifier and
fit the train data in the model so we do
all that data prep and you can see down
here we're only going to have a couple
lines of code where we're actually
building our model and training it
that's one of the cool things about
Python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick link X of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root let's do
y train there we go that's actually
supposed to be X train before we do this
let's go ahead and do import math and do
math square root length of Y test and
when I run that we get 12.409 I want to
see show you where this number comes
from we're about to use 12 is an even
number so if you know if you're ever
voting on things remember the neighbors
all vote don't want to have an even
number of neighbors voting so we want to
do something odd and let's just take one
away we'll make it 11. let me delete
this out of here that's one of the
reasons I love Jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier n neighbor is
equal 11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for
11. we have an odd number of neighbors P
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the euclidean metric there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion Matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion Matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the F1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion Matrix why
test why predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the Y predicted which would be
your title up here we could do let's
just do pred
predicted across the top and actual
going down
actually it's always hard to write in
here actual that means that this column
here down the middle that's the
important column and it means that our
prediction said 94 and prediction in the
actual agreed on 94 and 32. this number
here the 13 and the 15 those are what
was wrong so you could have like three
different if you're looking at this
across three different variables instead
of just two you'd end up with the third
row down here in the column going down
the middle so in the first case we have
the the and I believe the zero has a 94
people who don't have diabetes the
prediction said that 13 of those people
did have diabetes and were at high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct but our prediction said another
15 out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect so you can see where that
classification comes in and how that
works on the confusion Matrix then we're
going to go ahead and print the F1 score
let me just run that and you see we get
a 0.69 in our F1 score the F1 takes into
account both sides of the balance of
false positives where if we go ahead and
just do the accuracy account and that's
what most people think of is it looks at
just how many we got right out of how
many we got wrong so a lot of people
when you're a data scientist and you're
talking to other data scientists they're
going to ask you what the F1 score the F
score is if you're talking to the
general public or the decision makers in
the business they're going to ask what
the accuracy is and the accuracy is
always better than the F1 score but the
F1 scores more telling it lets us know
that there's more false positives than
we would like on here but 82 percent not
too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different statistics and
running an sklearn and running the k n n
the K nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or the very East whether
they should go get a checkup and have
their glucose checked regularly or not
the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model what is skin means
clustering k-means clustering is an
unsupervised learning algorithm in this
case you don't have labeled data unlike
in supervised learning so you have a set
of data and you want to group them and
as the name suggests you want to put
them into clusters which means objects
that are similar in nature similar in
characteristics need to be put together
so that's what K means clustering is all
about the term k is basically is a
number so you need to tell the system
how many clusters you need to perform so
if K is equal to 2 there will be two
clusters if K is equal to 3 3 clusters
and so on and so forth that's what the k
stands for and of because there is a way
of finding out what is the best or
Optimum value of K for a given data we
will look at that so that is K means
cluster so let's take an example K means
clustering is used in many many
scenarios but let's take an example of
Cricket the game of cricket let's say
you received data of a lot of players
from maybe all over the country or all
over the world and this data has
information about the runs scored by the
people or by the player and the wickets
taken by the player and based on this
information we need to Cluster this data
into two clusters batsman and Bowlers so
this is an interesting example let's see
how we can perform this so we have the
data which consists of primarily two
characteristics which is the runs and
the wickets so the bowlers basically
take wickets and the batsman score runs
there will be of course a few Bowlers
who can score some runs and similarly
there will be some batsmen who will Who
would have taken a few wickets but with
this information we want to Cluster
those players into batsmen and Ballers
so how does this work let's say this is
how the data is so there are information
there is information on the y-axis about
the runs code and on the x-axis about
the wickets taken by the players so if
we do a quick plot this is how it would
look and when we do the clustering we
need to have the Clusters like shown in
the third diagram out here we need to
have a cluster which consists of people
who have scored High runs which is
basically the batsman and then we need a
cluster with people who have taken a lot
of wickets which is typically the
bowlers there may be a certain amount of
overlap but we will not talk about it
right now so with cayman's clustering we
we will have here that means K is equal
to 2 and we will have two clusters which
is batsman and Bowlers so how does this
work the way it works is the first step
in k-means clustering is the allocation
of two centroids randomly so two points
are assigned as so-called centroids so
in this case we want two clusters which
means K is equal to two so two points
have been randomly assigned as centroids
keep in mind these points can be
anywhere there are random points they
are not initially they are not really
the centroids centroid means it's a
central point of a given data set but in
this case when it starts off it's not
really the centroid okay so these points
though in our presentation here we have
shown them one point closer to these
data points and another closer to these
data points they can be assigned
randomly in anywhere okay so that's the
first step the next step is to determine
the distance of each of the data points
from each of the randomly assigned
centroids so for example we take this
point and find the distance from this
centroid and the distance from this
center right this point is taken and the
distance is found from this centroid and
this Center and so on and so forth so
for every point the distance is measured
from both the centroids and then
whichever distance is less that point is
assigned to that centroid so for example
in this case visually it is very obvious
that all these data points are assigned
to this centroid and all these data
points are assigned to this centroid and
that's what is represented here in blue
color and in this yellow color the next
step is to actually determine the
central point or the actual centroid for
these two clusters so we have this 1
initial cluster this one initial cluster
but as you can see these points are not
really the centroid centroid means it
should be the central position of this
data set Central position of this data
set so that is what needs to be
determined as the next step so the
central point on the actual centroid is
determined and the original randomly
allocated centroid is repositioned to
the actual centroid of this new clusters
and this process is actually repeated
now what might happen is some of these
points may get reallocated in our
example that is not happening probably
but it may so happen that the distance
is found between each of these data
points once again with these centroids
and if there is if it is required some
points may be reallocated we will see
that in a later example but for now we
will keep it simple so this process is
continued till the centroid
repositioning stops and that is our
final cluster so this is our so after
iteration we come to this position this
situation where the centroid doesn't
need any more repositioning and that
means our algorithm has converged
convergence has occurred and we have the
cluster two clusters we have the
Clusters with a centroid so this process
is repeated the process of calculating
the distance and repositioning the
centroid is repeated till the
repositioning stops which means that the
algorithm has converged and we have the
final cluster with the data points and
the centroids so this is what you're
going to learn from this session we will
talk about the types of clustering what
is k-means clustering application of
k-means clustering k-means clustering is
done using distance measure so we will
talk about the common distance measures
and then we will talk about how k-means
clustering works and go into the details
of k-means clustering algorithm and then
we will end with the demo and a use case
for k-means clustering so let's begin
first of all what are the types of
clustering there are primarily two
categories of clustering hierarchical
clustering and then partitional
clustering and each of these categories
are further subdivided into
agglomerative and divisive clustering
and k-means and fuzzy c means clustering
let's take a quick look at what each of
these types of clustering are in
hierarchical clustering the Clusters
have a tree-like structure and
hierarchical clustering is further
divided into agglomerative and divisive
agglomerative clustering is the
bottom-up approach we begin with each
element as a separate cluster and merge
them into successively larger clusters
so for example we have ABCDEF we start
by combining B and C form one cluster
DNA form one more then we combine d e
and f one more bigger cluster and then
add BC to that and then finally a to it
compared to that divisive clustering or
divisive clustering is a top-down
approach we begin with the whole set and
proceed to divide it into successively
smaller clusters so we have a b c d e f
we first take that as a single cluster
and then break it down into a b c d e
and f then we have partitional
clustering split into two subtypes
k-means clustering and fuzzy c means in
k-min's clustering the objects are
divided into the number of clusters
mentioned by the number K that's where
the K comes from so if we say k is equal
to 2 the objects are divided into two
clusters C1 and C2 and the way it is
done is the features or characteristics
are compared and all objects having
similar characteristics are clubbed
together so that's how K means
clustering is done we will see it in
more detail as we move forward and fuzzy
c means is very similar to k-means in
the sense that it clubs objects that
have similar characteristics together
but while in k-min's clustering two
objects cannot belong to or any object a
single object cannot belong to two
different clusters in c means objects
can belong to more than one cluster so
that is the primary difference between K
means and fuzzy c means so what are some
of the applications of k-means
clustering k-means clustering is used in
a variety of examples or variety of
business cases in real life starting
from academic performance diagnostic
system search engines and wireless
sensor networks and many more so let us
take a little deeper look at each of
these examples academic performance So
based on the scores of the students
students are categorized into a b c and
so on clustering forms a backbone of
search engines when a search is
performed the search results need to be
grouped together the search engines very
often use clustering to do this and
similarly in case of wireless sensor
networks the clustering algorithm plays
the role of finding the cluster heads
which collects all the data in its
respective cluster so clustering
especially k-means clustering uses
distance measure so let's take a look at
what is distance pressure so while these
are the different types of clustering in
this video we will focus on k-means
clustering so distance measure tells how
similar some objects are so the
similarity is measured using what is
known as distance measure and what are
the various types of distance measures
there is euclidean distance there is
Manhattan distance then we have squared
euclidean distance measure and cosine
distance measure these are some of the
distance measures supported by k-means
clustering let's take a look at each of
these what is euclidean distance measure
this is nothing but the distance between
two points so we have learned in high
school how to find the distance between
two points this is a little
sophisticated formula for that but we
know a simpler one is square root of Y2
minus y1 whole square plus x 2 minus X1
whole Square so this is an extension of
this formula so that is the euclidean
distance between two points what is the
squared euclidean distance measure it's
nothing but the square of the euclidean
distance as the name suggests so instead
of taking the square root we leave the
square as it is and then we have
Manhattan distance measure in case of
Manhattan distance it is the sum of the
distances across the x-axis and the
y-axis and note that we are taking the
absolute value so that the negative
values don't come into play so that is
the Manhattan distance measure then we
have cosine distance measure in this
case we take the angle between the two
vectors formed by joining the points
from the origin so that is the cosine
distance measure okay so that was a
quick overview about the various
distance measures that are supported by
K means now let's go and check how
exactly K means clustering works okay so
this is how k-min's clustering works
this is like a flowchart of the whole
process there is a starting point and
then we specify the number of clusters
that we want now there are a couple of
ways of doing this we can do by trial
and error so we specify a certain number
maybe K is equal to 3 or 4 or 5 to start
with and then as we progress we keep
changing until we get the best clusters
or there is a technique called elbow
technique whereby we can determine the
value of K what should be the best value
of K how many clusters should be formed
so once we have the value of K we
specify that and then the system will
assign that many centroid so it picks
randomly that to start with randomly
that many points that are considered to
be the centroids of these clusters and
then it measures the distance of each of
the data points from these centroids and
assigns those points to the
corresponding centroid from which the
distance is minimum so each data point
will be assigned to the centroid Which
is closest to it and thereby we have K
number of initial clusters however this
is not the final clusters The Next Step
it does is for the new groups for the
Clusters that have been formed it
calculates the main position thereby
calculates the new centroid position the
position of the centroid moves compared
to the randomly allocated one so it's a
nitrative process once again the
distance of each point is measured from
this new centroid point and if required
the data points are reallocated to the
new centroids and the mean position or
the new centroid is calculated once
again if the centroid moves then the
iteration continues which means the
convergence has not happened the
clustering has not converged so as long
as there is a movement of the centroid
this iteration keeps happening but once
the centroid stops moving which means
that the cluster has converged or the
clustering process has converged that
will be the end result so now we have
the final position of the centroid and
the data points are allocated
accordingly to the closest centroid I
know it's a little difficult to
understand from this simple flowchart so
let's do a little bit of visualization
and see if we can explain it better
let's take an example if we have a data
set for a grocery shop so let's say we
have a data set for a grocery shop and
now we want to find out how many
clusters this has to be spread across so
how do we find the optimum number of
clusters there is a technique called the
elbow method so when these clusters are
formed there is a parameter called
within sum of squares and the lower this
value is the better the cluster is that
means all these points are very close to
each other so we use this within sum of
squares as a measure to find the optimum
number of class Masters that can be
formed for a given data set so we create
clusters or we let the system create
clusters of a variety of numbers maybe
of 10 10 clusters and for each value of
K the within SS is measured and the
value of K which has the least amount of
within SS or WSS that is taken as the
optimum value of K so this is the
diagrammatic representation so we have
on the y-axis the within sum of squares
or WSS and on the x-axis we have the
number of clusters so as you can imagine
if you have K is equal to 1 which means
all the data points are in a single
cluster the witnesses value will be very
high because they are probably scattered
all over the moment you split it into
two there will be a drastic fall in the
within SS value and that's what is
represented here but then as the the
value of K increases the decrease the
rate of decrease will not be so high it
will continue to decrease but probably
the rate of decrease will not be high so
that gives us an idea so from here we
get an idea for example the optimum
value of K should be either 2 or 3 or at
the most 4 but beyond that increasing
the number of clusters is not
dramatically changing the value in WSS
because that pretty much gets stabilized
okay now that we have got the value of K
and let's assume that these are our
delivery points the next step is
basically to assign two centroids
randomly so let's say C1 and C2 are the
centroids assigned randomly now the
distance of each location from the
centroid is measured and each point is
assigned to the centroid Which is
closest to it so for example these
points are very obvious that these are
closest to C1 whereas this point is far
away from C2 so these points will be
assigned which are close to C1 will be
assigned to C1 and these points or
locations which are close to C2 will be
assigned to C2 and then so this is the
how the initial grouping is done this is
part of C1 and this is part of C2 then
the next step is to calculate the actual
centroid of this data because remember
C1 1 and C2 are not the centroids
they've been randomly assigned points
and only thing that has been done was
the data points which are closest to
them have been assigned but now in this
step the actual centroid will be
calculated which may be for each of
these data sets somewhere in the middle
so that's like the main point that will
be calculated and the centroid will
actually be positioned or repositioned
there
same with C2
so the new centroid for this group is C2
in this new position and C1 is in this
new position once again the distance of
each of the data points is calculated
from these centroids now remember it's
not necessary that the distance Still
Remains the or each of these data points
still remain in the same group by
recalculating the distance it may be
possible that some points get
reallocated like so you see this so this
point earlier was closer to C2 because
C2 was here but after recalculating
repositioning it is observed that this
is closer to C1 than C2 so this is the
new grouping so some points will be
reassigned and again the centroid will
be calculated and if the centroid
doesn't change so that is the repetitive
process iterative process and if the
centroid doesn't change once the
centroid stops changing that means the
algorithm has converged and this is our
final cluster with this as the centroid
C1 and C2 as the centroids these days
data points as a part of each cluster so
I hope this helps in understanding the
whole process iterative process of K
means clustering so let's take a look at
the K means clustering algorithm let's
say we have X1 X2 X3 n number of points
as our inputs and we want to split this
into K clusters or we want to create K
clusters so the first step is to
randomly pick K points and call them
centroids they are not real centroids
because centroid is supposed to be a
center point but they are just called
centroids and we calculate the distance
of each and every input point from each
of the centroids so the distance of X1
from C1 from C2 C3 each of the distances
we calculate and then find out which
distance is the lowest and assign X1 to
that particular random centroid repeat
that process for X2 calculate its
distance from each of the centroid c 1 C
to C3 up to c k and find which is the
lowest distance and assign X2 to that
particular centroid same with X3 and so
on so that is the first round of
assignment that is done now we have K
groups because there are we have
assigned the value of K so there are K
centroids and so there are K groups all
these inputs have been split into K
groups however remember we picked the
centroids randomly so they are not real
centroids so now what we have to do we
have to calculate the actual centroids
for each of these groups which is like
the mean position which means that the
position of the randomly selected
centroids will now change and they will
be the main positions of this newly
formed K groups and once that is done we
once again repeat this process of
calculating the distance right so this
is what we are doing as a part of Step 4
we repeat step two and three so we again
calculate the distance of X1 from the
centroid C1 C2 C3 and then C which is
the lowest value and assign X1 to that
calculate the distance of X2 from C1 C
to C3 or whatever up to c k and find
whichever is the lowest distance and
assign X2 to that centroid and so on in
this process there may be some
reassignment X1 Pro was probably
assigned to Cluster C2 and after doing
this calculation maybe now X1 is
assigned to C1 so that kind of
reallocation may happen so we repeat the
steps 2 and 3 till the position of the
centroids don't change or stop changing
and that's when we have convergence so
let's take a detailed look at it at each
of these steps so we randomly pick K
cluster centers we call them centroids
because they are not initially they are
not really the centroids so we let us
name them C1 C2 up to c k and then Step
2 we assign each data point to the
closest Center so what we do we
calculate the distance of each x value
from each C value so the distance
between X1 C1 distance between X1 C2 X1
C3 and then we find which is the lowest
value right that's the minimum value we
find and assign X1 to that particular
centroid then we go next to X2 find the
distance of X2 from C1 X2 from C2 X2
from C3 and so on up to c k and then
assign it to the point or to the
centroid which has the lowest value and
so on so that is Step number two in Step
number three We Now find the actual
centroid for each group so what has
happened as a part of Step number two we
now have all the points all the data
points grouped into K groups because we
we wanted to create K clusters right so
we have K groups each one may be having
a certain number of input values they
need not be be equally distributed by
the way based on the distance we will
have K groups but remember the initial
values of the C1 C2 were not really the
centroids of these groups right we
assign them randomly so now in step 3 we
actually calculate the centroid of each
group which means the original point
which we thought was the centroid will
shift to the new position which is the
actual centroid for each of these groups
okay and we again calculate the distance
so we go back to step 2 which is what we
calculate again the distance of each of
these points from the newly positioned
centroids and if required we reassign
these points to the new centroids so as
I said earlier there may be a real
occasion so we now have a new set or a
new group we still have K groups but the
number of items and the actual
assignment may be different from what
was in step two here okay so that might
change then we perform step three once
again to find the new centroid of this
new group so we have again a new set of
clusters new centroids and new
assignments we repeat this step two
again once again we find and then it is
possible that after iterating through
three or four or five times the centroid
will stop moving in the sense that when
you calculate the new value of the
centroid that will be same as the
original value or there will be very
marginal change so that is when we say
convergence has occurred and that is our
final cluster that's the formation of
the final cluster all right so let's see
a couple of demos of k-means clustering
we will actually see some live demos and
python notebook using python notebook
but before that let's find out what's
the problem that we are trying to solve
the problem statement is let's say
Walmart wants to open a chain of stores
across the State of Florida
and it wants to find the optimal store
locations now the issue here is if they
open too many stores close to each other
obviously the they will not make profit
but if they if the stores are too far
apart then they will not have enough
sales so how do they optimize this now
for an organization like Walmart which
is an e-commerce giant they already have
the addresses of their customers in
their database so they can actually use
this information or this data and use
k-means cluster to find the optimal
location now before we go into the
python notebook and show you the Live
code I wanted to take you through very
quickly a summary of the code in the
slides and then we will go into the
python notebook so in this block we are
basically importing all the required
libraries like numpy matplotlab and so
on and we are loading the data that is
available in the form of let's say the
addresses for simplicity's sake we will
just take them as some data points then
the next thing we do is quickly do a
scatter plot to see how they are related
to each other with respect to each other
so in the scatter plot we see that there
are a few distinct groups already being
formed so you can actually get an idea
about how the cluster would look and how
many clusters what is the optimal number
of clusters and then starts the actual
k-means clustering process so we will
assign each of these points to the
centroids and then check whether they
are the optimal distance which is the
shortest distance and assign each of the
points data points to the centroids and
then go through this iterative process
till the whole process converges and
finally we get an output like this so we
have four distinct clusters and
which is if we can say that this is how
the population is probably distributed
across Florida State and the centroids
are like the location where the store
should be the optimum location where the
store should be so that's the way we
determine the best locations for the
store and that's how we can help Walmart
find the best locations for their stores
in Florida so now let's take this into
python notebook let's see how this looks
when we are running running the code
live all right so this is the code for
k-means clustering in Jupiter notebook
we have a few examples here which we
will demonstrate how k-means clustering
is used and even there is a small
implementation of k-means clustering as
well okay so let's get started okay so
this block is basically importing the
various libraries that are required like
matplotlib and Empire and so on and so
forth which would be used as a part of
the code then we are going and creating
blobs which are similar to clusters now
this is a very neat feature which is
available in scikit-learn make blobs is
a nice feature which creates clusters of
data sets so that's a wonderful
functionality that is readily available
for us to create some test data kind of
thing so
so that's exactly what we are doing here
we are using make blobs and we can
specify how many clusters we want so
centers we are mentioning here so it
will go ahead and so we just mentioned
four so it will go ahead and create some
test data for us
and this is how it looks as you can see
visually also we can figure out that
there are four distinct classes or
clusters in this data set and that is
what make blobs actually provides now
from here onwards we will basically run
the standard k-means functionality that
is readily available so we really don't
have to implement k-means itself the
k-means functionality or the or the
function is readily available you just
need to feed the data and we'll create
the Clusters so this is the code for
that we import k-means and then we
create an instance of k-means and we
specify the value of K this n underscore
clusters is the value of K remember K
means in K means K is basically the
number of clusters that you want to
create and it is a integer value so this
is where we are specifying that so we
have K is equal to 4. and so that
instance is created we take that
instance and as with any other machine
learning functionality fit is what we
use the function or the method rather
fit is what we use to train the model
here there is no real training kind of
thing but that's the call okay so we are
calling fit and what we are doing here
we are just passing the data so X has
these values the data that has been
created right so that is what we are
passing here and this will go ahead and
create the Clusters and then we are
using
after doing uh fit We Run The predict
which basically assigns for each of
these observations which cluster it
belongs to all right so it will name the
Clusters maybe this is cluster one this
is two three and so on or I will
actually start from zero cluster 0 1 2
and 3 maybe and then for each of the
observations it will assign based on
which cluster it belongs to it will
assign a value so that is stored in y
underscore K means when we call predict
that is what it does and we can take a
quick look at these y underscore K means
or the cluster numbers that have been
assigned for each observation so this is
the cluster number assigned for
observation one maybe this is for
observation two observation three and so
on so we have how many about I think 300
samples right so all the 300 samples
there are 300 values here each of them
the cluster number is given and the
class faster number goes from 0 to 3 so
there are four clusters so the numbers
go from 0 1 2 3 so that's what is seen
here okay now so this was a quick
example of generating some dummy data
and then clustering that okay and this
can be applied if you have proper data
you can just load it up into X for
example here and then run the game so
this is the central part of the K means
clustering program exam so you basically
create an instance and and you mentioned
how many clusters you want by specifying
this parameter and underscore clusters
and that is also the value of K and then
pass the data to get the values now the
next section of this code is the
implementation of a k means now this is
kind of a rough implementation of the
k-means algorithm so we will just walk
you through I will walk you through the
code at each step what it is doing and
then we will see a couple of more
examples of how k-means clustering can
be used in maybe some real life examples
real life use cases all right so in this
case here what we are doing is basically
implementing k-means clustering and
there is a function or a library
calculates for a given two pairs of
points it will calculate the the
distance between them and see which one
is the closest and so on so this is like
this is pretty much like what k-means
does right so it calculates the distance
of each point or each data set from
predefined centroid and then based on
whichever is the lowest this particular
data point is assigned to that percent
right so that is basically available as
a standard function and we will be using
that here so as explained in the slides
the first step that is done in case of
k-means clustering is to randomly assign
some centroids so as a first step we
randomly allocate a couple of centroids
which we call here we are calling a
centers
and then we put this in a loop and we
take it through an iterative process
for each of the data points we first
find out using this function pairwise
distance argument for each of the points
we find out which one which Center or
which are randomly selected centroid is
the closest and accordingly we assign
the data or data point to that
particular centroid or cluster and once
that is done for all the data points we
calculate the new centroid by finding
out the mean position with the center
position right so we calculate the new
centroid and then we check if the new
centroid is the coordinates or the
position is the same as the previous
centroid the positions we will compare
and if it is the same that means the
process has converged so remember we do
this process till the centroids or the
centroid doesn't move anymore right so
the centroid gets relocated each time
this reallocation is done so the moment
it doesn't change anymore the position
of the centroid doesn't change anymore
we know that convergence has occurred so
till then so you see here this is like
an infinite Loop while true is an
infinite Loop it only breaks when the
centers are the same the new center and
the old Center positions are the same
and once that is done we return the
sender Center labels now of course as
explained this is not a very
sophisticated and advanced
implementation very basic implementation
because one of the flaws in this is that
sometimes what happens is the centroid
the position will keep moving but in if
the change will be very minor so in that
case also with that is actually
convergence right right so for example
the change is 0.0001 we can consider
that as convergence otherwise what will
happen is this will either take forever
or it will be never ending so that's a
small flaw here so that is something
additional checks may have to be added
here but again as mentioned this is not
the most sophisticated implementation uh
this is like a kind of a rough
implementation of the k-means clustering
so if we execute this code this is what
we get as the output so this is the
definition of this particular function
and then we call that find underscore
clusters and we pass our data X and the
number of clusters which is 4 and if we
run that and plot it this is the output
that we get so this is of course each
cluster is represented by a different
color so we have a cluster in green
color yellow color and so on and so
forth and these big points here these
are the centroids this is the final
position of the centroids and as you can
see visually also this appears like a
kind of a center of all these points
here right similarly this is like the
center of all these points here and so
on so this is the example or this is an
example of a implementation of K means
clustering and next we will move on to
see a couple of examples of how k-means
clustering is used in maybe some real
life scenario or use cases in the next
example or demo we are going to see how
we can use k-means clustering to perform
color compression we will take a couple
of images so there will be two examples
and we will try to use k-min's
clustering to compress the colors this
is a common situation in image
processing when you have an image with
millions of colors but then you cannot
render it on some devices which may not
have enough memory so that is the
scenario where where something like this
can be used
so before again we go into the python
notebook let's take a look at quickly
the the code as usual we import the
libraries and then we import the image
and then we will flatten it so the
reshaping is basically we have the image
information stored in the form of pixels
and if the image is like for example 427
by 640 and it has three colors so that's
the overall dimension of the of the
initial image we just reshape it and
then feed this to our algorithm and this
will then create clusters of only 16
clusters so this this colors there are
millions of colors and now we need to
bring it down to 16 colors so we use K
is equal to 16 and this is uh when we
visualize this is how it looks there are
these are all about 16 million possible
colors the input color space has 16
million possible colors and we just
subcompress it to a 16 colors so this is
how it would look when we compress it to
16 colors and this is how the original
image looks and after compression to 16
colors this is uh the new image looks as
you can see there is not a lot of
information that has been lost though
the image quality is definitely reduced
a little bit
so this is an example which we are going
to now see in Python notebook let's go
into the python node and once again as
always we will import some libraries and
load this image called
flower.jpg okay so let me load that and
this is how it looks this is the
original image which has I think 16
million colors and this is the shape of
this image which is basically what is
the shape is nothing but the overall
size right so this is 427 pixel by 640
pixel and then there are three layers
which is this three basically is for RGB
which is red green blue so color image
will have that right so that is the
shape of this now what we need to do is
data let's take a look at how data is
looking so let me just create a new cell
and show you what is in data basically
we have captured this information
so data is what let me just show you
here
all right so let's take a look at China
what are the values in China and if we
see here this is how the data is stored
this is nothing but the pixel values
okay so this is like a matrix and each
one has about for this 427 by 640 pixel
X all right so this is how it looks now
the issue here is these values are large
the numbers are a large so we need to
normalize them to between 0 and 1 right
so that's why we will basically create
one more variable which is data which
will contain the values between 0 and 1
and the way to do that is divide by 255
so we divide China by 255 and we get the
new values in data so let's just run
this piece of code and this is the shape
so we now have also yeah what we have
done is we changed using reshape we
converted into the three dimensional
into a two-dimensional data set and let
us also take a look at how
and let me just insert
uh probably a cell here and take a look
at how data is looking all right so this
is how data is looking and now you see
this is the values are between 0 and 1
right so if you earlier noticed in case
of china the values were large numbers
now everything is between 0 and 1. this
is one of the things we
all right so after that the next thing
that we need to do is to visualize this
and we can take random set of maybe 10
000 points and plot it and check and see
how this looks so let us just plot this
there so this is how the original the
color the pixel distribution is these
are two plots one is red against Green
and another is red against Blue and this
is the original distribution of the
car so then what we will do is we will
use k-means clustering to create just 16
clusters for the various colors and then
apply that to the image now what will
happen is since the data is large
because there are millions of colors
using regular k-means may be a little
time consuming so there is another
version of k-means which is called mini
batch came in so we will use that which
is which processes in the overall
concept Remains the Same but this
basically processes it in smaller
batches that's the only thing okay so
the results will pretty much be the same
so let's go ahead and execute this piece
of code and also visualize this so that
we can see that there are this this is
how the 16 colors uh would look so this
is red against Green and this is red
against Blue there is uh quite a bit of
similarity between this original color
schema and the new one right so it
doesn't look very very completely
different or anything like that now we
apply this the newly created colors to
the image and we can take a look how
this is looking now we can compare both
the images so this is our original image
and this is our new image so as you can
see there is not a lot of information
that has been lost it pretty much looks
like the original image yes we can see
that for example here there is a little
bit it appears a little delish compared
to this one right because we kind of
took off some of the finer details of
the color but overall the high level
information has been maintained at the
same time the main advantage is that now
this can be this is an image which can
be rendered on a device which may not be
that very sophisticated now let's take
one more example with a different image
in the second example we will take an
image of the Summer Palace in China and
we repeat the same process the this is a
high definition color image with
millions of colors and also
three-dimensional
now we will reduce that to 16 colors
using k-means clustering and we do the
same process like before we reshape it
and then we cluster the colors to 16 and
then we render the image once again and
we will see that the color the quality
of the image is slightly deteriorates as
you can see here this has much finer
details in this which are probably
missing here but then that's the
compromise because there are some
devices which may not be able to handle
this kind of a high density images
so let's run this chord in Python
notebook all right so let's apply the
same technique for another picture which
is uh even more intricate and has
probably much complicated color schema
so this is the image now once again uh
we can take a look at the shape which is
427 by 640 by 3 and this is the new data
would look somewhat like this compared
to the flower image so we have some new
values here and we will also bring this
as you can see the numbers are much big
so we will much bigger so we will now
have to scale them down to values
between 0 and 1 and that is done by
dividing by 255 so let's go ahead and do
that
and reshape it okay so we get a
two-dimensional Matrix and we will then
as a next step we will go ahead and
visualize this how it looks the 16
colors and this is basically how it
would look 16 million colors and now we
can
create the Clusters out of this the 16
k-means clusters we will create so this
is how the distribution of the pixels
would look with 16 colors and then we go
ahead and apply this
visualize how it is looking for with the
with the new just the 16 color so once
again as you can see this looks much
richer in color but at the same time and
this probably doesn't have as we can see
it doesn't look as rich as this one but
nevertheless the information is not lost
the shape and all that stuff and this
can be also rendered on a slightly a
device which is probably not that
sophisticated okay so that's pretty much
it so we have seen two examples of how
color compression can be done using
cayman's clustering and we have also
seen in the previous examples of how to
implement k-means the code to roughly
how to implement k-means clustering and
we use some sample data using blob to
just execute the Gaming's clustering hey
everyone welcome to this live session by
simply learn in today's session we will
take you through the most debated topic
that has taken the World by storm yes
you guessed it right we are talking
about coronavirus but before we proceed
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update in this session we will learn
about what coronavirus really is how did
it emerge and what are its symptoms then
we will see what has been its impact so
far in terms of the total cases emerging
the total number of deaths reported and
the total number of recoveries across
the globe we will analyze the outbreak
of coronavirus across different regions
visualize them using charts and graphs
and predict the number of upcoming
confirmed cases for the next 10 days
that is between the 16th of March to the
25th of March using linear regression
model and support Vector machines in
Python finally we look at the various
safety measures that you can take to
save yourself from getting attacked by
Coronavirus
before we begin let me clarify that this
video majorly focuses on how you can use
machine learning algorithms to make
predictions on such sensitive issues we
will certainly cover the current
scenario and the impact it has created
worldwide but there is nothing to panic
at all make sure you take all the
necessary precautions to stay safe also
the predictions may vary from the
current situation that you see as the
data was taken from Kegel that may have
some variations this is only to make you
learn how you can perform analysis on
such data sets and derive insights from
the prediction
so let's start with what is Coronavirus
coronaviruses first discovered in 1960s
are a family of viruses that cause
illness ranging from common cold to
severe diseases such as Middle East
Respiratory Syndrome and severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronaviruses can
be transmitted between animals and human
beings and hence they are zoonotic
now let's see how coronavirus emerged in
December 2019 the city of Wuhan in hubai
province which is China's seventh
largest city comprising 11 million
residents became the center of a
pneumonia outbreak of a known cause the
Chinese Health authorities conducted an
immediate investigation of these cases
to identify and control its spread by
isolating suspected patients closely
monitoring their contacts and obtaining
detailed clinical and epidemiologic data
the source of coronavirus 2019 or
covid-19 is believed to be a wet Market
in Wuhan which sold both dead and live
animals including fish and boats
let's see the symptoms of coronavirus
covid-19 is characterized by symptoms
such as cold cough running nose sore
throat and fever illness can be more
severe for some people and can lead to
pneumonia or breathing difficulties
older people and people with other
medical conditions such as asthma
diabetes or heart disease may be more
vulnerable to becoming severely ill the
noble coronavirus is now a public health
emergency of international concern
people across the globe are racing to
cut short their vacations and rebook
flights home as most countries continue
to lock down cities and towns amid the
spread of coronavirus as per the World
Health Organization till the 15th of
March the total deaths reported globally
stood at
5735 while more than 100 000 people were
infected worldwide on the 11th of March
the World Health Organization declared
covid-19 as pandemic on the screen you
can see the total coronavirus cases till
the 13th of March across the globe most
of the countries have been affected by
the spread of Coronavirus China South
Korea Iran Italy France Spain and
Germany are some of the countries that
got hit the most
you see China Italy Iran and the United
States of America have the highest
number of deaths reported till the 13th
of March the next map shows you the
total recovered cases across different
parts of the world China Italy Iran and
South Korea have the most number of
patients who have recovered
now let's move on to the most important
part of this video where we will analyze
the outbreak of coronavirus cases across
different countries and visualize them
using different charts and graphs the
data has information from the 22nd of
January till the 15th of March using
this data we will predict the upcoming
cases for the next 10 days using
algorithms such as linear regression and
support Vector machines in Python now
let me go ahead and show you the data
sets that we will be using for this
analysis so for this analysis we'll be
using three CSV files
so here you can see we I have opened all
the three files the first data set is
regarding the confirmed cases it has
columns such as province of the state
country or the region
latitude longitude
and the number of confirmed cases that
came up in all these days
similarly
the second data set is regarding the
deaths of patients between 22nd of Jan
till the 15th of March
foreign
data set is regarding the number of
recovered cases during the same time
interval now let's start with
understanding the code for this demo
where we will use support Vector machine
and linear regression to build our model
and predict the total number of
confirmed cases that may come up in the
next 10 days again to clarify our
prediction may vary from the current
scenario that you actually see since
this data set was taken from Kegel which
is usually for learning purposes I have
already implemented the code on jupyter
Notebook I'll run through each cell of
code and explain to you what it does
first we will import all the necessary
libraries that are important for this
analysis as you can see
we are importing libraries such as numpy
and pandas that are used for numerical
computations and manipulations then I am
importing matplotlib library for
visualizing the data and the model
followed by math and time after that
from the sqln library I'm importing
certain functions such as train test
split
svr to build the model
and so on we are also using Matrix
functions such as mean squared error and
mean absolute error and so on
now let me run this cell by hitting
shift plus enter
we have successfully run that cell now
we will load all the three data sets one
by one for that I have used the pandas
library and read underscore CSV function
which you can see here
I have provided the location of the file
followed by the file name and the
extension of the file which is dot CSV
uploaded all the three data sets into
three variable names now let me run all
the three cells to import all the three
data sets I'll hit shift enter
scroll down
will load the depth data set and the
recovered data set
now to display the data sets I'm using
dot head function to see the top five
rows from the data
you can see the top five rows from the
confirmed underscore cases data set
similarly
you can check the top 5 rows from the
reported data set
from the depth reported data set
and from the recovered cases as well
after that
I'm extracting all the column names from
the confirmed cases data frame using the
dot Keys function
let me run it
So Below you can see all the columns
being displayed
then we are extracting only the date
columns that have information of
confirmed cases death cases and
recovered cases using the dot loc
function
the first parameter that is colon tells
you we need all the rows while the
second parameter tells you that we need
data from the fourth column till the
last column which are the date values
now let me run all the three
you can go ahead to see the outbreak
cases using confirmed dot head
here you can see it has only the date
columns and the values for each of the
dates
after that in the next cell I am finding
the total confirmed cases death cases
and the recovered cases and appending
them to four empty lists we are also
calculating the total mortality rate
which is nothing but the total death sum
divided by the total confirmed cases
you can see
I have declared four empty lists namely
World cases total deaths mortality rate
and total recovered then I am running a
for Loop taking the date variables into
consideration so for each of the date
values we are summing the total
confirmed cases the death cases and the
recoveries after that I am appending the
values to the four empty lists that we
had created now let me run it
moving ahead let me display each of the
newly created variables one by one
so if I run confirmed underscore sum you
can see the total number of confirmed
cases which is nearly 1 lakh 67 449
now if I run this one it will tell you
the total number of deaths that have
been reported which is 6440
and the total number of recoveries stand
at 76 034.
similarly if I run World cases
you can see
this kind of an array
which have been listed date wise
in the next step I am converting all the
dates and the cases in the form of a
numpy array using NP dot array function
let me run it
now I can display all the newly created
arrays by passing the variable names
so if I run days since
22nd of Jan
you can see it will list you the total
number of days that were present from
the 22nd of Jan till the 15th of March
now if I run World cases you can see it
has an array
which has values of the total number of
cases that emerge between
22nd of March
till
the 15th of March
similarly if I run the total debts
variable
you can see it lists all the Death
values between 20 seconds of Jan till
15th of March
and finally for the total recovered
cases
now since our prediction will be for the
next 10 days
so I have created a variable called days
in future and assigned a value of 10.
then I'm adding the last 10 days to the
total number of days we have now let me
show you the value of future forecast by
running the cell
you can see below
future forecast
has given us a total of
64 DS
next we are converting all the integers
into date time values for better
visualization
so let's run it
now before we start building our code
let's visualize the data using different
charts and graphs and see what has been
the impact of coronavirus so far for
visualization we need the latest data of
15th of March
so I have extracted the last column
values for all the three data sets
now let me display these for you
I'll run latest underscore confirmed
you can see it gives you all the values
from the 15th of March
similarly I'll go ahead and run the
remaining
latest deaths gives you the total debts
that were reported on 15th of March
across various regions
similarly
for the latest recoveries as well
after that I am finding the list of
unique countries using the dot unique
function
if I run this so below you can see there
are different countries
so that's Thailand Japan Singapore
Malaysia all the countries across the
globe
so in the next cell I'm basically
calculating the total number of
confirmed cases by each country
so I have created two empty lists namely
country confirmed cases and no cases
if the cases are greater than zero I am
appending the values to Country
confirmed cases else I am appending it
to no cases
next I am finding the number of cases
per country or region
so you can see that China has the
highest number of cases followed by
Italy and Iran
now in this cell of code we are finding
the list of unique provinces using the
dot unique function again now there are
certain countries that have been marked
as provinces or states such as the
United Kingdom Denmark and France those
we are classifying as outliers and
removing them from the list
next we are finding the number of
confirmed cases per Province state or
city so for this
we have created two empty lists namely
Province confirmed cases and no cases if
the cases are greater than zero I am
appending them to Province confirmed
cases else to no cases I am also
removing the areas with no confirmed
cases
foreign
city or state
so here are the values
coming to the next cell in this piece of
code you're basically handling Nan or
missing values let me just run it
okay
so now that we have done with preparing
the data for visualization let's build
different charts and graphs to see what
we can derive from it
first we'll plot a bar graph to see the
total confirmed cases across different
countries in the beginning
I am giving the size of the graph using
plt.figure so we have 32 by 32 size then
I am passing the unique entries in the
x-axis and the country confirmed cases
in the y-axis I have given a title to
this graph number of covid-19 confirmed
cases in countries I have also given a
label for the x-axis which is number of
covet confirmed cases we are using
plt.show that will display the graph let
me run it
as you can see if I scroll down
China
has the highest number of cases followed
by Italy Iran South Korea Spain Germany
France and so on
now I'll plot another bar graph to see
the total confirmed cases between
mainland China and outside mainland
China for mainland China I am finding
the sum of all the cases where country
or region equal to equal to China while
for outside mainland China I am taking
the sum of all the confirmed cases and
subtracting China cases
let me now run it
as you can see the total number of cases
outside China is more than mainland
China
now if you want you can also print the
exact values which I have done below so
the total cases outside mainland China
is around 86 446 while in China it is
close to 81 000 and the overall cases
till 15th of March stand at 1 lakh sixty
seven thousand four hundred and forty
nine
another thing I have done is to show 10
countries that have the most number of
confirmed cases while the rest of the
countries have grouped into a category
named others so I have created two empty
lists
named visual unique countries and visual
confirmed cases I have taken the 10
countries based on the top 10 cases
while the others category has the
remaining cases
now let's visualize the 10 countries
using a bar graph
so this is how the graph looks like
on the y-axis you have the different
country names you also have
the others category
and on the x axis
you have the number of cases
you can see
China has the highest number of covid-19
cases Italy has the second highest while
other countries in total
have the third highest cases
now the same visualization you can do
using a pie chart to check the total
confirmed cases in 10 different
countries I've used a color scheme css4
colors I have given the figure size 20
by 20. I am using plt.pi function and
plt.legend function to show the
different countries
let me just run it
so here is how
the pie chart looks like
and to the right you can see the
different Legends
so this color corresponds to China
while this one corresponds to Italy
this is actually others and so on
here I have created another pie chart to
visualize the total confirmed cases in
10 different countries apart from China
it has the same code as ever but
under plt.pi I have passed columns apart
from China and hence we are using one
colon similarly under plt.legend we have
values apart from China
let me run it
so this is how the pie chart looks like
as you can see Italy has the highest
number of cases followed by Iran and
then South Korea
we also have others in this category
which has
pretty high number of confirmed cases
so now that we have visualized our data
let's start by building our model using
a support Vector machine algorithm
support Vector machine uses different
parameters to build a model these
parameters are kernel C gamma Epsilon
shrinking and svm grid
kernel specifies the kernel type to be
used in the algorithm it must be one of
linear poly RBF sigmoid pre-computed or
callable if nothing is given RBF will be
used C is a regularization parameter
gamma is the kernel coefficient of RBF
poly and sigmoic Epsilon specifies the
Epsilon tube within which no penalty is
associated in the training loss function
shrinking takes Boolean values that is
true or false svm grid has all the
values passed as parameters to it then
with the help of randomized search CV
function we are building a model by
passing the necessary parameters finally
we are fitting the data using
svmsearch.fit function and passing
extreme confirmed and white train
confirmed
let me now run it
this might take some time
since we have an Epoch or an iteration
defined
here we have given 40 iterations
now we have successfully run that
particular cell
now let's find the best parameters for
the model
so you can see the result shrinking is
false kernel it has taken as poly
gamma's value is 0.1 Epsilon value is
0.01 and C value is also 0.01
now you can find the best estimator
using svm search dot best estimator
function
and predict the future forecast using
the predict function I'll run this
if I run svm underscore confirmed below
you can see the results
similarly svm underscore predict will
tell you the predicted values
for all the dates
now you can check the values of the
testing data after creating the model
for that we'll create a plot with the
svm test predicted data and the y-test
confirmed data then I'll print the mean
absolute error and the mean squared
error values
So Below you can see the graph
and the error values
then I'll plot the total number of
coronavirus cases over time starting
from 22nd of Jan
I have given a title number of
coronavirus cases over time so there are
X labels and Y labels defined
let me now run it
so here is the graph
on the y-axis you can see the number of
cases
and on the x axis you can see the total
number of these by looking at the graph
you can tell after 40 days the cases
were close to 90 000 and now after 50
plus days the cases have reached nearly
1 lakh sixty thousand
the next plot shows you the total
confirmed cases versus the sbm predicted
cases that might come up
let me now run it
here you can see the graph
the blue line which is this one
it represents all the confirmed cases
while the dotted purple line is the
prediction from the svm model which is
this one
now we'll predict the values of the
cases for the next 10 days using the svm
algorithm
here is the output
you can see it starts from the 16th of
March till the 25th of March that is the
next 10 days after 15th of March you can
see the total number of upcoming cases
each day so on 16th of March the model
predicts there will be around 1 lakh 84
000 cases on 17th of March we might have
one lakh 93 000 cases and so on
let us now see how you can predict these
cases using the linear regression model
so we have imported the linear
regression function from the
scikit-learn library
I have fit the model with extreme and Y
train confirm data which is this one
for prediction I have used X test
confirm data and the future forecast
data finally in the end I am printing
the values of Mae and MSC for this model
let me now go ahead and run this code
below you can see it has given us the
value for mean absolute error and mean
squared error
let's now plot the confirmed values from
the test data and the linear predicted
data
so this is how the graph looks like
we did for the svm model we can also
plot a graph to show the number of
coronavirus cases over time since 22nd
of Jan
I'll run this
so here is the graph
thank you
the Blue Line depicts the confirmed
cases while the yellow line tells the
linear regression predictions
now I'll go ahead and predict the cases
for the next 10 days using linear
regression here you can see the
predictions
it is different from that of the svm
model which had a higher number of cases
now we'll plot the total number of
deaths over time
let me run it
so as you can see from the graph
on the x axis we have time that is the
number of days on the y axis we have the
number of deaths
so by day 50 the number of deaths
reported have crashed 5000.
in the next cell we are plotting a graph
to visualize the total mortality rate of
coronavirus cases over time
I'll hit shift enter
so here is the graph of mortality rate
of Corona virus cases over time
then I am plotting the total number of
coronavirus cases recovered over time
as you can see from the graph
nearly 75 000 people have recovered from
this pandemic
in the next plot
I am checking the number of coronavirus
cases based on deaths and recoveries
So Below is how the graph looks like
the green line represents the number of
recoveries and the red line represents
the number of deaths
as you can see there are a lot of
recovered cases which is good news
and finally we are checking the total
number of coronavirus deaths versus
recoveries in a single plot
so here is the graph
the x axis has the number of recoveries
while the y-axis has the number of
deaths reported so far
with that we have come to the end of the
demo to analyze coronavirus outbreak
globally
now let me address a few questions that
our viewers are asking related to
coronavirus and about this prediction
analysis first question I can see here
is how coronavirus spreads and how to
protect yourself so coronavirus spreads
in a similar way to flu or the common
cold basically in large droplets
produced by cuffs or sneezes germs can
live on surfaces for several hours
Public Health England defines the spread
as having close contact with a virus
carrier within two meters of the person
for 15 minutes as mentioned there is no
vaccine as of now to protect yourself
you need to take precautionary measures
such as regularly washing your hands
staying away from crowded places like
malls and pubs and using mosques
another question which I can see on the
chat window is who started the
coronavirus to be honest there are a
number of crazy conspiracy theories that
have been circulating that the virus
somehow escaped from a Chinese lab
either by accident or design however
this is categorically untrue and
scientists studying its genetic core
have linked it to bats it probably then
jumped to other animals which passed it
on to humans
one more question is can we use time
series analysis and other type of
algorithms to make predictions of the
cases of course you can you can use time
series analysis to predict the upcoming
cases but it would be recommended for
you to have individual data from
different countries you can also use
algorithms such as Bayesian Ridge and
logistic regression there's another
question can we also predict the death
cases and the recovered cases for the
next 10 days surely you can predict both
the parameters you just need to provide
the total debts and the total recovered
cases information to the splitting step
where we are dividing the data set
with that I think we have covered most
of the important questions related to
this topic machine learning is the
future and yours can begin today comment
below with your email ID to get our
latest machine learning career guide let
your journey begin
finally it's our duty to tell you the
important safety precautions that you
can take to ensure you are not suffering
from the spread of coronavirus since
there is no coronavirus vaccine yet so
here are the measures that you can
follow clean your hands often with soaps
and sanitizers avoid close contact with
people who are ill
always wear a face mask when you are out
practice respiratory hygiene please
avoid gathering in crowded places do
stay at home if you are sick and most
importantly seek medical care early if
you have fever cough or difficulty
breathing
and with that we have reached the end of
this session welcome to another live
session by simply learn I would like to
thank you all for actively participating
in these sessions on YouTube and
Facebook
today we will understand how to perform
stock market prediction using machine
learning so what really is stock market
a stock market is a place or a public
market where you can buy and sell shares
for publicly listed companies
the stocks which are also known as
equities represent ownership in the
company
the stock exchange is the mediator that
allows the buying and selling of shares
Amsterdam stock exchange is the oldest
Stock Exchange that were established in
1602 the top stock exchanges in the
United States are the New York Stock
Exchange NASDAQ American Stock Exchange
and Chicago Board operations Exchange
in India we have the Bombay Stock
Exchange or the BSC that was established
in 1875 and it's Asia's first stock
exchange
we also have the National Stock Exchange
or NSE
now let's understand the importance of
stock market
stock markets help companies to raise
capital
if stock markets did not exist then
companies would have to resort to
borrowing loans from the banks to raise
money for expansion
this would be a trouble for the company
as they would have to repay the loans
with interest
with stock markets companies have the
free hand to create an initial public
offering and raise large amounts of cash
without having to worry about repayment
another reason why the stock market is
important is it helps generate personal
wealth for an individual investor the
stock market provides a platform to
invest your income and earn a share of
the company's profit
stock markets serve as an indicator of
the state of the economy that is the
stock market serves as a barometer for
the economy
a rise of fall in the prices of shares
indicates what cycle the economy is in
such as a recession or a boom the stock
market is considered to be one of the
most widely used sources for people to
invest money in investors are always
looking to invest in companies with high
growth potential
if the stock market is performing well
this increases investment from local
investors it also attracts foreign
direct investment as people abroad
invest in the local Stock Exchange
with that let's Now understand stock
market prediction
stock market prediction helps to
determine the future value of company
stock and other financial instruments
traded on an exchange
the whole idea of predicting stock
prices is to gain significant profits
predicting how the stock market will
perform is a difficult task to do
there are a lot of other factors
involved in the prediction such as
physical and psychological factors
rational and irrational Behavior Etc
all these factors combined to make share
prices Dynamic and volatile
this makes it very difficult to predict
stock prices with high accuracy
so we will use machine learning
techniques to predict the stock prices
of two different companies Tesla and
Google
will be using linear regression
algorithm and long short-term memory
networks for building our prediction
models
so first
let's understand the basics of linear
regression
linear regression is a very popular
statistical technique used for solving
machine learning problems it is a
supervised learning algorithm for
predicting the output of a continuous
Target variable
it can be used to predict the total
revenue of a company or the total units
expected to be sold of a certain product
it can also be used for weather
prediction and stock price prediction
now here is an example to predict the
total number of ice creams a vendor or a
company can sell based on the
temperature of the day
you can see the green dots represent the
actual data points so the x-axis has the
input variable that is temperature and
the y-axis has the target variable that
is unit sold
linear regression uses the linear
equation formula Y is equal to MX plus c
where m is the slope of the line C is
the intercept
we find the coefficients and plot the
regression line
so in this graph the red line is a
regression line
the best fit line should have the least
Square distance between the original
data points and the predicted values
now let's see how to predict the stock
prices of Tesla using the linear
regression model
so this is the CSP data set that we will
be using for our prediction
we have information from the 29th of
June 2010
till the 15th of May 2019.
here open column means the price at
which a stock started trading when the
market opened on a particular day
the close column refers to the price of
an individual stock when the Stock
Exchange closed market for the day
it represents the last Buy sell order
executed between two Traders
the high column is the highest price at
which a stock traded during a period
the low is the lowest price of the
period
volume is the total amount of trading
activity during a period of time
the adjusted closing price is a
calculation adjustment made to the
Stock's closing price
it is more complex and accurate than the
closing price the adjustment made to the
closing price depicts the true price of
the stock because the outside factors
could have altered the true price
now before I begin the demo I want to
tell you that if you want to get a copy
of the source code files and the data
sets that I'll be using in this session
then please put your email IDs in the
chat section of the video also please
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to stay updated with all the
latest trending Technologies
so here is my jupyter notebook where I
have implemented my linear regression
code
so I'll run through each cell of code
and explain what it does
first
we'll import the necessary libraries for
building our model
so I am importing pandas numpy and
matplotlib for numerical computation
data manipulation and data visualization
we'll also import the plotly library for
building our graphs now if you are using
plotly for the first time you will have
to install it and then import it onto
Jupiter
let me run this cell
so I have successfully imported all my
libraries
next
I load the Tesla stock price data set
using the pandas library and the read
underscore CSV function I'll also give
the location where my CSV data set is
present
now let me import the data set I'll hit
shift enter
so now I have successfully imported my
data set now let's
see my data sets for that I'll use the
head function
I like Tesla dot head
so this will return the top 5 rows from
the data set
in the next cell I'm using the info
function to find the total rows and
columns in my data set the info function
will also return the data type of the
variables and check if there are any
null values
there you go so we have total seven
columns and there are
2193 entries
here you can see the data type of each
column and each column has non-null
values
moving ahead
in the next step we are converting the
date column into date time format using
pandas library and to underscore date
time function
controller
up next let's do some exploratory data
analysis and get more insights from our
data
I'm using the print function and a
formatted string literal that is f
these strings contain replacement fields
which are expressions delimited by curly
braces you can see here
here I am finding out the data frame
contains stock prices between what dates
and the total number of days
so the total number of days can be
calculated by subtracting the maximum
deed value and the minimum date value
so let me go ahead and run it
you can see
our stock prices are from 29th of June
2010 till 15th of March 2019 and the
total number of days are 3181 days
now let's see some summary statistics
for our data using the describe function
so the describe function gives you the
count mean standard deviation the
maximum and minimum from each column the
25th quartile the 15th quartile and the
75th quartile
let me now go ahead and create a box
plot to visually check our outliers I am
considering five columns open high low
close and adjust it close
so this is how our box plot looks like
in this cell we'll plot a graph using
the plotly library that we have imported
we are setting the layout for our graph
using the go layout function
and providing a title to the graph
I'm also setting my x-axis for giving
the title
so the x axis will have the date column
you can see it here
we are also defining the title font a
family size and color
similarly I am providing the layout for
the y-axis you can see it here
finally I am passing my data list and
the layout created to
plot variable
let me go ahead and run it
now I'll plot My Graph using the I plot
function
there you go so we have the stock prices
of Tesla plotted in this graph
on x-axis we have the year
from 2011 till 2019
and on the y-axis you have the price
which is basically the
close column
you can see from the graph
that initially during 2011 or 2010 the
stock prices were
growing a little lower than expected but
towards
2015-16 and 17 onwards the stock prices
grew higher
now
coming to the most important part that
is to build the linear regression model
so in this cell I'm importing the
necessary libraries and the respective
functions
first I am importing the train
underscore test underscore split
function from the scikit-learn library
next
I'm also importing some preprocessing
functions like min max scalar and
standard scalar from SQL Library
also for evaluating the model and
finding the accuracy we'll use the mean
squared error and r squared error from
scikit-learn Matrix Library
let me run it
so we have successfully imported our
required libraries
moving ahead
in the current step
we are splitting the data into training
and testing sets
the X variable contains the independent
features and the Y variable has the
dependent variable of the target
variable that is close column
I am taking the test data size as 0.3 or
30 percent of the total
and I'm assigning a random state of one
zero one
let's run it
okay
now
I'll perform feature scaling on the
extreme data set
for that I am using the
standardscaler.fit function and passing
in my extreme data
standardization of a data set is a
common requirement for any machine
learning algorithm
they might behave badly if the
individual features are not normally
distributed
so that's why feature scaling is
important
with that
it's time for us to import the linear
regression function from the
scikit-learn library
now
using a variable LM which stands for
linear model I'll declare a linear
regression function and then I'll use
the fit method to pass the training data
sets that is Extreme and white train
so let me run it
now we have successfully created a
linear regression model
next we'll plot the graph for actual and
predicted values for the training data
set
here we will be creating a scatter plot
and draw our prediction line
so I have used the go dot scatter
function
I am using markers for plotting the
actual data points and I have used a
line to draw the prediction line
let me run it
now to plot the graph I use the I plot
function
if I scroll down
you can see on the x axis we have the
day column
or the day variable
and on the y-axis we have the prices of
our stocks the blue dots represent the
actual stock values if I hover over this
blue dots you can see the actual values
and the red line is a predicted
regression line
the final step will calculate the scores
for evaluating our model
so here we are using two Matrix one is r
squared error and mean squared error for
finding the r squared error we have used
R2 underscore score function and I am
passing my y train
as well as X strain using the LM predict
function
similarly for finding the r squared
error for testing data set I am using Y
test and LM predict for
X test
likewise to find the mean squared error
value I have used the Y train and Y test
data along with predicted X strain and
Extras Theta
now let me run it
below you can see the two Matrix scores
so our r squared error score is around
0.86 for the training set and it's
around the same value of 0.86 for
testing data set and similarly you can
see the main Squad error as well
with that you saw how to predict the
Tesla stock prices using linear
regression model in Python if you want
to get a copy of the source code files
and the data sets that I'm using in this
session then please put your email IDs
in the chat section we'll share the
files over email also please subscribe
to our Channel and stay updated with all
the latest Technologies
now we will understand about long short
term memory Networks
so lstms are a type of recurrent neural
networks for learning long-term
dependencies
it is commonly used for processing and
predicting on the basis of Time series
data
from the image on the left you can see
lstms have a chain-like structure
instead of having a single neural
network layer there are four interacting
layers communicating with each other in
a very special way
now lstms work in a three-step process
the first step in lstm is to decide
which information to be omitted from the
cell in that particular time step
it is decided by the help of a sigmoid
function
it looks at the previous state that is H
T minus 1 and the current input state
that is x t and computes the function
in the second layer there are two parts
one is the sigmoid function and the
other is the tan H function or the
hyperbolic tangent function
in the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through that is 0 or 1.
the hyperbolic tangent function gives
the weightage to the values which are
passed deciding their level of
importance from -1 to Plus 1. in the
third step it decides what will be your
final output
first it will run a sigmoid layer which
decides which parts of the cell State
make it to the output then
we put the cell State through the tan H
function to push the values to be
between -1 and plus 1
and multiply it by the output of the
sigmoid gate
now let's go to a jupyter notebook and
Implement a long short-term memory
Network to predict the stock prices of
Google
before that let me first show you the
data set that we will be using
so this is my Jupiter lab
and on the left you can see we have our
Google data sets so we will be using two
data sets for this demo a training data
set and a testing data set let me show
you how the training data set looks like
I'll open
the CSV table
so this is our training data set of
Google
it has the same columns like date open
high low close and volume
and if I scroll down you can see
we have data from 2012 till 2016.
let me close this
now let me open my Google test data set
so this is my test data set and
we'll be using this data set to evaluate
our model
so first
let me go ahead and import all the
libraries that we'll be needing to build
our lstm model
you can see I'm importing the numpy
pandas and matplotlib library for
numerical computation data manipulation
and data visualization
we are also importing min max scalar
function from scikit-learn
pre-processing library
then we have some built-in functions
from the Keras Library
such as sequential to analyze a sequence
of data then dense lstm and Dropout to
measure the dropout rate
I'll hit shift enter to run this cell
you can see it says we are using
tensorflow backend
now
let me go ahead and import the Google
training data set using read underscore
CSV function from pandas
I have imported my data set now if you
want to check the head of the data set
you can use data dot head
run again so it will display the top 5
rows from the data set
similarly
now let's see the total rows and columns
we have in this data set and the data
types of each variable
we'll use the info function for this
you can see
this is my output so we have a total of
six columns and 1258 entries
and here you can see the data type so
date it has taken as object
open it has taken as float hi it has
taken as float similarly close and
volume column it has taken as object
now we will do some pre-processing of
data to transform our closing price
variable to a numeric type drop the
non-available data and keep only the
close column for training the data
now to convert the close column into
numeric I have used PD dot to underscore
numeric function
now to drop my missing values I have
used drop any function
and similarly
to consider only closing column as my
training data
I am using ilock or index location
now let me run it
now let's once again see the data types
if I scroll down you can see we have
changed the close column data type to
float
earlier it was object now it's float
next we will rescale our data into
values between 0 and 1 for better
performances
for that
you can use
the min max scalar function and give the
range
then I have used fit underscore
transform method to transform the values
and then I'm also printing the shape of
my training data
let me run it
now we'll prepare our data flow training
first we need to prepare our input
sequences with 60 time steps of extreme
data alongside the respective by train
labels
next we'll be adding another axis for
the batch size since the input for an
lstm network is a 3D tensor so it will
have a sequence length the time steps
and batch size
now we'll build a model containing four
layers of lstm Network all followed by a
Dropout layer
on the top we'll also have a final dense
layer
which is this one
all of this compiled using an atom
Optimizer and a mean squared error as a
loss function
let me run it
next I'll train the data using 20 epochs
and batch size of 32 using the model.fit
function and passing my X strain and Y
train data
this will take some time to run since
it will complete 20 iterations so you
can see it has started with first Epoch
and it will run for
20 box
now we are into our second Epoch you can
see the loss that was incurred during
the training of the first epoch
meanwhile when our model is getting
trained if you have any questions please
put it in the chat section
you can see we have completed our fifth
Epoch as well now we are into our
seventh epoch
now we have entered our 15th epoch
now we are almost about to finish our
training
we have entered into our final Epoch now
I think we have successfully completed
training our model
next let's visualize the loss that was
incurred during the training process for
each epoch
I am using the matplotlib library and
the plot function
I have given a title to my
visualization I have also defined my X
labels and Y labels
So Below you can see this is how the
graph looks like on the top you can see
the title that is training model loss
you can see the loss has been a steep
decline
with that let's test the model using a
new data set
we'll continue with the same steps of
inputting the data set
so you can see I am using the read
underscore CSV function to import my
test Google data set
then we'll convert the close column into
a numeric type
I'll then drop the missing values and
select the closing price columns for
testing next I am selecting the labels
for white test data finally we are
providing the input array for the model
and converting the x-test data into a
numpy array and printing its shape
let me hit shift enter to run it
in the next cell I am predicting the
model output using the model.credit
function and passing the x-test data so
let me run it
now if you want to check the values of Y
prediction
you can just give the variable name and
hit shift enter
so these are my values it's not in a
proper order or a proper format
now
to plot the data between actual and
predicted stock prices we'll use the
inverse underscore transform function
over bypread data
and finally
we'll plot the graph in order to
visualize the actual stock price and the
predicted stock price
I am using the macplotlib library and
I'll pass in the data
we're also providing a title to the plot
the X labels and the Y labels
so this is how the graph looks like
on the x-axis you have time
and on the y-axis you have the stock
price
the red line indicates actual stock
price while the green line indicates the
predicted stock price
with that we have successfully created
our model and predicted the stock price
values using long short-term memory
networks if you have any questions
please put it in the chat section we'll
be happy to help you
hi everyone
welcome to this really interesting video
on data analysis of the 2021 World
happiness report using python
so today we will perform some
exploratory data analysis using python
libraries to analyze visualize and draw
insights from 2021 World happiness data
before I begin make sure to subscribe to
the simply launch Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update
first let's understand what the world
happiness report 2021 is all about
the international happiness day is
celebrated every year since 2013 on 20th
of March to emphasize the importance of
happiness in the daily lives of people
so the United Nations sustainable
development Solutions Network published
the world happiness report on 19th of
March 2021 that ranks the world's 149
countries on how happy the citizens
perceive themselves to be based on
various indicators
the happiness study ranks the countries
on the basis of questions from the
Gallup world pool
the results are then equated with other
factors such as GDP life expectancy
generosity Etc
this year it focused on the effects of
the covid-19 pandemic and how people all
over the world have managed to survive
and prosper
so using this 2021 data we will answer
critical questions such as the top 10
most corrupt countries
we will plot a graph to understand how
the happiness score is related to the
freedom of making Life Choices we look
at the life expectancy of 10 happiest
and 10 least happy Nations so these are
a few examples but we will explore more
about the data in detail in our demo
session
let's get started so first I'll show you
the data set we'll be using in this demo
so this data has been collected from
Kegel let me show you that
so this is the CSV data set that we have
downloaded from kegel.com so you can see
here World happiness report 2021
and
we will share the data set link in the
description of the video you can click
on the link to download the data set
now we have information about
149 countries you can see it here count
is 149 let me go to the top and I'll run
through the columns that are there in
this data set
so the First Column is the country name
so we have 149 different countries and
then we have something called as
Regional indicator we can call this as
just the region so you can see we have
different regions I've applied a filter
we have Central and Eastern Europe then
we have common wealth of independent
states so these include countries such
as Russia then we have East Asia Latin
America and Caribbean we also have South
Asia southeast Asia sub-Saharan Africa
Western Europe and other regions
I'll just cancel this and then we have
the
happiness score column that has been
sorted in descending order
so we have Finland Denmark and
Switzerland who are the top three
happiest Nations now if I scroll down we
have countries like Rwanda Zimbabwe and
Afghanistan which are the least three
happy countries
now
there are a few columns that we won't be
using in our analysis so we will learn
how to exclude those columns and keep
only the relevant ones
so columns such as
standard error of ladder score
then we have
upper viscose and lower whisker column
so we are going to ignore these columns
we are only concerned about
the GDP column which is this one then we
have the social support or the social
status column then we have the health
life expectancy
freedom to make Life Choices generosity
and
perceptions of corruption and
there are a few other
columns you can see to the right and
these columns are not of our interest so
we are going to ignore them now let's
head over to our jupyter notebook and
we'll start by importing all the
necessary libraries for analysis and
data visualization
okay so I am on my jupyter notebook so
first step I'll just
rename this notebook to let's say
happiness
report
data analysis
I'll click on rename all right now we'll
start by importing our libraries so
first Library I'm going to import is
numpy as NP
then I have
import
pandas as PD
then I'll import to data visualization
libraries C bone and matplotlib so I'll
say input
c bond as SNS and then
import
matplotlib
Dot
Pi plot which is the module name as PLT
and
I'll say
percentage
matplotlib
inline
okay
now let me just go ahead and run this
all right
well now let's set the parameters that
control the general style of the plots
the style parameters control properties
like the color of the background and
whether a grid is enabled by default or
not
so for that I'll say sns.
set underscore
Style
I'll
give it as dark grid
next I'll say
PLT Dot
RC
params
which stands for runtime configuration
parameters I'm going to set my
font
size
to
let's say 15
then I'll say
PLT Dot
RC
params
now I am going to set the
figure size so I'll say figure Dot
fixed size
let's say 10 comma 7
next
just copy this
paste it here
now we are going to set the
face color
so I'll see
figure Dot
face
color
I want to set it to peach color so I'm
going to pass in my RGB values for peach
I'm going to set it in terms of hex code
so for peach the value is f f
e
5 b and 4.
now let me run it okay
now it's time to load our data set so
for that I'll create a variable called
Data and
I'll use the
pandas Library
followed by the read underscore CSV
function because our data set that we
saw
is a CSP data set which is this one now
inside the parenthesis
I'll pass in the location of my
data file so I have my data here World
happiness report 2021 I'll just copy
this location and we'll
paste it here
and make sure the location is within
quotes
and you need to change it to either
forward slash or double backslash so
here I'm using
double backslash so let me just include
one more
backslash
and then
I'm going to pass in the
file name which is
world
hyphen
happiness
hyphen
report hyphen 2021
dot CSV which is the extension of the
file
now let me run it all right now to
display the first five rows of
information you can use the head
function
so I am writing data which is my
variable that holds the
data frame so data dot head
there you go
you can see here we have
printed the first five rows from the
data set you have the country name
Regional indicator happiness score
then we have information about the GDP
life expectancy generosity
then we have corruption data and these
are some of the columns that we are not
bothered about so we are going to drop
these columns from our analysis
now
we are going to do that so I'll create a
variable called Data columns which are
of our interest
so I am going to take only specific
columns I need the
country name so have
taken country name make sure the column
names are within single quotes So I have
my country name next I want the
second column which is
Regional indicator
I'll give a comma
we also need the
happiness score
next I need the
logged GDP per capita data
so I'll take that column
I'll say logged GDP
per capita
give a comma my next column would be
social support
give a comma here
my next
column would be Health life expectancy
so I'll write
health
life expectancy
let's give another comma and we'll take
the next column as well which is freedom
to make life choices
so I'll write that column name freedom
to make
Life Choices
and finally
we'll take the
next two columns that is generosity and
perceptions of corruption So within
single quotes I'll say
generosity
give a comma and we're going to include
the final column which is of our
interest that is
perceptions of corruption
let me have a recheck
to ensure that I have put the column
names correctly otherwise it will throw
an error
now let me go ahead and run this cell
I'll hit shift enter all right so we
have successfully
taken the columns that we'll be using
for an analysis
now I'm going to say data equal to
data I'll pass in my new variable that
is data underscore columns and I'm going
to copy all the data so I'll say dot
copy
let's run it
okay this should be data underscore
columns all right
now
let's rename all these columns we'll
make it more simpler and
easy to understand so I'll say
let's say my new
variable is Happy underscore DF which
stands for data frame equal to I'll say
data Dot we'll use the rename function
and using a dictionary we will
rename our columns so I have used a
curly bracket
I am going to pass in my
First Column which is country name I'll
just paste it here
then I'm going to give a colon
and again Within
single quotes I'll say country
underscore name so this is going to be
my new column name
I'll give a comma
we'll take the next
column which is regional indicator
I'll paste it here and give a colon and
the new column would be small r
Regional underscore
indicator
now similarly we'll do this for all the
remaining columns in the data set
okay now I have renamed all my columns
you can see it here
let's run it
now
we are going to display the head of the
data set again
so I'll say happy underscore DF dot add
there you go
so we have
only those columns that are of our
interest
so I have the country name Regional
indicator happiness score GDP social
support life expectancy
freedom to make Life Choices then I have
generosity and
perceptions of corruption
cool
now
we are going to check whether any of the
columns have
any null values so for that I will say
happy underscore DF
Dot
I'm going to use the is null function
I'll give another Dot and we are going
to find the sum
for each of the columns
you can see from the data we do not have
any
null values in any of the columns in the
data set
it is all zero
okay
now let's get started with our first
visualization that is
we'll create a plot between
happiness score and the GDP for
different regions
so for that I'll give a comment as
plot
between
happiness
and GDP
I'll just scroll down
cool
first I am going to set the
RC parameters so I'll say PLT Dot
RC params
within square brackets I'm going to give
my figure size so I'll say
figure Dot
fixed size
equal to let's say my figure size is 15
comma 7
I'll set the
title that is PLT dot title of my plot
to
let's say plot between
happiness score
and GDP
next
I'm going to say SNS Dot
let's create a scatter plot so I'll say
SNS dot scatter plot
I'm going to Define my x-axis on the
y-axis for the plot let's say in the x
axis we have
my data frame happy
underscore DF
Dot
this should be an underscore
I'll see
a column name as happiness underscore
score
give a comma
and in the y-axis we'll have
my data frame name that is Happy
underscore DF Dot
will have the GDP column that is
logged underscore GDP
underscore per underscore capital
let's give a comma and we'll pass in Hue
for
the color
let's say for Hue I am going to use the
original
column or the regional indicator column
so I'll say
happy underscore DF
Dot
Regional underscore indicator
and then I am going to give this size of
the dots as let's say 200
then I'll give a semicolon
come to the next line
I'll say PLT dot let me just scroll down
now we are going to define the legend so
I'll say PLT Dot Legend
and in Legend we'll have
the location let's say I want to put the
legend at upper left
corner so I'll say loc which is for
location equal to upper left
give a comma and then say
font size of my Legend let's see B10
make sure this is within quotes
then I'm going to pass my x-axis labels
and the y-axis labels
so I'll say plt.x label
let's see the X label is
happiness score
and my by label is
GDP per capita so I'll say PLT dot my
label
within single quotes I'll say GDP per
capital
there's an error here this should be
plot all right so I have
written my code to create a scatter plot
let's run it and see the result
there is some error here
okay this should be
Regional
indicator and not in the K3 there's a
spelling mistake let's run it again
all right
so here you can see we have a nice
scatter plot on the top you can see we
have the title of the plot that is plot
between happiness score and GDP on the
x-axis we have the happiness score from
0 to 8
and above
and on the y-axis you have the GDP per
capita
and if you see here
in this region we have
countries from
Western Europe which have the
highest happiness score and the GDP per
capita is also the highest
around this region you can see here
which is for green and in the legend you
can see green is for sub-Saharan Africa
so all these countries have
low happiness score and even the GDP per
capita is also low
and if you see the
countries for
Latin America and Caribbean you see a
lot of the values lie here so they are
all within the range of 5.52
7 in happiness score
and even the GDP per capita is more than
9 for most of them
now even the happiness score is high for
the countries that line the North
America and Enz region and even the GDP
per capita is also the highest I can
name a few countries such as Australia
New Zealand we have Canada and
United States of America which belong to
the North America and ANC region cool
now there is one country which you see
here this seems to be like an outlier
which means that this is the country
which has the lowest happiness score and
even the GDP per capita is also low but
it is not the lowest because you can see
here there are a few countries up here
from the sub-Saharan Africa which have
the lowest GDP per capita but the
happiness score is higher than this
value or this country so we can assume
that this country is Afghanistan which
has the lowest happiness score as per
the 2021 happiness report data
cool
now we'll plot a pi plot to understand
the GDP by region so by this we can know
which region has the highest percentage
contribution to the world's GDP as per
our data
for that
I'll create a variable GDP underscore
region
equal to
we'll use our data frame that is Happy
underscore DF
dot I'm going to use the
Group by function
and after that
I'm going to use my
column that is region
so we have named the column as Regional
underscore indicator so I'm going to
group it by this region column
and I'm going to sum the values of GDP
so I'm going to use the logged
underscore GDP underscore per capita
column
and after that I am going to use the sum
function
and let me just print GDP underscore
region
you can see it here we have the
sum of all the countries
for different
regions and their GDP all total
now this data we are going to plot it in
the form of a pi plot
so I'll see
GDP underscore region
Dot plot
Dot pi
we are going to plot it in terms of
percentage so I am going to use a
parameter called
Auto PCT
equal to then I am going to pass in my
format
so I'll say percentage 1.1
f
percentage percentage
then I'll say PLT Dot
title
let's see the title of my Pi plot is
going to be GDP by
region
and I'll say PLT Dot
by label
which is going to be blank
let's run it
okay
so here you can see
we have the each background at the back
because we had
assigned
a peach
face color you can see it here
so for the first
scatter plot also we had the peach color
at the back
and now you can see
we have sub-Saharan Africa contributing
20.7 percent to the walls GDP the reason
being we have
around 34 countries in the sub-Saharan
Africa
and
we have the Western European countries
contributing to 16.2 percent of the GDP
to
check the least we have North American
ANC region because we only have four
countries America Australia Canada and
New Zealand so hence they are
contributing only 3.1 percent to the
world's GDP
okay now moving ahead
let's find the total number of countries
in each region so for this we are going
to use the group by function that is
part of the pandash library and we'll
count the total number of countries in
each region
so I'll just give a comment
as
total countries
all right I just scroll down
so I'll create a variable called total
underscore country
I am going to use my data frame that is
Happy underscore DF dot I'm going to use
the
Group by function
I'll group
the values based on the region column So
within single quotes I'll see
Regional underscore
indicator
and then
I'm going to
find the total count of country name so
I'm using the column country underscore
name
and after that I'll just use dot count
now let's go ahead and
print my variable that is
total underscore country
all right now let me hit shift enter
okay so here you can see all right so
for sub-Saharan Africa there are total
36 countries and not 34 as I mentioned
earlier so hence you can see because it
has the highest number of countries it
is contributing the most to the world's
GDP that is 20.7 percent
then we have the least number of
countries in North America and ANC that
is only four
we have six countries in East Asia and
then we have 20 countries in Latin
America and Caribbean 12 countries a
commonwealth of independent states then
we have 17 countries in Central and
Eastern Europe
cool now
I'm going to show you how to create a
correlation map so that we can see the
relationship that exists between each of
the variables that are present in our
data set I'll just run through the code
and we'll see the output
okay so here I have my code written for
the correlation map that I want to
create so first of all I am going to
compute the correlation Matrix so I have
used the Corr function which stands for
correlation and the method I am going to
use is Pearson method now here I have a
Wikipedia page opened for Pearson
correlation coefficient so this is a
nice article where you can understand
what the Pearson correlation is all
about
and then I am going to set up the
matplotlib figures so I have used the
subplots function and I have given the
figure size as 10 comma 5. and after
that we are going to draw the
heat map with the mask so I'm using the
heat map function present in the c bond
library and then I have passed in my
variable that is cor which essentially
stands for correlation
and then I have used mask which is a
Boolean array or it can be a data frame
and it is an optional parameter if it is
passed the data will not be shown in
cells where the mask is true
and the cells with missing values are
automatically masked after that I have
used the
cmap parameter which stands for color
map so you can customize the colors in
your heat map and I'm going to create a
heat map which is in square shape so I
have said Square equal to true and the
axis I am going to pass it as ax which I
have defined here so this is the
matplotlib axis and it is optional so
axis in which you want to draw the plot
otherwise you can use the current active
access
now let me just go ahead and run this
and we'll see the heat map
there you go so if I scroll down here we
have the
correlation Matrix and since I had given
my cmap as blue
and here you can see it is mostly blue
and we have the scale here
now
I'll tell you how to read this
correlation Matrix so wherever the cells
are in blue or dark blue color this
means that the variables have very high
correlation and all these cells where
you see light blue color or grayish and
white color
this indicates that the variables have
very low correlation for example there
is very low or
almost negative correlation between
happiness score and perceptions of
corruption so obviously if the citizens
of a country feel that there is a lot of
corruption in the country that happiness
score would obviously be less or low and
if you see there is also low correlation
between happiness score and generosity
there is
then low correlation between
Health life expectancy and perceptions
of corruption
and if you see these places
there is really high correlation between
the happiness score and GDP per capita
again for social support also there is
very high correlation
now if you see even for
social support and healthy life
expectancy there is very high
correlation but there is
low correlation between
making life choices and generosity
and there is
negative correlation between corruption
and freedom of making life choices you
can see it is almost white color which
means it falls around this region so
negative correlation
similarly for
logged GDP per capita and
corruption that is
negative correlation all right
okay now we are going to visualize a bar
plot that will
tell us the corruption in different
regions so I'll just give a comment
corruption in
regions
let me just scroll down okay
so I'll create a variable called
corruption
which will be equal to
my
data frame that is Happy underscore DF
now first of all I am going to use the
group by function to group all my
regions so I'll say Regional underscore
indicator Which is my
column name present in the data set and
after this I'm going to find the average
of the corruption that is perceptions of
corruption so I am going to pass in my
variable name that is
perceptions of
corruption
and I'm going to use the mean function
to find the average corruption in each
of these regions
now let me just go ahead and print my
variable that is corruption
if I run it you can see here
I have the values for the different
regions and from here you can see that
Central and Eastern Europe has the
highest perceptions of corruption as per
the
questions answered in the poll
and if you see the table
we have Western Europe
and the North America region with the
least perceptions of corruption now we
are going to visualize this using a bar
plot now so first of all I'll
set my
parameters by giving the
figure size
I'll say
fig
size
it's rather figure dot fixed size
I'll just add figure here
okay
and now let's see
I'll assign it as 12 comma 8.
now I'll give a title to my plot so I'll
say PLT dot title
and my title of the plot is going to be
perception of
corruption
in
various
regions
all right
then I am going to Define my X label
so I'll say x label will be
regions
and
we'll set the font size of the X label
to let's say 13
or let it be 15
then we are going to set the
y label
in violable I'll have
corruption index
as the label name
again we are going to set the font size
to 15
now I'm going to use
X ticks
parameter
since I want to
rotate the access labels in the x axis
by 30 degrees so I'll say rotation
equal to 30
and I'll say h a which stands for
horizontal alignment equal to right
make sure this right should be within
single quotes
and finally I'll say PLT dot bar because
I'm going to plot a
bar graph
I'll say corruption
dot index
comma
and then I'll say
corruption
Dot
perceptions of
corruption which is my column name
all right so I have my code ready for
the bar plot now let me just go ahead
and
print
the bar plot
make sure everything is correct I'll
just hit shift enter
okay there is one mistake here it says
okay this should be X ticks and not X
tick
let me run it again there you go
so if I scroll down
on the top you have the
title which is perception of corruption
in various regions on the
x-axis you have the regions label on the
y-axis you have the corruption index and
if you see this
as per our table that we created
we have least corruption in North
America and ANZ region then we have the
next least corruption in Western Europe
but we have the highest corruption in
Central and Eastern Europe as per their
citizens perception similarly we have
the
second and third highest corruption in
Latin America and Caribbean as well as
South Asia
cool
now moving ahead
I'm going to show you how you can find
the life expectancy of the top 10
happiest countries and bottom 10 happy
countries so for that I am going to run
you through the code and we'll see the
visualization side by side
okay so I have my code written in these
two cells so first I am going to find
out the top 10
happiest countries and then I am going
to find the bottom 10
happiest countries so for that I'm using
the head function and I have passed in
10 since I want the top 10 country names
and to get the bottom 10 countries as
per their happiness score I am using the
tail function so let me just run it
so we have received the result in two
variables top underscore 10 and bottom
underscore 10 and to
create the bar plots we are using
two different
codes so here you can see I have set my
figure size and access and then I have
my X label as
country name
after that I am setting my
title of the bar plot to top 10 happiest
countries life expectancy I've used my
x-tick labels and I'm rotating it by 45
degrees and I have my horizontal
alignment as right
you can see it here we have used the bar
plot function I have the x-axis as
country name and y-axis as healthy life
expectancy column and I have set my Axis
then I am using the X labels and Y
labels as country name and life
expectancy and similarly I have my bar
plot for
the bottom 10 least happy countries life
expectancy
let's just run it and we'll see the
result
there you go
now if I scroll down you can see we have
two different bar plots the first one is
for the 10 happiest countries and then
we have the bottom 10 least happy
countries
so if you see
on an average the top 10 happiest
countries life expectancies above 70
years so if you are from one of these
countries you are expected to live
for more than 70 years now if you check
the bottom 10 least happy countries you
see here
Lesotho has less than 50
life expectancy age and most of them are
less than
60 years so if you are from one of the
top 10 happiest countries you are
expected to live
10 years more than these countries that
line the bottom 10 region cool now
moving ahead
all right so now we are going to see the
plot between freedom to make life
choices and the happiness score for this
I am going to use a scatter plot so
I'll first Define my figure size so I'll
say PLT Dot RC p a r a m s which stands
for parameters
I am going to pass in my
figure size so I'll say figure Dot
fig size
equal to
let's say 15 comma 7
then using the C bone library and the
scatter plot function
we'll pass in the
x-axis let's say the x-axis is
my data frame name happy underscore DF
and
I'll have the freedom to make life
choices in the x-axis
so the column name is freedom underscore
2 underscore make
underscore life
and choices
and give a comma and we'll pass in the y
axis again I am going to use my
data frame name Dot and I'll have the
happiness score
I am also going to
pass in a hue parameter
to differentiate
the different regions
so I'll say DF Dot
Regional underscore indicator
and I'll give the size of the dots
or the Bubbles as let's say 200
now I'll say
PLT Dot
Legend
I'll place the legend
at upper left corner so I am giving the
location which is loc equal to
upper left
and
font size
Let It Be
12.
I'll say PLT Dot
X label
as
freedom to make
life
choices
and my y label
would be happiness score
all right
now we have the code written for the
scatter plot that I want to create let
me just run it
there you go
so here we have the legend for the
different regions and we have the
different colors for each of these
regions
and you can see here
I have
on the x-axis freedom to make life
choices and on the y-axis we have the
happiness core
so you can see it very clearly
for the countries that line the Western
Europe region the blue dots
the freedom to make life's choices is
more and so is the happiness score
then if you see
the values the
green region which is for Middle East
and North Africa the freedom to make
life's choices is
lower and hence the happiness score is
also low and for all these countries
that are part of the sub-Saharan Africa
some of them have
decent
score for freedom to make life's choices
but the happiness score is low again
now if you focus on the
pink dots which is for the Southeast
Asian countries the happiness core is
comparatively lower but the
freedom to make life's choices is more
than
0.8
cool and again we have one data point
which is
lying at the bottom we can assume this
is Afghanistan so in Afghanistan the
freedom to make life's choices is very
low and even the happiness score is
really low
cool
now moving to our next analysis
we are going to see the top 10 most
corrupt countries
so first I am going to sort the
perceptions of corruption column and
find out the top 10 countries in the
list
so for that I'm going to create a
variable called country
I'll have my data frame name that is
Happy underscore DF dot sort underscore
values
by
I'm going to sort by
column that is
perceptions
of
corruption
Dot
head
and I want to find the top 10 most
corrupt countries as per the
Pole
and then
I'm going to
pass in the figure size so I'll say PLT
dot RC
params
and then I'm going to set the
figure size so I'll say figure Dot
fixed size
make sure there is no spelling mistake
let's say the figure size is 12 comma 6.
I'll pass in the title so I'll say PLT
Dot
title let's say the title of my plot is
going to be
countries
with
most
perception of
corruption
after that I'll say PLT Dot
X label
in the X label I'll have country and
I'll set the
font size to
13
then I'll say PLT Dot
y label
in y label I'll have the
corruption
index
next
I'll
passing the font size for the buy label
again it is going to be 13
now I'll see PLT dot X
I'm going to
rotate it by 30.
and I'll say horizontal alignment equal
to
right
and then
I'll have my
bar function or the bar plot function so
I'll say PLT dot bar
I'm going to pass in country Dot
country
underscore name
and then we'll have a variable country
Dot
the column name that is
perceptions of
corruption
all right
now if I run it
you can see here
so these are the countries with the
least perceptions of corruption so
Singapore has the
lowest corruption index
and then we have Rwanda Denmark Finland
now if you want to see the countries
with the highest perceptions of
corruption you need to change this head
to
deal of 10 since we are sorting it in
ascending order so we would want to know
the bottom 10 countries if I run it
there you go
so these are the countries with the most
perception of corruption you have
Slovakia Lesotho
Kosovo that's Ukraine Afghanistan
Bulgaria Romania and Croatia all of
these countries have a corruption index
of more than
0.85
cool now coming to the final section of
this interesting video on happiness
report data analysis for 2021 I want to
visualize a scatter plot that will tell
us how the corruption varies in terms of
Happiness score
so I'll just say
a comment as corruption versus
happiness
okay
so first of all I'll set my
figure size so I'll say PLT Dot
RC
params
within single quotes I'll give the
figure size
as
15 comma 7.
then I am going to use the scatter plot
function that is part of the c bond
Library
in the x-axis I'll have my
column that is
corruption or rather we'll have the
happiness score in the x axis so I'll
say happy underscore DF Dot
column name that is happiness score
let me give a comma and in the y axis
we'll have
the corruption column so I'll say happy
underscore DF Dot
perceptions of
corruption
and then
in Hue we'll have the region that is
Regional underscore indicator so I'll
say happy underscore DF Dot
Regional
indicator
and I'm going to give the size of the
dots so I'll say s equal to 200
foreign
PLT Dot
Legend
I'm going to
put it at
lower left corner this time so I am
giving my location as
lower left
and
the font size of the Legend I Want Is
14.
after that I'll just say PLT Dot
X label
as
corruption and
PLT Dot
y label
as
happiness score
you know this should rather be the
opposite since in the x axis we have
taken happiness score
so we'll
put the happiness code label in X and
I'll have
corruption in y
all right
so I have my scatter plot
code ready let me just run it
there you go
so here you can see on the lower left I
have the different regions and on the x
axis I have the happiness score on the y
axis I have the corruption index now you
can see the general Trend as per the
scatter plot that the countries with
greater happiness score have lower
corruption index so you can see these
countries which are from the Western
European regions have
highest happiness score and the
corruption is also really low so all
these blue countries you can name a few
Finland we have Sweden we have Belgium
France Netherland lying in these regions
we also have a few countries from North
America and ENC which are essentially
Australia then we also have Canada U.S
and New Zealand
okay now if you focus on these
green region this region
now these are the countries from the sub
Saharan Africa and most of the countries
from these regions have a very low or
less than five happiness score but
the corruption is also really high you
can see here they have almost more than
0.7 the corruption index
now
you also have a country here which is
from the
southeast Asia we would like to give you
a task it would be really great if you
can tell us in the comments section
which country is this
it has more than six happiness score but
the corruption index is really low Which
is less than
0.2
now if you consider
Middle East and North African regions
the
darker green countries here also if you
see the happiness score is less than 5
and the corruption index is also High
now there are a few countries the
Commonwealth of independent states for
example
countries such as Uzbekistan then you
also have Kazakhstan we have Russia
Armenia belonging to these
gray color dots you also have Georgia
and Ukraine as part of Commonwealth of
independent states so here you see the
corruption is below
0.6 for these countries and the
happiness score is more than 5
all right so with that we have come to
the end of this demo session on world
happiness report 2021 data analysis
using python
hi everyone welcome to this exciting
session by simply loan today we have a
really interesting topic for you in this
video we'll be analyzing the upcoming
United States presidential election
using Twitter sentiment analysis in
Python
in the course of this session we will
understand in brief about the upcoming
election the candidates fighting the
2020 U.S election and throw light on the
result of the 2016 U.S election
we look at the election forecast by some
of the popular news agencies as well as
poll analysis websites such as 538
before we begin I want to make it clear
that this video is solely for learning
purposes
we at simply learned do not lean towards
any party in the United States or our
bias towards any candidate
the analysis is based on what people
have tweeted and we will understand the
mood and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from Twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a CSV file and perform
textile analysis the results obtained
are purely based on the data that we
have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 U.S presidential
election has begun with the 59th United
States presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of November 2020.
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the United States House
of Representatives 35 of the 100 seats
in the United States Senate and Office
of the President of the United States
will be contested
both the Republican party and the
Democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president Donald Trump is
the Republican nominee
while the 47th Vice President of the
United States Joe Biden is the
Democratic party's nominee
the current vice president Mike Pence is
the Republican party's Vice Presidential
nominee and is running for a second term
in office
sanator Kamala Harris of California was
chosen by Joe Biden as his running mate
on 11th of August 2020. now let's see
the results of the last U.S presidential
election in 2016. the Republican ticket
of businessman Donald Trump and Indiana
Governor Mike Pence had defeated the
Democratic ticket of former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton and U.S senator
from Virginia Tim Kaine
Donald Trump received a total of 304
electoral votes while Hillary Clinton
got 227 electoral votes a significant
number of central states in the United
States were swept by the Republican
Party
it was surprising to see that Donald
Trump getting nearly 46.4 percent
popular vote as compared to Hillary
Clinton who got 48.5 percent votes
Donald Trump's Victory came after
crucial wins in the Battleground streets
of Florida Ohio
North Carolina and Pennsylvania
will Donald Trump be re-elected to the
White House or are we going to see a new
president and a vice president of the
United States is the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election according to 538
Donald Trump has not gained ground since
the final debate on 22nd of October
at this moment Joe Biden is favored to
win the election and he leads in both
National and State pools The Economist
is analyzing polling economic and
demographic data to predict the U.S
elections their model thinks Joe Biden
is very likely to beat Donald Trump in
the Electoral College as per their
forecast Joe Biden has 96 percent chance
of winning the Electoral College and
this 99 percent chance of Biden winning
the most votes the Democrats have 75
percent chance of controlling the Senate
while the Republicans have around 25
percent
the Democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the House of
Representatives now according to the
guardian Joe Biden is leading Donald
Trump in the National polls for the
presidential election
but to keep in mind this does not
guarantee the Democratic candidate Joe
Biden's victory
Hillary Clinton also had a clear lead
over Donald Trump in the polls for
almost the entire 2016 campaign she
ended up losing the electoral college
now the BBC forecast tells that Biden is
leading National presidential polls with
51 percent
he has hovered around 50 percent in
recent months and has had a 10 point
lead on occasions
so clearly Joe Biden is set to be the
next U.S president let's wait and watch
what happens on the 3rd of November the
voters of America will decide on 3rd of
November whether Donald Trump remains in
the white house for another four years
let's perform a tutor sentiment analysis
to understand the sentiments of people
tweeting about Donald Trump and Joe
Biden by tagging them in their tweets
we have our code implemented already
I'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail
the objective is to check the polarity
of each tweet to figure out if it's
positive negative or neutral we'll
compare the tweets of Donald Trump and
Joe Biden to see who people are favoring
the most
finally we learn to create a word cloud
I have already extracted the tweets and
stored them in two separate CSV files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for Donald Trump and Joe Biden
then please put your email IDs in the
comment section of the video we'll share
the code file and the source file with
you now you would need to install the 3p
Library fetch the Twitter keys and
access tokens and then authenticate the
Twitter API
I've extracted 5000 tweets each for
Donald Trump and Joe Biden converted
into a data frame and stored it in a CSV
file
so let me open and show you both the
files
so here is my data set for Donald Trump
on the top you can see Trump underscore
data 5000 which means there are 5000
tweets here
the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and goes all the way to 499 the
next column is the text column which has
the content of the tweet
you can see
they have tagged at the rate real Donald
Trump
there are links as well there are
special characters like emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means
it's the username who had put that tweet
similarly I have another data for Biden
you can see these are
for Joe Biden and here you can see the
content they have tagged Kamala Harris
also
similarly we have the username now let
me take you straight to my jupyter
notebook where I have implemented the
code
okay so first and foremost let's import
all the required libraries so we have
the numpy library for numerical
computation then we have the pandas
library for data manipulation next we
are importing two libraries matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
then we have text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell
in the current cell we'll import the
data sets using read underscore CSV
function present in the pandash library
so I have passed in my location where
the data file is so I have placed it on
my desktop
and
the index underscore col parameter or
column parameter refers to the columns
to be used as the row labels of the data
frame here 0 indicates that the First
Column will be used as row labels
let me run it
okay now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and
print the shape of one of the data
frames
so I'll write print
let's say we'll check the shape of Biden
data frame so I'll write print Biden Dot
shape
I let shift enter
you can see there are 5000 rows and
there are two columns one is the text
column and the next column is the user
column
now let me
go ahead and print the head of the data
sets so the head function will return
the first five rows
I'll write
Trump
dot head
you can see these are the first five
rows from the Trump data frame and
similarly if you want to check for Biden
I can write Biden dot head
you can see it here
now you can also use the info method so
let me
show you that you can write Trump dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to 499 there are
two columns and these are the number of
rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay moving ahead the next cell I am
displaying the 200th tweet present in
the Trump data frame so I have my data
frame name mentioned then I have my text
column and inside one more square
bracket I have put 200 which means I
want to see what's there in the 200th
row if I hit enter
so you can see this was the Tweet fake
[ __ ] fake president
next
let me show you
the Tweet number 1000 for Biden so I'll
write Biden and inside square brackets
I'll give the text column
and
the number is one thousand
for hit shift enter
so this is the tweet
now the text block function
is used in natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
Tuple in the form of sentiment
in Brackets polarity and subjectivity
let's check the sentiment of the 200th
to it made for Donald Trump
if I hit shift enter
you can see this was the polarity
now minus 0.399 means the polarity was
negative and you can see the
subjectivity is around 0.933
similarly let's check for Biden's tweet
number 1000
so I'll write
text
blob which is my function name
and inside brackets I'll give Biden
then
pass in my column name that is text
and I'll give the row number which is
1000
and then I'll give the
parameter or the attribute sentiment
for hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead
here
I have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity to our
two data frames Trump and Biden
let me run this
okay
in the next cell I have used the apply
function that will return the polarity
based on the tweets you can see we have
the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
Let Me Now display the top 5 rows of the
data frame so what I'll do is I'll click
on this cell go to insert and
I'll hit insert cell below
let's do one more
okay now here I'll display the head of
the data frame once again so that you
can see the polarity column added
you can see it here so for Donald Trump
we have the polarity you can see the
tweet and the polarity now 0.0 which
means these are neutral minus is
negative and anything
that's in positive value
indicates it's a
positive tweet or it has positive
polarity
similarly let's see for Biden
I'll write biden.head
okay so here you can see the
polarity for Biden now this 0.5 means
it's a positive tweet
okay
now
I want to create another column called
expression where we will classify the
tweets as positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value
so I have used the NP dot where function
and the condition we have here is if
polarity is greater than 0 it's a
positive tweet else if it is less than 0
it's a negative tweet and if the
polarity is equal to 0 it means it's a
neutral tweet
let me run this
okay so here you can see we have the
column called expression and it has
classified the polarity based on
negative neutral as well as positive
foreign ly let's do the same for Biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo then
please put your email address in the
chat section we'll send it to you via
mail
also please subscribe to Simply learn
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply alone
in the next cell of code we have another
function that will basically help us
creating a bar plot based on the
expression column from both the data
frames
so this is my user defined function name
and it has two parameters reviews and
title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly
below you can see here
we have defined the color for the bars
using RGB values
now let me run it
okay
so we have successfully created our user
defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function and pass in my two parameters
reviews and title so here we have the
function name and under reviews we have
the data frame name Trump and the title
we have given is analysis for Trump let
me run this
okay so you can see we have a horizontal
bar plot on the top you can see the
title of the plot which is analysis for
Trump
and
as per the tweets it has classified as
positive neutral or negative
if I hover over you can see there were
2831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for Donald Trump
now
let me call that function once again so
I'll write exp underscore graph
which is my function name
then I'll pass in my
parameters this time I'll take Biden and
the title I'll put is analysis
for Biden
if I run it
okay you can see the plot for Biden now
if I hover over there were 1290 positive
tweets for Biden and
747 negative tweets
okay
let's scroll down
now let me check the number of rows that
have polarity equal to 0
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than zero for
both the data frames using the dot shape
attribute so first we have
for Trump equal to equal to 0 means we
are checking the total number of neutral
tweets
you can see the result
now let's check for Biden we have the
result below
let me run it
okay
now
we'll drop those columns that have a
polarity equal to 0 from both the data
frames and display the shape you can see
we have the condition mentioned and we
have also used the drop function
so all the neutral treats will be
deleted
and I'm printing the shape of the data
frame
there you go so out of the 5000 tweet it
has deleted all the neutral tweets or
dropped all the neutral treats and this
is the final result
in the current cell we have defined
another function called balanced
underscore data now this will help us
get an equal number of rows and columns
and delete a specified number of rows
let me run it all right
now I'll call that function to delete
169 rows from the trumps data frame and
37 rows from Biden's data frame this
will help us subset the data frames
you can see
we have now 2000 tweets from each of the
data frames
up next we'll create some visualizations
to analyze the textual data
so first I am using the C bone library
and creating a distribution plot for
Donald Trump
if I hit shift enter
you can see this is the distribution
plot thus there are bars at the back and
there's a trend line
okay
similarly let me now create a box plot
so this is a box plot here you can see
there are some outliers
now let me add
a few cells below so that I can show
that plot for Biden
so I'll write SNS
Dot
I'll use the function dist plot
and under this plot I'll give
Biden underscore
subset
and
I'll pass in my column that is polarity
let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for Joe
Biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so I'll
use the c bond library and the box plot
function
I'll pass in my data frame which is
Biden underscore subset
and I'll give my column name that is
polarity
I'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for Joe
Biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert cell above okay
Now using Group by function you can
create a cross table
so I'll use
the Trump underscore subset data frame
and then I'll give my group by function
and inside Group by function I'll give
my expression column
and I'll count the number of expressions
if I run this
you can see this is a cross table
similarly you can do it for Joe Biden as
well
I'll just replace the names I'll write
Biden
and the rest is the same
you can see this is the cross table for
Biden underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets to do this
I have defined a function called
pole underscore percent and we have two
parameters declared subset and total
let me run this
okay
now here
I am calling the above defined function
and printing the polarity percentage for
Biden and Trump
and I have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number
so these are the values moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for Donald Trump and Joe
Biden
let me hit shift enter
you can see we have a
really good bar graph now if I hover the
mouse cursor you can see Donald Trump
had
27.825 percent of positive tweets and
22.17 negative similarly Joe Biden had
31.6 positive tweets and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on Trump and Biden tweets let me
run this two cells first
okay
now for Donald Trump the total positive
polarity is a combination of Trump's
total positive percentage and Biden's
negative percentage
similarly
for Joe Biden the total positive
polarity is a combination of Biden's
total positive percentage and Trump's
negative percentage
let me run this
you can see the result here
next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our accent y labels defined we
also have set our bar colors with the
help of RGB values and we have the title
as well
now if I go up you can see this is the
public sentiment so 26.88
is the percentage that is in favor of
Joe Biden and for Donald Trump you have
23.11
coming down
and the next cell of code
we have a user defined function that
will basically plot a table which has
the most positive tweets for Donald
Trump and Joe Biden the condition we are
checking is that the polarity should be
equal to 1. so if it's close to 1 or
equal to 1 which means
the Tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
okay
now let me go ahead and call the
function now
let me scroll over to the top
you can see these are the top five
positive tweets for Donald Trump and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for Joe Biden
likewise
let's check the polarity for most
negative tweets here the condition will
be the polarity should be equal to -1
which means it's highly negative
let me run it
okay
now let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so I'll write neg
underscore
tweets
and then inside bracket I'll give my
parameters
which is Trump underscore subset
and then
I'll give my title as
negative
tweets
for
Donald Trump
okay now I'll just copy this
will also check for Joe Biden so I'll
just replace this with
Biden and let's say
negative 24 Joe Biden
let's run it
okay if I go on top here you can see
the top
negative tweets for Donald Trump and
similarly we have the
top five negative tweets for Joe Biden
all right
finally
let's see how to create a word cloud
now word cloud is a method to show which
words are most frequently occurring
among the given text
I have defined a function called word
cloud you can see here and it has two
parameters data and title
inside
the built-in function or the word cloud
function we have mentioned the max font
size
the maximum words scale value there's
also background color which is white
okay
let's run it
now this will create
a word cloud
so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments so I'll write word cloud
which is my user defined function
and I'll give my parameters
Trump underscore subset
comma I'll give my title as
word
cloud
for
Donald Trump
let's see Donald Trump tweet
replies
okay
similarly
let's
do it for Joe Biden
write word cloud
Biden underscore subset
and then I'll give the title as
word
cloud
for
Joe Biden
to it replies
okay
let me run it
there you go
you can see we have a nice word cloud
so on the top you can see the title
which says word cloud for Donald Trump
tweet replies
so here you can see
some of the words like real Donald Trump
then there's president
love right
all these
similarly if I scroll down you can see
the word cloud for Joe Biden tweet
replies you can see this the handle Joe
Biden Falls there are some other words
like due taxes believe even will
it's fact
and you can see Kamala had his name here
okay now that brings us to the end of
this demo on Twitter sentiment analysis
using Text data you learned how to
classify tweets and find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had the most frequently
occurring words in the tweets so welcome
to this session where we will learn on
time series analysis using our
programming language so this is
basically a mini project where we will
look at time series data and how we can
analyze it visualize it to basically
find some important information or
gather insights from the data now when
you talk about time series analysis time
series is basically any data set where
your values are measured at different
points in time so when you talk about
time series data data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example hourly weather measurements
you have daily counts of website visits
monthly sales total and so on so when
you talk about time series that can also
be irregularly spaced and sporadic for
example timestamp data and computer
systems event log or history of 911
emergency calls now when we work with
time series data for example here I am
taking a energy data set we can see how
techniques such as time based indexing
resampling rolling windows can help us
explore variations in electricity demand
and renewable energy Supply over time
now here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which I am considering so
there is this is open Power Systems data
set and here is the data set I have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption and then you
have data for wind and solar and wind
plus solar so in certain cases you have
only the date and the consumption but
then if we scroll down we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a Time series data set
which we would want to work on sometimes
you may also have the data collected
which just does not have the time but it
may also have time stamp that is it
would have say hour minutes and seconds
and that can also be worked upon so
let's consider this data set and let's
work on this project where we will
Analyze This Time series data set now
here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long term Trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how blue wind and solar
power production compared with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find a lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically coal
or you have this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my GitHub
repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I have
given the documentation sample data set
and also your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your
rstudio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame
from this data set now here if you see I
am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column I
am also giving row dot names and I'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as I showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
update consumption wind solar wind plus
solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just create this let's look at what does
this data frame contain and here if you
see it shows me some data which has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so I can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data I can also do a tail and look
at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind solar wind dot solar and
that basically has n a values so there
are missing values but let's look at the
tail and that tells me that there is
some data available for wind and solar
and wind solar now we can always look in
a tabular format using View
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see any values but if I
really scroll down
I can see some values which would be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so I can just use view now I can
look at the dimensions of this
particular object
and that tells me there are 400
4384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can be useful but I also look at my
other columns they are of the num types
so that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column now if I try to
do this this will show me that this is
null because date as a column does not
exist because we created it as an index
so if I look at Road names
and then I search for my data show me
the index column or row dot names it
tells me these are the values that's the
date column which we are seeing here now
we can access a specific row by just
doing a my data and give the index value
or row name value so let's look at that
and that shows me based on this index
you are looking at the value you can
obviously search for a different date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector and you can give range of
values so that is 0 1 2006 to 4 of
January and we can look at this one so
it shows me
these are the values so here actually
I'm not giving a range but I'm just
selecting multiple values from row dot
names now we already know that in R you
have a summary function so you can
always do a summary and that gives you
for each column it gives you minimum
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values so we are
looking at consumption we are looking at
wind solar and wind dot solar now this
is good but then if I would want to
really visualize the data access the
data do some analysis then it would be
good to take all the columns and then we
can later decide to change the data type
of say date column if we want to use it
so earlier I was using date as row dot
names or the name of the rows or index
what you call in any other programming
language so here I will just use my data
set and I'll say header as true I'm
calling it my data 2. let's look at the
data and this one shows me
five columns wherein My First Column is
the date consumption wind solar and so
on now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type
so it tells me that if now I'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor with 4 384 levels and
these are the values so it is not in a
date time format it's a factor now what
we can do is we can convert this into a
date format how do we do that so let's
have a variable X and I'm going to use
as dot date function and I'm going to
pass in my date column so that's
assigned to X now let's look at the head
of X and it shows me the values we will
also see what kind of class it is and we
will look at the structure of X so class
already says it is date type and look at
the structure so it shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into X now how do I
basically extract values out of it or
make it a part of data frame so first I
will use so all once it has been
converted in date format I will go for
as dot numeric and here I will create a
variable called year and I will just do
a format on X which is basically of date
type and then I'm saying percentage y so
that will get me the ear component out
of this let's look at the values that
shows me year component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if I look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what I can do is I can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c byte that is
column bind and I will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me date so
that should be date format consumption
now this one might not be date format
but we'll see you have consumption wind
solar and we have extracted the year
month and day which can help us for
group by we can do some aggregations we
can do a plotting and we can do various
things by these additional columns now
let's look at first three rows here so
I'll say one is to 3 for my data 2 and
that shows me some data here you can
always do a head and look at the sample
of data so that basically shows me month
day your columns and then you have your
date now what we can do is we would want
to visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as I said if we want to visualize the
data say for example I want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here gigawatt
hours so if I would want to create this
visual to basically understand the
pattern of the data how do we do it so
we can you create a line plot of
full-time series of Germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is I can straight away
use the plot method I can then say what
would be in my x-axis what would be on
my y-axis what would be the type of
graph I would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so I am saying my data 2
I'm extracting the year column and here
I am taking the consumption so let's
create a plot and here if you see we are
looking at a plot we do see some tick
times and we see that the data has been
divided with every two years so from
2006 onwards to 2016 but then really
this data does not give me uh you know a
very useful way of looking at the rate
or understanding it might be what I can
do is I can use the same way but I can
give apart from x axis and y axis I can
say that limits that is X limit is 2006
to 2018 and Y limit is from 800 to 1700
so we can do this and let's look at this
again this is a plot but it really does
not help me in visualizing and
understanding the data so what are the
better options
I can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns so as of now we will
just keep it as it is par
MF row now if I would want to plot I can
straight away give the column name so I
am interested in getting the consumption
now I can just do a plot I'll say my
data 2 and I will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here
from our data so consumption was the
second column so I can just do a plot in
a straight away way without mentioning
your x-axis y-axis limits and so on and
if you look at this this one is giving
me a pattern now here I am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph and
we are looking at the data it does show
me some kind of pattern but might be we
can make it more meaningful so I can do
it this way where I say my data second
column let's give access as ER x axis
y-axis is consumption now that has
changed the x-axis and y axis now I can
also give some more details I can say
type should be line I have the line
width I'm saying color is blue and let's
do this so this looks more meaningful
maybe shows a wavering pattern of
consumption over years I can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying X limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018. I can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so I can do a
plot I can choose column second X lab
which is x-axis y-axis type is line
width giving X limit y limit and then
I'm giving a title to this which is
consumption graph and then basically you
are looking at the line graph now those
are the options which you can do either
you could be very specific or you could
just give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details now what we can
do is if we would want to look at this
data and understand it better rather
than just looking at a simple line I can
take the log values so here I am saying
log of my data to Second column so I'm
taking log values of consumption and I'm
taking the difference of logs so I can
say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it by some number so rest
Remains the Same I'm changing the color
and let's look at this plot and you see
this basically is giving me a better
pattern which makes meaning here we see
the log values so this is you are using
a simple plot function
in R you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so I'll
say no I will access this by using the
library ggplot 2.
and now I can use ggplot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data too that's the data frame I am
saying type as o and when I'm saying
line I am basically going to use x-axis
which is here Y is consumption and let's
look at this plot so again we are back
to the one which we were doing earlier
really does not make any sense gives us
some data but then really does not give
me enough information I can
in my Aesthetics I can say access here
Ys consumption I can do a grouping and
then I can give line and plot so again
we have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so I am just doing the
same thing here and I'm looking at line
type being test I'm using the GG plots
other methods such as geomline and
geompoint to give me more information
and if I look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but I would
still prefer the way we were doing with
plot
now we can change the color and
obviously add details to it so what we
see is when you use the plot method
which I did earlier it was choosing
pretty good tick locations that is every
two years and labels the years for the
x-axis which was helpful right but with
these data points which we were seeing
here
or say for example this one
or say this one
or say this one we are looking at some
data but then that really is quite
crowded
and it is hard to read you can look at
the values but then it really does not
give you enough information so we can go
for plot method but then we will see how
we can consider different data now if I
would want to plot the solar and wind
time series so let's see how do we do
that
so wind column is what I'm interested in
so first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so I'm saying
minimum I'm saying let's put in here my
data to
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns we know
consumption is the second column when
does the third column and you have solar
as the fourth and this one is the fifth
so let's say let's find out the minimum
of each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column and here I'm also
saying remove the any values because we
do not want to consider the N A values
so let's let look at the minimum that
shows me
5.7757 what is the maximum value it is
826 so that also helps me in giving a
limit if I want to plot wind on y-axis I
can give a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or give some limits so that's fine now
for multiple plots as I said instead of
having one plot let's plot consumption
and wind and solar and try to see a
pattern so I can say par function and I
will say three rows and one column so
now when I start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier and let's
look at the data so that gives me some
data you can always do a zoom and you
can look at the data you can basically
expand this graph or you can reduce this
graph to see what kind of pattern we
have in consumption similarly we can
basically choose date being x-axis my
consumption being y-axis right so this
is being more specific because here we
have a range but it really does not give
me enough information so I will
basically give x-axis Y axis I will give
the name that is daily totals and then I
will basically give consumption color
and Y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this and now
we can look at the data here so let's
see this later makes a little more
meaning because we are looking at the
dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me how the data pattern is
changing for consumption now this is for
consumption so what we can do is we can
also extract specific data so if you see
here I have done some testing where I am
saying okay I would want to get a date
specifically
I would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just changed the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it it would be good if we can convert
a column into date time format and put
that in our data frame now let's look at
the plot 2 this is mainly for your
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so here I see it is solar
data and I can plot this one to see how
it looks like
and that tells me from 2006 onwards we
have some pattern I can be more specific
where I say I would be giving date and
then the column for solar x axis Y axis
what is the type what is the Y limit and
what is the color it is always good to
specify your X and Y axis give a name
rather than let it automatically pick up
now this makes more meaning because it
shows me some dates similarly we can do
for wind so either you do it just by
giving the column
or you give your X and Y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot 3 this one we can choose
plot 2 we can choose plot one and we can
put all that data in one graph so that's
when you are putting in multi plots in
one particular graph you can always do a
zoom you can always look at the data
right and this is usually useful to look
at the pattern what kind of pattern we
see what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window and let's basically plot
time series in a single year so what we
have seen is that when you look at the
plot method it was quite crowded then we
looked at solar and wind and if you
compare that you will see your
consumption pattern your solar pattern
your wind pattern and basically we can
see from this particular data data some
kind of pattern so electricity
consumption is highest in the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in Winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year further into months we can see that
but we see a pattern which goes for
every year or every two years being
highest at a particular point of time
and then it drops down so electricity
consumption is highest in Winter and
that might be due to electrical Heating
and increased lighting usage and lowest
in summer now when you look at
electricity consumption appears to split
into two clusters we can always look at
the consumption one with oscillation
centered roundly around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at 1400 gigawatts
and you see all the values here which
are in that particular consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points entries roughed around 1150
so if you really expand this you can see
you will have lot of data points at this
point
now we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production that is
highest in summer when sunlight is most
abundant and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you're
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge you are you know knowledge of
business to understand how this goes if
you look at wind power production that's
again highest in Winters and drops down
in summer so due to stronger winds and
more frequent storms and lowest in
summer
so there is some kind of increasing
Trend in wind power production over
years which we can see here
over the years
and all the time series data what we are
looking at is referring or showing us
some kind of seasonality that is we are
looking at seasonality in which a
pattern is repeating again and again at
regular times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons for example
if you look at retail stale sales data
uh that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months so seasonality when we say can
occur on other time scales so the plots
what we are seeing here they are fine
but if you look at those plots they
might show some kind of weekly
seasonality also so in your consumption
corresponding to weekdays and weekends
so let's plot for one single year now
how do I do that so first is I will look
at my data too
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is Factor other columns which
are all numerics now like we did earlier
I'll repeat this step where I'm going to
convert the date column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what I want to do is I want to add
this
as to my data frame so I will create a
variable called mod data and this one
will have as data and I'm formatting the
value of x which is date time into month
day and year so let's do that and now
you look at the mod data which I created
like modified data so this is the format
I have it is in date type if you
carefully see here and then I can look
at the head of it so it saves me mod
data now we are what we did here is when
I said my data 3
so my data 3 we did a c bind and I did a
mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data
too so my new data frame is my data 3.
let's look at the structure of it and
you see there is this date column I can
delete it I can remove it I can let it
be right so that depends on our choice
might be we want to once our analysis
done we want to remove the mod data
right so we can keep both of them now
let's basically extract data for a
particular year now how do you do that
so this is some wrangling so I will say
my data 4 let's call it my data 4 and I
will use subset function so subset will
work on my data 3 that's the data and
what I'll do is I will do a subset how
do how is the subset found so I'll say
take the mod data column the value
should be greater than or equal to 2017
and should be less than
2017 December 31st so I'm getting data
for one year and I'm storing it as my
data 4.
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data now let's do a plotting of this
where I will only create a plot for one
year so I'm saying my data 4 that's my
new
data what we got
so here I am going to take the first
column
which is mod data
I am going to take the third column
which is consumption so I'm looking at
the date format for one year consumption
values for it and then rest of the
things as we have done earlier let's
look at the plot and this makes more
meaning right so when you look at this
plot it tells me Jan to Jan it shows me
some kind of pattern where I have
divided the year into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so Jan and March and May and July
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where I've broken it down into
months so this is where you have taken
time series in a single year to
investigate further and this is what we
see right now we can clearly see there
are some weekly oscillations what one
more interesting feature is that at this
level of granularity that is when you're
looking at yearly data there is a
drastic decrease in electricity
consumption in early January and late
December during the holidays or probably
we can assume that this is holidays now
I can zoom in further and look at just
Jan and Feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data 3 I was doing a subset
and I was giving the date but this time
I will make it more narrower so I'll say
my data 4 I will say subset from my data
3
and I will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format I
will choose the starting date as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is Jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this now again as I said earlier
let's find out the minimum of this from
the
First Column so that is basically your
mod data so let's look into this one and
that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the value so this one tells me
Jan 17 January 1 and maximum is
your
Feb 28th second month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I am
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I am giving some naming
convention for sorry namings for your
x-axis y-axis what is my consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see I'm using X limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and Y limit so let's look at this data
and if you look at this data it is
specifically for two months and again I
can look at the pattern here what I can
also do is I can add some grid here
so I can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now I can add
a line here using AB line and then I can
basically choose what lines I would want
to add horizontally so that basically
allows me to dissect the data and look
at data in a more meaningful way I can
also add vertical lines so vertical
lines is I'm saying sequence will be
minimum maximum and I'm saying an
interval of seven so let's do this and
this basically has added some lines
every week and you can see at the end of
week it is dropping and then it is
starting again it Peaks somewhere in the
middle of the week and again it drops
down so this is you're looking at your
consumption data right now what we can
also do is we can create some box plots
so when we looked at zooming in data for
Jan and Feb you can add some data point
points like this so consumption is
highest on the weekdays as I showed you
here and lowest on the weekends so this
is what we are seeing when we are
breaking the data or zooming it further
for a couple of months so we have
vertical grid lines and we have nicely
formatted tick labels that is Jan first
and 15th Feb first and so on so we can
easily tell which days are weekdays and
weekends with use of these grid lines
and basically breaking it down so there
are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use use
histograms and so on now moving further
we would want to explore the seasonality
right so when you further explore the
seasonality of our data we can use box
plots basically to group the data by
different time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so I can just do a simple box
plot and I can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
plot it is basically a visual display of
your Phi number summary that is you want
to look at your mean median you want to
look at your 25th percentile 50
percentile or 75th percentile so we can
use a quantile function use the
consumption column and then you
basically give a vector which shows you
Phi number summary so that's your
quantile and then let's do a box plot so
if you are looking at quantile it tells
me what is the minimum what is 25th
percentile 50 75th and 100 that's from
my consumption column so let's create a
box plot for consumption let's give it a
name as consumption let's give y-axis as
consumption and a limit for y-axis now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the year
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on year
so here I can give x axis y axis and I
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now I'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me 5 percentile or
sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot by just
giving consumption yearly grouped and
here I am giving the title as
consumption Y axis x axis and y limit
wherein I can also use less so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me the tick
points if you compare this one to the
previous graph so when I created this
previous graph I had 2 2006 2008 and I
had from 600 to 1800 and if I go for the
next one I am basically seeing more
useful information now let's look at
monthly data so I would want to group it
based on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where I'm looking at
months
and I could select a particular year or
I can just do a grouping based on months
so I can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this now
let's create a box plot for consumption
which is monthly data and let's give it
a color let's look at the wind data
which is again grouped monthly and let's
look at the solar data which is grouped
monthly now if I zoom in it basically
gives me the seasonality of the data for
your wind for your consumption for your
solar so what we are doing is we are
creating these box plots which are
giving us values now what I can also do
is I could look at the day wise also but
before we look into this how do I infer
some information from these box plots
which are being created so this is what
we have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me ear seasonality which we were seeing
in our gear plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in Winters and
lower in summer so we can obviously look
at our plot we can see where it is lower
where it is higher and then we can look
at the median and lower two quartiles
are lower in December and January
compared to November and February so
that is you look at the quartiles and
you will see that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in December and January
kill Jan and December so you can look it
from my plot now this is giving you some
idea on seasonality
now that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at your solar and wind
power production both will give you a
year seasonality what we are seeing here
and
if basically I look at the data so it
depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise so here let me again reset
this to one plot per graph now I'll say
box plot I'll say consumption which is
group based on day now we know that
there is a day column and let's give a y
limit and let's look at the data so this
is where I am grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here I have given day and I have chosen
all the 31 days but I can break it down
to a week and I can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption where I'm doing
a consumption group by day is higher on
weekdays than on weekends
so time series with strong seasonality
can often be represented with models
that can decompose signal into
seasonality and long Trend now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here we have
looked at data so what we will do is we
look at the frequency now when you look
at the frequency when you talk about
frequency in your data so we have the
modified date column which gives me a
frequency and if we really look into the
data that will tell me that the data is
on a daily basis so for that let's look
at my data 3 again which gives me data
and you can just see all the data's data
or dates are in sequence so your 22 23
24 25 26 and so on I can look at I can
access a d player package
that is basically allowing me to work in
a better way now I can look at the
summary of this and for all my columns I
am seeing what is the minimum Phi number
summary date and consumption so date
does not show me anything because this
is not in a date format it is just a
factor but other things have the fine
number summary so we are looking at wind
plus solar we are looking at year and
month and day and all these columns now
what we will do is we will want to find
out the sum of each
column how many entries does it have and
we will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns so let me run this
again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have and these counts do
not include the N A values now similarly
I can find out specifically for
consumption I can find out is there any
n a value so I'm saying is Dot N A and
let's find out if there is any n a value
or missing value in consumption it says
0 okay that's good if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are n a
similarly solar similarly wind dot solar
or wind plus solar so it gives me a
count of n a values that is missing
values and also values which are not
missing so to understand frequency what
we can do is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the First Column and
I am saying RM
n a DOT RM is true that is get rid of n
a values and find out the minimum and
let's look at the minimum value this is
the minimum from my modified date
now if I would want to get the frequency
I can basically use sequence function so
I can say from X minimum that is the
minimum value I want to look at the
frequency that is day wise and let's
just look at five entries and see if
there is a day by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is day wise
frequency so that allows me to look at
the frequency look at the type of it it
is an integer class is a date so
similarly we can say from X minimum we
can basically look at the frequency
month wise and I can again look at five
records so that shows me monthly data
right so I can extract the data for
frequency similarly yearly data and
that's also very useful now we can
select data which has any values for
wind so how do I do it I would want to
find out the wind column and I want to
find out where the values are in a so I
will create a variable and here I will
say my data 3 and then I give a
conditional where I say is n a
in the column so let's do this now once
I've done this
once I have done this I have said that
my selected wind data from my data 3
where we said any values and I will give
the names to this so name should be in
my data 3 I'm interested in mod data
consumption wind and solar so these are
the four columns I'm interested in let's
look at first 10 records here or first
10 rows so that tells me these are the
values where wind has n a or missing
values
I can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data so it basically shows
me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has any solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out any values
now what we will do is we will select
data which does not have any values so I
will call it cell selected wind 2 I'll
again use my data 3 I will say which but
now I am saying not any
from this column and I will select the
data for the columns so I am interested
in looking at 10 records and this shows
me not any value so no more missing
values so if I really look at this data
as I saw earlier which has n a and if I
look at these values which are not any
for the wind column so looking at these
two result we will know that in year
2011 wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do I
do that let's call it a different
variable I'll say my data 3 I will say
here when I say which where we were
saying n a here I will say the year
should have a value of 2011 and I want
all these columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
V
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame to a view and
this one will help me in finding out
where are the N A values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and I will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
I could select and search for one
specific value and I'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data and seeing is
wind column having n a or missing value
for a particular row and let's scroll
here and here you see there is a missing
value for one particular row so 13th
December 2011 has wind value 15 December
has wind value but your 14th December
does not have right similarly we can
search so there was only one entry which
was missing now that could be for some
reason might be it was not calculated
might be it was not tabulated so we have
a missing value and that can affect my
plotting that can affect my analysis so
let's look at the number of rows in this
which will tell me how many rows we have
for 2011 so it tells me 365 so that is
basically the number of days in a year
now we will find out if there were any
values so we earlier checked total
number of any values per column
that is in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269
so this is where we were seeing are
there any n a values right so let's go
back here
and
we want to find out the number of any
values for a particular year how do I do
it so I can just do a sum I will say is
n a now I am interested in my data 3
wind column and I am saying my ear has
to be 2011 but I am finding out the N A
values
so let's do this and it tells me one and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see how many non-na
values you have and that is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so it's 364 plus 1
missing so there are 365 let's look at
the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable
selected wind 4 I will save in 3 that is
which was having all my n a and non-na
values for 2011 I will say let's find
out the n a value
because I am interested in finding out
that particular row so I'm saying find
out where the values n a and I want all
the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific
row which has a n a value
now we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has any and
non-na values so let's say let's call it
test one I will use wind 3 which has n a
non-na values but now I will say I want
the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001. now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of December there is no date
so I will select a subset of data which
includes this n a and non n a that is
might be I can take 13th of December and
15th of December so let's start from 12
12
so the date should be greater than 12 12
that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have a I've selected a
subset of data I could have done this
using subset also so I have any and non
n a values now why are we doing this so
sometimes you might have some data for a
particular column and you may want to
find out if there are any missing values
might be you want to fill them up or
replace them with something so that is
usually useful when you are doing a
trend detection so say for example you
have data for every month and might be
in one one of the months you have missed
or might be you have data for every year
collected monthly and then in one of the
years for a couple of months you don't
have the data like I can say 2016 I have
data for all 12 months 2017 all 12
months 2018 might be a don't have data
for March and June 2019 I don't have
data for same months so I can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous year's same month data so we
can do that so here I have test data
where I have extracted a subset of data
I can look at the class of this it is a
data frame structure of this it has the
columns now let's use the library and
function and use the Tidy r package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so I will use test one I will fill
the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward fill so filling values
can be done in different directions as I
said and you may want to First convert
your time series to specified frequency
if your data does not have a frequency
but we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as I showed you and then
basically you can do a forward fill
for the values so for example if I have
my data I can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data I
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data then let's
look at the trends of the data which is
the last part of this project so
basically let's look at the trend So
when you say Trend what does that mean
so in Time series data you always have
some kind of trend so that will exhibit
some slow gradual variability in
addition to higher frequency variability
such as seasonality and noise now to
visualize these Trends what we do is we
use what we call as rolling means so we
know how our data is spread over year or
month or day but how about looking at a
rolling average and see what is the
difference so a rolling mean will tend
to smooth a Time series by averaging out
the variations and frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called those
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame you can also average out any
seasonality on a time scale equal to
window size so this will allow you to
look at lower frequency variation in the
data
so when we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean using the
zoo package and you can say what is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I am going to my look at my data 3 which
we have been using so far now let's call
it a three day test you can give it any
name I'm going to use my data 3 I'm
using the piping function
now I will use D plier and I will
arrange the data descending in here now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so I'll call it as
says 0 3 day so I'm going to calculate a
rolling mean every three days for my
consumption column and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and here
when I'm doing a three day test
let's look at the result of this and
then I'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven is
the average consumption in 2017 from the
first date with the data point on either
side of it that is you can look at this
date so one one three zero then you look
at
you are looking at the value one three
six seven here so you look at one one
three zero one four four one one five
three zero if I take a mean of these so
for example if I would just do this part
and that
is giving me mean okay because I have a
comment so let's basically add anything
as comment and then let's do this so it
saves me one three six seven that's what
we are seeing here right so you're
getting a rolling average every three
days similarly if you want every five
days it takes the five values and it
gets the mid value right so you can
always find out the mean rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and yearly data that is 365 days so how
do I do it same logic my data test
now I am using my data 3 I'm arranging
it in a descending order I am grouping
by year so when you do a group by year
so earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had right so
let's do a grouping by year and let's
say test 0 7 so that's a rolling average
every seven days and I'm also saying
take care of the N A values similarly
I'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly might
be you can do half yearly and let's do
this so let's create this my data test
and let's look at the result of this so
I will use my data test I will say
arrange based on modified date now we
know there is a column called modified
date I want to just look at 2017 data so
I'm doing a filter
right and then I will choose what are
the columns I'm interested in so I will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first seven records so let's do
this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average order of
seven day mean which is for first seven
days and then 365 you will not see the
data here but if I do a view on this I
can basically see the values so you can
always select a particular column to see
the values
these are the values for every seven day
rolling average this is for 365 days
every 365 days so you see all the values
are missing but every 365 entry you will
have basically some data
now
let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting I will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is spread over a period of
time and that's fair enough but now
let's add some more plot to this so I
will add the seven day rolling average
to this so for second plot we added in
the same one in R you can use points so
I will say points I will choose 7 data
column type is line width x limit y
limit and color so let's do this and
that's my pattern seven day rolling
average which basically gives me some
kind of trend
similarly I can add one more here and
this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be aware in x axis and y axis so I'm
saying it will be 2500 and Y is 1800 so
my Legend will come in some in here I am
saying my Legend will have consumption
test and this one I can give some names
I can give what is the color I can say
what kind of
Legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
I've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here I see that my x-axis is fine but Y
axis is going a little about of my
plotting area so I can actually change
that so here I have 1800 how about
making it 1600 and let's look at this
one so we can basically uh go for this
one and start again here plot and points
and line and then add a legend right and
you can basically place your Legend
anywhere in the plot so this basically
is giving me the trend what I'm looking
at my rolling average so similarly you
can look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so seven day
rolling mean has smoothed out all week
leases anality which we were seeing Here
in My Graph where you look at every
seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality so seven day will tell that
electricity consumption is typically
higher in Winter and lower in summer so
better is you break it down uh yearly so
here if you look at every year you can
see when it's winter when it's summer
what is the seasonality what your Trend
what you are seeing here and if there is
a decrease or increase for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
365 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically
uh reduces the variation so if I look at
360 by Rolling mean we can see long-term
Trend in electricity consumption is
pretty flat now that's what we are
seeing it's kind of pretty flat there is
not much variation over the years if you
really join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code
which you have here in the form of a
project.r file you can find here in my
GitHub page this is a document which
explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder so continue learning
and continue practicing R okay now let's
see two more crucial projects related to
German Credit Data and College admission
project so here we are going to use two
algorithms the first would be a logistic
regression algorithm on the German
Credit Data and then we'll explore about
K means clustering algorithm and solve a
business case study regarding College
admission
you can use the Anaconda Navigator and
the which is your jupyter notebook which
will then open up in Google Chrome this
is one of the Ides or ways of editing
python code I like this one because it
one protects my computer and creates its
own kind of container and two it's got a
really nice visual demo for doing python
certainly you can use a number of other
different tools like pycharm there's
another real popular one you can
actually access pycharm code through the
Anaconda Navigator now and there's a lot
of other tools on there that each have
their benefit and we come into our
jupyter notebook go ahead and create a
new python I've already done that and
we'll start with a lot Logistics
regression model just so you can see
what this looks like in code we'll
actually do two of these
as we go through this and take a look
and see what that code looks like in
Python now the first thing we want to go
ahead and do is
load up all our parts modules that we
need in our python code
I'll go ahead and run that and you'll
see here I'm going to ignore warnings
because some of the stuff we're doing
we're just looking at it and as you go
from one version of python to one
version of whatever the site kit or in
this case the SC package you'll see some
warnings come up they're not really
important right now
um and then we're going to go ahead and
use the German Credit Data CSV
and so when I run this this is all
loaded up now let's go ahead and just
open up this CSV file so you can see
what that looks like
and here he is here's our German Credit
Data file we'll go ahead and just open
that up with ah let's do wordpad is fine
because it's a Word document
and when we open that up
you can see right here is just a bunch
of comma separated values we have across
the top it actually has columns on here
so our first row is a bunch of columns
and then of course we look down here
oops I just move stuff around but that's
okay I'm not going to save it and you
can see the values al1 al4 whatever that
means or A14 I guess and then some sort
of numbers on here
and we'll take a closer look when we get
into the program
and looking at the data for right now
we've loaded that under credit DF
and at this point I want to just kind of
take a detour back to the life cycle of
data science so we can see how that fits
in there
and so we've already done our data
Discovery we have a little data prep but
the data is pretty clean it already
comes in preset on there we'll make do a
little data preparation in here we're
going to start looking at exploring the
data analysis and building a data model
and then interpreting the results so
really we're focusing on the last three
steps of this the data Discovery would
be asking start asking questions of what
do we want in there is this going to be
is this going to be a good loan a bad
loan what do we want to get out of this
data where are we going with it that
would be part of the data Discovery and
a lot of times that might be a meeting
you have with the management in the
office or whatever
and then data preparation is of course
cleaning the data up making sure you
know where the source came from all
those kind of fun things that go into
making sure you have good data coming in
now you'll notice here
uh we've got we're using uh pandas
whoops drew it through the pandas and
we're going to go ahead and read it as a
panda's data frame and of course Panda
sits on numpy so a lot of stuff you do
with pandas can go right into numpy very
easily
uh and the reason I bring this up is
because pandas has a lot of tools in
there for just looking at the data real
quick and easy
and so the first one we want to go ahead
and do is do credit.df or credit
underscore DF our data we read in info
and just see what that looks like
and when we go ahead and print this out
you can see here we have
13 columns remember we were looking at
our data and it had those that row you
couldn't read across the top
and then it has non-null count how many
values don't have null what kind of
objects are they they're an object an
integer
different things like that and we look
at object is it a checking account this
is probably text on here
duration how long credit history amount
savings account present employee
employed since so a lot of different
numbers coming in here and these are
just the columns we're looking at
and if you're going to look at the
columns it's kind of nice to actually
look at the data
and so we'll use the pandas to go ahead
and print it out just like you would on
a spreadsheet
hard to see them all on here but you can
see we have here's our row across the
top because Panda does such a good job
sorting out columns
and the actual data checking account a11
a12 A14 not sure what that means
duration how long they've had it credit
history I'm not sure what the a33 or a34
means I'm sure it has a special meaning
on there the amount here's our savings
account and all the information on that
and this is actually a very a much more
easy to read view than what we had
before as far as like that text file
when you're just looking at data through
the database sometimes those can be
really hard to read this you can really
see and if I take it down a notch I can
get all the columns in here we'll go and
keep it zoomed in just so we can see
that what's going on a little easier
and then we can also do credit df.i
location the ilocation feature in the
pandas is going to go ahead and do rows
0 through 5 and we're going to look at
columns one through seven and let's go
ahead and just run that and you can see
right here how we just split it up so
it's really easy to manipulate our data
and get a smaller view of different
parts of the data as we're going through
it and just like we can look at the
first seven columns we can also look at
the last seven columns
uh same kind of format we're looking at
row 0 through 5 column seven to the end
if you leave the number out there
and you can see we can easily now look
at this on a smaller screen much better
for displaying those are just tricks to
help you display
your information so that when you
present this in front of a group of
people
it makes it very easy to read or you can
just copy this out and put it into a
document that kind of thing and then we
also like to go ahead and do like credit
status value counts and things like that
again we're just looking at the
different uh sets of information on here
and in our pandas data frame value
counts is we're looking at unique values
so there's a lot of unique values in
here that's um 700 and 300 that's a
significantly uh diverse set of data
and if we look at the data one of the
things we're looking at is the status 0
1 0 0 1
and I'm going to guess that that means
that it is either default or not default
so that's probably what we're going to
want to look for hopefully you've had
your specialty in domain remember we
talked about the different parts of data
science domain is what field it is in
this would be in Banks and loans and so
if we want to figure out what the status
of a new loan is we're going to separate
the status out and so if we take our X
features equals the list of the columns
that's all this is credit underscore
df.columbs we remove status
uh and then we go ahead and this will
print our features out and you can see
it's everything but the status on the
end because that's what we want to
predict we want to predict the new data
whether that's status is zero or one or
not and next we want to do a little bit
more data preparation we're going to go
ahead and encode
and we're going to take an encode credit
DF we're going to create that off of our
setup on here
and you're going to ask well what are we
encoding on here well when we go up to
here let me just go back all the way
when we're looking at all this
information up here
you can see there's a object
object object well if I'm doing a
prediction and something's just a random
object it doesn't really mean anything
there's no numbers to process
and so when we come down a little
further we can see down here that we are
looking at
a65 I'm not sure what a65 means we're
looking at a 93 personal status we're
looking at a143 these aren't actual
numbers there's some kind of code that
the bank put in probably and so for our
model they really don't mean anything
unless we convert them to numbers
and you convert them to numbers by
literally creating a bunch of yes no's
so instead of thinking it as as
a173 and a172 as being 0 1 and if you
had an A7 174 maybe 0 1 2 you would
think of this as a label a173 is true or
false and then you'd have another label
a172 is true or false so for every
unique job in here that it becomes
another feature added in and it's on or
off it's true or false that's what this
encoding is doing
and we'll go ahead and list our encoding
as it comes out and if you come up here
you can see it did exactly what I was
describing we've now encoded it so
here's checking account a13 checking
account
a1214
a31 here's all of our uh
checking account numbers so there was
three of them uh here's our credit
history a31 a32 a33 34. again the
computer has no idea of knowing what
those are all it knows is those are each
unique features and the same thing with
the savings account a62 and so on going
down and so once we have our nice listed
there we can go ahead and do um
let me pull this in here we go let's
look at our new data set
and if we go ahead and run the new data
set we have our in-cone credit DF
checking and we're just going to look at
these and look at the head this is just
the first few of these so we can see
what it actually looks like in the data
and just like I said it's now uh zero
zero zero zero one one zero zero
this First Column is just the count zero
one two three four that's not part of
the data but you can see here
that it just puts a check mark of one uh
because it's an AC a12 and we have a
checking account aca14 where it's also a
check mark of one going across
so we've done a little data preparation
uh we've come in here and done some
exploratory data analysis
and now we want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model and then interpreting the
results on this and so when we go ahead
and import our stats models as API
as SM
now a lot of times we use the SK learner
the scikit models in this one we're
going to go ahead and use the SM model
from stats models which is pretty common
for doing a very basic Logistics
regression model and then from the site
kit we're going to have our train test
split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your date in your setting
up your models is to split it up into
your training set and your testing set
and what I want you to notice on here is
we have X train well what is X Train
That's all the columns except for the
last one which was the status was it
default or was it in in good standing
and then of course our X test is part of
the data we're going to split that up by
0.3 so 30 percent of the data is going
to be 30 of our rows are going to be put
in the X test and the Y train and Y test
is just the status and then we create
our once we've created our data and
split it up we go ahead and create our
model and it's a logit we're just going
to call it logic but you can a lot of
times you end up seeing logic model
um with logit
equals the sm.logit X train
y train X train and SK learn it's always
X train y train uh but in the
stats model is reversed on there and
then they go ahead and run the fit so we
load the data up and then we fit it
and then we can go ahead and summarize
that model and see what it looks like
and let's go ahead and run that
it takes it just a moment uh and we got
a nice summary of our data again we're
still looking at the data and we have
takes just a moment to to kind of feed
through and you can certainly see where
we have our coefficient which has to do
with the weights in the model standard
error that's very important as we look
at this coefficient and how it affects
the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
Z 0.025 these are all your statistical
notes on here so as you look at these
you might look at like how big is a
standard error that's one of the big
ones that I usually look at as we go up
and we start looking at the different
things the higher the error the less the
more we want to be a little careful of
it the lower the error the better in
more general terms they also have
dealing with the model and it's
iterations you can see some general
status on here how many iterations did
it have to go through true before I was
able to come up with the numbers because
it kind of guesses it's playing a high
low game and it takes it six iterations
till it finds what it considers the best
fit uh and you can see there's more
information up here as far as when it
converts how it converts and so on now
when we have our summary up there one of
the questions starts coming in remember
I told you we're looking at like our
standard error and you know how these
numbers all are telling us how important
each one of these features is in running
our prediction and if you have a ton of
features and some of them are just kind
of all over the place all they do is
create noise so we really want to get
rid of them they also cause issues in
that if you're running a huge amount of
data and you have to rerun this model
over and over again this can really text
your time and so you're losing both time
money and your results might not be as
good because they might be weighted
based on some of these very fuzzy
numbers
uh so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that again we're we've come
in if you remember from back here uh
we're still in kind of an exploratory
data analysis and data modeling they
kind of go hand in hand sometimes we
haven't quite got to interpreting the
results in running predictions and so
we'll go ahead and build this thing on
here it looks at the LM values so that's
coming up here where this was generated
I didn't have to actually look that up
for the this particular model because I
usually use the sklearn version of this
so as we look at this we're going to
look at the P values of our variables
and basically we're looking to see how
good the p-values are if they're less
than or equal to 0.05 we probably
those are probably solid values and if
they're greater than that then probably
we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we pull out all the
values that are less than or equal to
0.05 for the P values and if we go up
here uh here we go here's our P I knew
it was up here I just wasn't seeing it
correctly so you can probably see
duration that's going to be good amount
0.01 that looks good instance instant
inst rate
which I'm guessing is the percentage
rate or the interest it's trying to say
in inst in interest at the same time so
we have our interest rate and all that
if we come down here we see duration
amount our instant rate age checking
account a13 checking account A14 credit
history a34 savings account e65 these
are our primary features these ones are
related when we look at the data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our SM model or our final logit
model and you'll see here we now have
the X-ray the Y train and then instead
of the X train it's x-train significant
variables right there so all we're doing
is is running this just on the
significant variables in the setup and
we'll go ahead and fit it and you can
see here you can actually double bracket
and do it all in one line up above we
had to do it and the two lines which is
how the um setup is for this particular
module and then we'll go ahead and do a
final legit summary and just see what
that looks like and we can see here
here's our P scores remember they're all
supposed to be under 0.0 underneath the
0.05 these are all under 0.05 you can
see up here different statuses as far as
how it ran it still took six iterations
to go through the data the date and so
forth and now that we have a solid model
and let's if you remember correctly let
me flip back on over here we've done our
data modeling we've created a solid
model and so now we need to actually run
a prediction so that we can interpret
the results and weigh in on that and see
how good they are and so for that I'm
going to go ahead and let's see find it
over here
uh why predict so we have our model that
we created we want to go ahead and
create our y predict and it's based on
our final object and here's the magic
word predict or dot predict
um and so this is where we're going to
come in and actually get our predictions
on here
that our model comes up and remember
we're testing X test is going in there's
our X test and it's only the significant
variables so we've created our model now
we want to push in our test version
that's never seen this data before so
this is all new and then we're just
going to take a random sample to see
what it looks like what do those
predictions look like
in this random sample we're just looking
at 10 of these and you can see here is
the actual number it says 0.08 gives us
a 1.07
this is our probability number which is
I would have to actually look to see
whether higher or lower is better
I'm guessing the closer to
zero the better it is but I'm not
completely sure on that I have to
actually look up on and see what this
particular framework
but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero so I guess this is a
good loan a bunch of defaults and some
good loans that's what it predicts it's
going to come out as now just looking at
the data you know it's confusing this is
you have different models they have
different setup they have the predicted
probability comes out on this and other
models it doesn't so you really need a
tool to dig deeper into the setup to
understand what this means and so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
our predicted values which you can see
right here has an actual predicted
probability
and then we're going to go ahead and
insert on there
from a sample let me just run this
because it'll make a lot more sense we
have our actual value and our predicted
value so this is what we predicted and
this is the actual setup if we just look
at this right off the bat we can see
that we predicted 0 and this was a one
these all came out correct number 332
came out correct 917 was an actual they
were good on their loan and they
predicted it's going to be a default you
start to see that there's some variants
so how do we measure that how do we know
whether our model was any good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and load up a nice graft and we'll use
for our graph we'll import matplot
Library Pi plot
in Seaborn Seabourn sits on matplot
Library
in this matplot Library inline is just
because I'm using Jupiter notebook with
the new version I'm in it doesn't even
need it but I tend to leave it in for
older versions and then we import from
our sklearn metrics this is your scikit
site kit is the main package and sklearn
is how it looks on here and we'll go
ahead and run that so it's nicely loaded
and then we'll go ahead and create a
little routine
in just a moment here
to print this out so we can see what
that looks like
and this metrics is kind of a fun
metrics because it it tells you uh like
how many you have correct on the correct
one
how many you had run on the wrong one
and this top part is just all a draw
routine
so it comes in here and has our actual
and our predicted and it's our CM
metrics it breaks it up puts it into the
heat map the SN heat map gives it some
colors
add some labels and then we go ahead and
show it and we're just going to dump
that in there and run that
and you can spend forever building
Graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit
uh we have bad credit good credit we
have predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here it had
on the good credit
it tells you how well it predicted it
and how many false positive it has and
on our bad credit
here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
were bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
while 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be bad credit
and then we have here we have 188 that
were good credit
uh but the actual value and then it had
61 there were bad credit that it said
were predicted good credit uh so at this
point you look at this and you'd say
well if I'm predicting uh uh these are
this is our good credit here let me flip
this on over here and this is our bad
credit there we go
so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking at and you say okay can we
afford that many defaults after five
years or whatever it is
um and so those are the questions you
start asking is does this model work
good enough to predict whether we should
give these people loans or not you're
always going to have somebody default on
them and again that starts going into
domain uh banking domain something I
don't know very much about clearly I
know whether I default that alone or not
which I don't and I try very hard not to
and then if we're going to draw the
chart which is really nice to have just
a clear visual chart metrics also has
our classification report and you can
see these are just the numbers we are
looking at they let us know the
Precision
uh our f-score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print a
straight out metrics classification
report now we looked at a regression
model uh let's go ahead and look at a
clustering model to see what that looks
like and we'll go ahead and create a new
Troop
python on there
and this is going to be our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and switch on over to my clustering menu
in this case we're going to be looking
at k-means clustering
so let's just put that up here okay
means clustering
now the last one was a regression model
so it figured out coefficients for lines
you can go back to your old euclidean
geometry
or the algebra expression for slope on a
line Y equals MX plus b or whatever
and it goes on from there as far as
finding distances and figuring out the
lines on there this is a little bit
different we talk about clustering it
uses similar ideas but it has to do with
edges two points and how do you figure
out a distance between two points and
what does that mean
now you'll see here we have our pandas
PD our numpy is NP our matplot library
Seaborn sits on matplot libraries we
talked about
um they've added some perimeters here as
far as colors and then we did an inline
for the matplot library again that's not
really necessary even in the new version
of the jupyter notebook in the old
version Jupiter notebook if you didn't
do that it would just kind of hang or
disappear
and then we're going to import some data
it's important to have our data set up
in here
and instead of looking at this and
guessing what the data is
usually you open up the CSV file at this
time let's just go ahead and print it
under the DF head
because really those those text files
are so messy and you look at the DF head
and it's easy to look at
whoops had a path issue there so College
data it's a CSV so automatically knows
there's a DOT CSV on there
and we can see here that they downloaded
from a number of colleges
Abilene Christian University Adelphi
University Adrian College
and then it has whether it's private I'm
guessing yes or no
apps I'm not sure what that is
acceptance rate applications and bidding
and then the acceptance rate enrollment
uh top 10 percent top two five percent
undergrad so on so these are just
statistics based on the college or
college getting into a college
we did before let's explore the data if
you can remember from the chart we were
looking at we're going through our data
Discovery data preparation and
exploratory data analysis so we're
really kind of looking at the data and
what do we have here what came in at
this point the data has already been
prepared we're not doing a whole lot as
far as
getting rid of null values and finding
out whether it's bad data or good data
and that kind of thing and data
Discovery would be figuring out which
data to sit so that we've already done
so we're going to go to the exploratory
data jump into Data modeling and
interpret the results just like we did
with the other one
and we'll go ahead and use the panda
tool to get the info DF you'll see DF
very commonly it just stands for data
frame a lot of people use it as a
generic setup when they import from pan
does
and so we have our info and you can see
right here uh
non-null numbers here's our count so
each one of these has 777 non-null
values
and again here's our type of data we're
dealing with
and if you remember from last time
here's an object
uh
this was our yes or no everything else
looks like it's integer we do have a
float value here integer integer floats
and integers usually they're when you're
running them on a prediction they're
pretty interchangeable in a lot of cases
but whether it's private true or false
that's pretty important on here
the fact that they could probably be
switched to a zero or one is pretty
helpful also and if we're going to look
at all that data we can go ahead and
describe it so there's our data frame
describe
and you have the same thing here's our
count all these should be 777.
we have the mean value so you can
actually look at what our average is
standard deviation
minimum different quartiles 25 50 the
third quartile and so on and of course
our max value on there Min and Max and
as we explore the data we can do a lot
of fun things on here we're going to use
our Seaborn
and we're going to look at a room and
board versus graduation date we're going
to add this is going to be a heat map so
we're going to add whether it's a
private college or not
how it fits the size the aspect ratio
and all that that's what this line is
here Seaborn you can almost do your own
class on matplot library in Seabourn
because there's so many features in
there but when you look at the very
Basics you can throw up some data
and have a nice colorful map set up and
here we have our graduation rate
compared to room and board costs and in
private or public
so you can see that the graduation rate
compared to room and board play
interesting thought how much did I spend
on room and board uh am I going to
graduate the more I spend on room and
board and you can see it numbers go up
there in graduation rate and you can see
that the graduation rate tends to go way
up for your private schools and the room
and board also goes
continues to grow on private schools
kind of thing it's kind of just a fun
heat map
and we can explore other things in our
doing our heat Maps we can look at out
of state whether it's out of state
undergrad private again is one of our
setups on here and you can see here that
um
for undergrad there certainly is a lot
more public schools and whether it's out
of state
interestingly enough the out-of-state
number goes way up how many people
coming from out of state into the school
for the private schools just kind of fun
things if you're trying to figure out
where you're going to go maybe you'd
want to do this for picking a bachelor's
degree or a master's degree or something
or certainly you could also plot this
with fun locations and download
information on
uh tourism sites if you're traveling
that kind of thing you do the same kind
of thing with and we'll go ahead and
throw another map on here
um let me go and run this this is a
slightly different setup on here with
the out of state
and so we're running let's see pull this
up
uh Ben's 20 the bins is each how many uh
bins are you going to split it into and
this is kind of a fun one where you can
see private versus public we have how
many out of state and
I'd have to look this up to see what
they picked on here
oh there we go okay so you can see we
have another chart that has to do with
the out of state and the number of
students coming in and private and
public
uh so a lot of different setups on here
as we dig into the different graphing
so at this point we've just been kind of
looking at uh the graphs on here let's
go ahead and import our cluster our
k-means cluster
and you can see here we have we're going
to call it km I guess for k-means or
maybe it's K means model I always label
mine with model
equals K means in clusters equals two
random State equals 90.
uh and so where when we cluster it we're
only going to Cluster into two groups
that's what this this is meaning here
across the different settings on there
and then we're going to go ahead and fit
and we're going to drop private
uh so we're not we're not going to be
looking at whether it's a private or
public school we're just going to go
ahead and
run the cluster on there
and then once we run the cluster on
there we can actually look at cluster
centers let's go ahead and do that on
this
when we talk about K means let me run
this boom there we go so we have
all these different columns and each of
those columns has the center and we
start looking how the data comes
together on those centers that's what
all these numbers this is the hidden
stuff behind the Clusters on here
and so we can now do maybe we'll create
a little converter here if private
equals yes return one now let's return
zero we're going to run our cluster
private and apply the converter
and then we'll go ahead and print that
out let me just show you what that looks
like so you can see what we're doing
here
go ahead and do uh DF cluster we'll
create a new column on here private
apply converter
and we can see here it creates some
private apps except
we've just added on to our data frame on
here
and we did that so that we can run the
confusion Matrix
make sure we import our confusion Matrix
we're going to do a classification
report confusion Matrix and we'll go
ahead and run this on our clustering
and as you can see here as we're
predictions uh here's our confusion
Matrix up here just like we had on the
other setup where it has how many
false true false false true false and
false false as your accuracy and our
setup on there this is really if you're
looking at which where you want to go
maybe you're looking at where you want
to go in a I think more of a tourism
thing but for colleges this is a great
way for looking for a bachelor's or a
masters coming in here and you can start
finding out which one you want to go to
based on this accuracy whether it's
private or public
or how many graduations are on there and
that brings us to the end of this video
tutorial on machine learning projects by
simply learn if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the
comment section of the video thank you
for watching
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here